OUR FOR HER COLLEAGUES TO COME
DOWN AS SOON AS THEY CAN BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT TO GET- CENTER
GONZALEZ BILLS OUT TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE DOUBLE FOR IT ON THE
SAME DAY IT'S VERY EXCITED. AND
CAN ASSUMING THE COMMITTEE WANTS
TO PASS THE BILL SO. WHICH I'M
CERTAINLY HOPEFUL OF. ALL RIGHT
SO OBVIOUSLY WE'RE CONTINUE TO
TAKE PRECAUTIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
WITH COVER THOUGH THEY HAVE BEEN
CHANGING A LITTLE BIT- WE'RE
WORK TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT BY
PHONE WE CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
GOT A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN
THE DISTANT FULL FREE NUMBER IS. 877-226-8163 THAT'S SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN
THREE SIX. 1-033-736-2833 SO
WE'RE GOING TO MAINTAIN DECORUM
. OUR ALSO HOLDING THESE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HEREIN THE-
STREET BUILDING FOR THOSE
WATCHING T HOME- WE ARE ACROSS
THE STREET FROM THE CAPITOL
WE'RE ASKING ALL MEMBERS TO.
COME ON DOWN. TO ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR
CORPSMAN THINK IN. A VOTE ON
BILLS. NOW WE HAVE THIRTEEN
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA I LIKE
TO ANNOUNCE THAT SB TEN TWENTY
HAS BEEN TAKEN OFF. THE AGENDA
AND WITHDRAWN FROM COMMITTEE.
AND- WITH THAT I'M- IN IT AND I
WANT TO THANK THE MINORITY STAFF
FOR AGREEING LET'S LET'S LET
CENTER GONZALEZ BEGIN
PRESENTATION OF HER BILL THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER ONE IN YOUR AGENDAS-
S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND WE
JUST ASK OUR- OUR FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES- FROM THE COMMITTEE
TO COME UNDER. SO S. B.
THIRTEEN. EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
PRESENTING SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WHICH WILL DANCE EQUITY
MEASURES IN THE STATE'S CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM. CURRENTLY
WHITE HIGHER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO PHONE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS OF COLOR AS
SPORT UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE IN COMMUNITIES
OVERBURDENED BY MISSIONS. THE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM IS
SPECIFICALLY INTENDED TO.
ADDRESS THE EXISTING INEQUITY IN
ACCESS TO CLEAN ZERO EMISSION
AND HYBRID VEHICLES OVER THE
LAST SIX YEARS CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL HAS PLACED. DOESN'T ZERO
EMISSION AND HYBRID VEHICLES
INTO LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
REPLACING OLDER HEAVY POLLUTING.
VEHICLES SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TO
BUILD OFF THE SUCCESS OF THE
EXISTING CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT
THE- OF THIS HEAVILY
OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAM MUST ALSO
BE MADE MORE ACCESSIBLE- IT
WILL. LOWER COSTS AT THE COST TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
EXEMPTING CARS BOUGHT AND SOLD
THROUGH THE PROGRAM FROM STATE
SALES TAX WEAVING THREE POINT
NINETY FOUR PERCENT. TAX TO MAKE
THE PROGRAM MORE AFFORDABLE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY I
HAVE ALLEN ADDS. LEGISLATIVE
OFFICER FOR THE BAY AREA.
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT THE
FIRST WE'LL START WITH BILL
MCGOVERN POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR. GIVE
MUCH. AND AN MR CHAN BILL MCKAY
WITH COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM
HAS BEEN A SUCCESSFUL ONE. IN
THE DISTRICTS WHERE IT'S BEEN
IMPLEMENTED. AND WE'VE BEEN
TRYING FOR MANY YEARS TO
DEMOCRATIZE THE ELECTRIC CAR. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE SUFFERING
THE WORST IMPACTS OF AIR
POLLUTION AND CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HISTORIC DISINVESTMENT. HAVE
ACCESS TO THE CLEANEST
TRANSPORTATION AND THAT'S WHAT
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL DOES. THIS
BILL WOULD MAKE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE PROGRAM AND
I THINK IT REALLY WOULD RESPOND
TO. SOME POINTS WERE MADE LAST
YEAR BY THE UCLA LUSKIN CENTER
FOR INNOVATION. WHICH FOUND THAT
THE INTENT AND EFFICACY OF OUT
REACH TO POTENTIAL PARTICIPANTS
IS CRUCIAL TO ENSURE BOTH
PROCEDURAL AND DISTRIBUTIVE
EQUITY. AND RECOMMENDED THE
INSTITUTION OF ADDITIONAL
EVIDENCE BASED TARGETS FOR
ADVANCING DISTRIBUTIVE- BUT YOU
. THINK THIS BILL WILL HELP MOVE
US IN THE XIN AND BREAK DOWN
BARRIERS. TO PARTICIPATION IN
THIS IMPORTANT EQUITY BASED
PROJECT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CARE ALLEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M ALLEN APPS WITH
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT TESTIFYING
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND TO
EXPLAIN THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM IN
THE BAY AREA. TO SUPPORT EQUITY
IN ADVANCING A CLEAN CAR FUTURE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL IS RETIRING
REPLACE PROGRAM INCOME QUALIFIED
RESIDENTS AND COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED AT
POLLUTION CAN TURN AN OLDER
VEHICLE. GET AN INCENTIVE TO
PURCHASE OR LEASE A HYBRID PLUG
IN HYBRID ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE THAT
IS EIGHT YEARS OLDER NEWER.
PARTICIPANTS MUST HAVE INCOME
THAT IS LESS THAN OR EQUAL
24100% FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
CONSUMERS OUGHT TO HAVE THE
OPTION RECEIVE LOCAL THING FOR
MOBILITY OPTIONS THAT ALLOW
GRANTEES. DEV CARD WEBER OUR A
ANSWERED THE PUBLIC PROTECTION
GRANT SLOW BILLETE OPTION CAN
ALSO USE THESE FUNDS TO.
ELECTRIC BY IN THE- IN THE THREE
THAT THERE. THE HAS MINISTERED
THIS PROBE WE HAVE. ABSOLUTELY
TWENTY FIVE B. PURCHASE. WITH
TWO THIRDS OF THOSE OCCURRING IN
OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES CURRENTLY WE AVERAGE
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED VEHICLE
PURCHASE THIS MONTH. OLD
INCOMING VEHICLE CHOSEN
DETERMINES MOUNT. RISK PROGRAM
WITH GRANT. FROM. HUNDRED A
DOLLARS TO ON IT. YOUR GOAL. BUT
THE CLEAN FOR VEHICLES KERN
COSTS TWENTY THE DOLLARS. THE
AVERAGE CARS FOR ALL IN CENTER
IS A FIVE DOLLAR. AN AVERAGE LOW
SIGNING FOR. A REPLACE VEHICLE
IS FOURTEEN HUNDRED FOURTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THUS IT STILL REQUIRES A
SIGNIFICANT OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSE FOR MOST ELIGIBLE ACT
APPLICANTS. PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE OR LIMITING
THE TAX BURDEN ON INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROGRAM
WOULD HELP EXPAND THE APPLICANT
POOL REDUCE PARTICIPANT COSTS.
AND SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S EQUITY
IN ZERO EMISSION GOALS. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO ALSO DIRECTS
CARPET COORDINATE WITH AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND
LOCAL NONPROFIT AND COMMUNITY.
TO IDENTIFY. AND QUEEN CREEK
CARS FUNDING AND DEVELOP
OUTREACH PRO AND METRICS TO
ASSESS THE SUCCESS OF THE
PROGRAM. FURTHER SUPPORTING
EQUITY WITHIN THIS PROGRAM WE
THANK SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE BEEN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
LET'S GO TO THE PHONES AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO- I'M SORRY
THE FOLKS HERE IN PERSON I'M SO
SORRY I APOLOGIZE COME ON UP TO
MEET AND- EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR REID AT S. ON
BEHALF OF VALLEY CLEAN AIR NOW
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE BILL
THANK YOU IN SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU READ CHRISTIAN. YEP CYNTHIA
SALAD IN SUPPORT I'M WITH
INDIVISIBLE GREEN TEAM AND
SACRAMENTO ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ASSOCIATION GREAT THANK YOU WE
WOULD ALSO WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO. OKAY
HOW BOUT THE PHONE LINES-
MODERATOR YOU WANNA GO TO THE
PHONE LINES EVEN ONE OF THEIR
SUPPORT FOR SB THIRTY NEED TO.
IN PARTICIPANTS ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. WE DO
HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL GO
TO LINE THIRTY SEVEN ZERO AT.
THANK YOU AFTER HARTMAN ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. AT THE TIME THERE'S NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY LET'S
GO TO OPPOSITION ANYONE'S RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO- I DON'T I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE ANY REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AND I KNOW THAT I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY- FOLKSY
VERSION IN A TO COME SPEAK I'VE
MATTER DO YOU WANT TO- PLEASE
GIVE ME ONE CHECK TO SEE IF
ANYONE HAS RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
SB THIRTY TWO- TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. CAN
ONE ZERO PROPOSITIONS. ID ONE IN
OUR QUEUE TO BE JUST A MOMENT.
HELLO LINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GENOTOXIC FOUR TICKETS
HELLO CAN VALLEY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE. OKAY LET'S GO TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
CERTAINLY VERY SUPPORT OF THIS-
CINEMA CASKEY YEAH I GUESS. I
JUST WANT TO KNOW. THE AUTHORS
ON PAGE SIX AND SEVEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT FEATURES
THIS IS YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY A
GROWING PROGRAM AS START UP INTO
DISTRICTS WITH THE FIVE. AND WE
SEE HOW THE- THE SOUTH COAST
THOSE THINGS WITH THE TEN NINETY
NINE AND IN OTHERS. ALL THE AIR
DISTRICTS OUR LOCAL. DOING
DIFFERENT PROCEDURES SAID TO
FIND OUT WHO'S ELIGIBILITY
ELIGIBLE. RIVERSIDE HOW HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO- GENERALIZE IT
ALERTS ARE CONSOLIDATE THINGS OR
REORGANIZING THAT EVERYBODY'S
DOING THE SAME THING BECAUSE ALL
THIRTY FIVE THESE DISTRICTS OKAY
WITH WITH INCREDIBLE INDULGENCE
I JUST WOULD LOVE TO ESTABLISH A
CORNBALL QUICKLY BECAUSE WE DO
IT WITH ME THANK TERMS ARE BILL
I'M SO SORRY SEVERAS AS I WOULD
NORMALLY DO THIS BUT WE'RE IN A
TIGHT SPOT. I AM ESPECIALLY
PLEASED PLEASED TO CLEAR UP
PLEASE THAT STOPS A QUORUM ALLEN
HERE BATES DOLLY SALLY HERE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE SKINNER
STERN. BY CASKEY HERE. OKAY WE
DO HAVE A VEGAS DOLLARS I LET'S
BE YEAH I'M I DO APOLOGIZE.
WHICH FEATURES THAT NOW BEING
USED AT SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
REGIONAL AIR QUALITY WORDS YOU'D
LIKE WHAT DO YOU THINK CAN BE
EMULATED N THE OTHERS AS WE GO
FROM. TWO TO FIVE TO THIRTY FIVE
YOUR DISTRICTS. SAY THAT AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE WHAT SPECIFIC PROGRAM
FEATURES YOU KNOW SOME SOME
PROGRAM SAY BRINGING YOUR TEN
NINETY NINE AND WE'RE GONNA SHOW
THAT YOU GOT PROOF THAT YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE- WE GOT THIRTY FIVE
DISTRICTS THE ROLE. INDEPENDENT
AND ALL HAVE THEIR DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
SOPHISTICATION SALES SOUTH COAST
IS BEGAN A BEERY IS AGGRESSIVE.
I ACCEPT- UP AT THE AT THE OTHER
LITTLE ONES AS WE MOVE OUT TO
THOSE FOLKS WHAT WHAT PROGRAMS
WHAT DO YOU THINK WAS WORKING.
AS WELL THAT THIS IS YOU KNOW
THIS IS JUST ONE ISSUE ON- THE
STATE SALES TAX THAT WE'VE
TALKED TO ME AT LENGTH AND NOW
AND ARE. WORKING GROUP ABOUT
WHAT TO BE REFORMED IN TERMS OF
EVEN LANGUAGE ACCESS THE- THE
TEN EIGHTY NINE FORM IS VERY
HODGEPODGE DEPENDING ON WHICH
YOUR DISTRICT YOU GO TO BUT-
THAT IS A FEDERAL ISSUE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT I'M JUST SORT
OF HOLISTICALLY TO SEE IF WE
CAN. REFORM THAT SETS MARC MORE
CONSISTENT- BUT I WOULD ALSO
DEFERRED TO- THE STRAPS YOU
MISTER MCEVERS. WEALTH THERE'S
ANY ADDITIONAL- INPUT FROM THEM
AND WHAT ELSE BE DONE THE FULL
LOCAL AIR. SURE THING JUST
BRIEFLY I MEAN I THINK THEY'RE
THEY'RE SOME OUTREACH TECHNIQUES
THAT ARE THAT ARE WORKING WELL
IN SUMMER DISTRICTS THAT COULD
PROBABLY BE EXPORTED TO OTHERS
PARTICULARLY. THOSE THAT ARE THE
MOST COMMUNITY BASED THAT ARE
REACHING SOME OF THE HARDEST TO
REACH POPULATIONS LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE FARMWORKERS. UNITIES AND
I THINK YOU KNOW THIS BILL
DOESN'T PRE JUDGE BECAUSE IT
WOULD ESTABLISH A PROCESS FOR
EVALUATION. BUT I THINK THERE
ARE SUCCESS STORIES TO COULD BE
EMULATED YEAH AND SOMETHING IS
NOT WORKING IS THAT THAT A
COUPLE WHERE DISTRICTS. ISSUE
TEN NINETY NINE SO THESE- CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL REWARDS ARE BEING
TREATED AS TAXABLE INCOME AND IN
OUR OPINION THEY SHOULD NOT BE-
THE CVR. IS NOT TREATED AS TAX
INCOME SO THAT'S A ANY
CONSISTENCY THIS QUITE GLARING
RIGHT WHAT THE NEW. NEW RULES
FROM THE AIRPORT IN FEBRUARY ON
THE CPR CARE SAID SHRINKING
WORLD OF PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE I'D- BACK I DON'T KNOW
IF THERE'S ANYBODY WHO'S
ELIGIBLE RECEIVE THE RP DECIDE
ELIGIBLE FOR CREDIT CARDS FOR
ALL. MY HOPE THERE IS THERE
THERE'S- ACTUALLY IT'S A- INTERN
FOR THOU DOLLAR. VERSUS A
HUNDRED DOLLARS SAID YOU KNOW SO
THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE.
THAT CONSISTENCY THAT IS THAT'S
NOT THIS BILL THAT'S ANOTHER
BILL RIGHT. OKAY YEAH I GUESS.
MY CAN AS A IT'S SPREAD OUT IN
THE- THAT IS THAT YES GOOD TO DO
OUTRAGE AND GET THE OUTREACH
MULTIPLE. FOR YOU STILL HAVE
HAVE SOME CONSISTENCY ST ON WHAT
THE THEY DID THE ELIGIBILITY
WHAT BECAUSE I THINK. THERE'S A-
IF THERE'S A CRITICISM IS JUST
WERE BEEN TOO CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT
WE DON'T WANT SOMEBODY WHO'S NOT
QUALIFIED TO GET THE TO GET THE
INCENTIVES. AND THEN FIND OUT
LATER ON THAT DAY THAT THEY OWE
IT AND I DON'T. KNOW IF THAT'S
WELL THAT'S- THAT'S MY PERSONAL
PERSPECTIVE OF HOW- SLOPE.
THINGS HAVE GONE OKAY- YEAH D.
AND THE SALES TAX IS AT THE
POINT OF SALE RIGHT THAT'S YES
THAT'S THAT'S A THAT'S AND WE
CAN WORK WITH THE DEALERS THAT
THEY WOULD STILL BE A SET UP AND
THEN AND THEN TECHNICALLY THEY
WOULD JUST GO WITH THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD RIGHT TO WE PAY THE
SOURCE SAID WHAT VEHICLE SESSION
RIGHT THERE'S NOT. WE DON'T WANT
TO MARK THIS UP WITH THE AIRPORT
IS NOT GONNA HANDLE SALES TAX
THAT SHOULD BE A DIRECT
TRANSFER. BECAUSE THEY DON'T
THEY DON'T TOUCH IT ANYWAY. HI
I'M OF THE BILL GREAT THANK YOU
. AND OUR DEALERS ARE IN SUPPORT
AS WELL SO YEP THEY'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE BILL. OKAY THE
MEDIA CENTER STERN. JUST A QUICK
COMMENT BUILDING ON THE MY GOOD
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS COMMENTS
BUT- REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD WORK FROM
EARLY DAYS- WITH SOME OF YOUR
BILL SPONSORS HERE ON GETTING
THIS PROGRAM UP AND RUNNING AND
- I JUST WANT THIS BILL TO BE IN
LAW A YEAR AGO AND UP AND
RUNNING I MEAN THAT THAT'S MY
FRUSTRATION IS THAT. THIS THIS
ASSESSMENT I MEAN WHAT WE ASK
THE- BOARD TO DO IN TERMS OF
SETTING SPECIFIC GOALS. THEN THE
PERFORMANCE FROM THE AIR
DISTRICTS- YOU KNOW SOUTH COAST
IS NOT AS GOOD AT SELLING CARS
IN LEASING CARS IS LIKE CARVE.
CAR COMPANIES- AND IT SHOWS IT'S
NOT I MEAN THEY'RE GOOD
REGULATORS OR OR AND THEY- WE
WANT THEM TO DO MORE. OF THAT
AIR QUALITY REGULATION BUT IN
TERMS OF ACTUAL OUT REGION
SENDING OUT POSTCARDS OR
WHATEVER IT MAY BE TEN DEGREES
MISTER MCGOVERN I WOULD JUST SAY
FOR THE FUTURE. YOU KNOW. REALLY
CENTRALIZED TOP DOWN METRICS
WITH. LAKE SET WITH EASY
ACCESSIBLE FINANCING AND
INSTRUMENTS THAT ARE GOING TO
WORK FOR EVERYBODY AND NOT BE
PATCHWORK BUT THEN VERY DEEP
DIVE ON COMMUNITY BASED VERY
VERY GRASSROOTS TRINITY OUTREACH
SITE. BECAUSE BY A CAR IS A BIG
THING. TO DO AND IF YOU DON'T
KNOW A LOT OF MONEY IT'S A IT'S
USUALLY THE BIGGEST ASSET YOU
OWN ADDRESS. AND SO WE KNOW
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET OVER A BIG
HUMP HERE BUT I THINK. YEAH I
JUST APPLAUD YOU FOR PUT YOUR
SHOULDER THE WHEEL ON THIS AND-
HE SAID TO SUPPORT- SIGN ON IF
APPROPRIATORS THEIR AMENDMENTS
COMING THROUGH I'D LOVE TO SIGN
ON BUT- YET THIS IS. BEEN A LONG
TIME COMING SO THIS IS THE YEAR
I THINK WE GOT TO. FIX THIS ALL
UP AND SCALE SO I'D SAY NOT SOON
ENOUGH. OKAY ALL RIGHT WE'VE
BEEN A MUCH OF THE MEASURE BEEN
MOVED THAT SAN WE LIKE TO CALL.
ON IT THANK. THERMIC AVENUE
MISTER ABSTRUSE HERE EVERYONE
SPOKEN TO. I LOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM- TO CONTINUE
THIS. DISTRICT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK AN IBM SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT. AS VEHICLE. ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE ALLEN. AYE ALLEN AYE
BATES. DOLLY GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
ICE SKINNER STERN AYE STERN AYE
AYE CASKEY AYE CASKEY AYE. BILL
HAS FOUR VOTES. OKAY GREAT ALL
RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA I ALSO WE
LEAVE IT OPEN EARLY AND CLOSE IT
TO SENATE OVER IS THAT IS DO WE
WANT TO CLOSE ARE ALL.
SO I'M- OUR THOUGHT IS THAT WE
CLOSE THE WRONG EVEN THOUGH
DOESN'T MEAN YOU KNOW JUST
BECAUSE OTHER PEOPLE IN OTHER
COMMITTEES BUT IT REALLY DEPENDS
ON IF YOU'RE CALLING TO MILLIE
I'M HAPPY TO KEEP THE ROLL UP
AND- IT JUST DEPENDS ON WHAT WE
CAN. WE CAN CLOSE IT. WHEN YOU
NEED TO MOVE. SO CLOSER YEAH
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE ON SB THIRTY NEED TO
OBVIOUSLY MEMBERS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY VOTE ON THIS BILL
LATER ON IN THE PRICE STRUCTURE
I ASKED THAT THE MEASURE BE
EXPEDITED TO THE GOVERNMENT
FINANCE COMMITTEE- WITHOUT
WITHOUT FURTHER DELAY YEAH SEE
YOU'RE MAKING A DIFFERENCE
SENATORS GOOD. ALL RIGHT SO WE
WILL WE'LL CLOSER- EXPEDITED ITS
DELIVERY I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS BUT MASON WAS GONNA
DRINK A GATORADE BEFORE THEY GO
OR A COKE- OKAY. SO I. NOW THE
FUNNY THING IS THOUGH I MEAN THE
ISSUE IS I SUPPOSE THAT- WE
DON'T HAVE OTHER AUTHORS HERE AT
LET'S HAVE THE SINISTER AND YOU
WANT TO. WE WANT TO PRESENT- I
HAS BEEN PRESENTED BY DODD- OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR-
ITEM TWELVE A- SB ELEVEN SIXTY
FOUR YEAH SURE EVEN THOUGH- HOW
CAN PEOPLE. HUCAL OKAY- THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS- I'M
PRESENTING SP FORTINO FOR- FOUR
X- BEGIN MY PRESENTATION WHEN
IT. EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS LIST
ON PAGE FIVE. AND THEN I ALSO
UNDERSTAND I DO THE TIMING THAT
AMENDMENT WELL IF YOU MADE IN
THE SUBSEQUENT COMMITTEE WHICH
MY COMMITTEE OVER AND SENT OUT
TO RESEARCH AND WATER SO- JUST
WANNA MAKE THAT NOTE AND THEN
ALSO WANT TO. I'VE HAD REALLY
GOOD DISCUSSIONS WITH- COMMITTEE
STAFF- STAKEHOLDERS AND- THE
CHAIR IN PARTICULAR- AND I JUST
WANT TO COMMIT NOW TO. SOME
ALTERNATIVE A PRECONDITION THAT
WILL MORE NARROWLY CONSTRAIN
THIS BILL TO STILL ADEQUATELY
PROTECT OAK WOODLANDS BUT TO
REALLY EMPHASIZE HERE IS A MAP
BY STATE OR LOCAL AGENCIES- THAT
ARE CRITICAL HABITAT LINKAGE OR
NATURAL RESOURCES OR OTHERWISE
RELATED TO BIODIVERSITY AND
CONSERVATION SO I'M I'M HOPING
WE CAN WORK THROUGH SOME OF THAT
AND I APPRECIATE HEARING FROM
THE OPPOSITION- COMING FORWARD
AND HAVING THAT DISCUSSION BUT
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THAT
SETTLED IN SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCE AND WATER SO. THE BILL
DOESN'T FEEL TOO OPEN ENDED FOR
FOLKS BUT I JUST WANTED YOU KNOW
VERY SIMPLY SAY THAT- RIGHT NOW.
MORE THAN 30% OF PRE SETTLEMENT
OAK WOODLANDS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CLEARED THEY'RE GONE- AND WE
MADE WAY FOR VERY IMPORTANT USES
LIKE AGRICULTURE AND- YES- YES
NO CLOSE SHOULD I NOT BE
PRESENTING THIS TO WHAT THE
OTHER ONE. OKAY WHEN YOU DECIDE
- I DON'T HAVE TO WE CAN DO IT
IN A DIFFERENT ORDER- THE
EDUCATE HERB SOME MORE MOREOVER
CALIFORNIA TREES ARE THREATENED
BY DISEASE- INVASIVES AND THIS
IS REALLY PROVIDING A CRUCIAL
STEP IN STANDARDIZING
PROTECTIONS WE'VE SEEN A SORT OF
PATCHWORK OF PERMITTING AND- AND
A LACK OF RECOGNITION FOR THE
BROADER ECOSYSTEM BENEFITS OF
OAK WOODLANDS- WE KNOW THAT IN
CERTAIN CASES THIS ONE TO ONE
OAK TREE MITIGATION POLICY JUST
DOESN'T WORK BECAUSE IF YOU'RE-
YOU'RE CUTTING DOWN I'M- THAT
PIECE OF EQUIPMENT IN THE MIDDLE
OF A HABITAT AREA AND RE
PLANTING A SAPLING TWENTY MILES
AWAY- IT REALLY DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING FOR THE BROADER.
BENEFITS IN THE MITIGATION
PATTERNS THAT WE'RE HOPING TO
ACHIEVE- THROUGH THAT ECOSYSTEM
SERVICE THAT WE'RE GETTING FROM
AN OAK WOODLAND AND SO RIGHT NOW
THE BILL HAS A THREE. THE
SPECIFIES THE ON THE REMOVAL OF
A CERTAIN THRESHOLD THE TREES TO
TRIGGER THAT SIGNIFICANT EFFECT
ON THE ENVIRONMENT. BUT BUT I
DID SHARE IN MY OPENING REMARKS
THAT WE'RE INTERESTED IN
CONSTRAINING THAT ONLY WITHIN
AREAS THAT HAVE THAT SORT OF
HABITAT. CONNECTIVITY VALUE- SO
THE ILL THOUGH DOES NOT STOP
DEVELOPMENT COUNTRY TO SOME OF
THE- THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS
IT WOULD NOT HOLD DEVELOPMENT
EVEN IF YOU DID HAVE- OAK
WOODLANDS ON YOUR PROPERTY. I'M
THERE ARE VARIOUS MITIGATION
MEASURES THAT ARE OFFERED FOR
THAT CONSERVATION- CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS. I'M AN APPROPRIATE
PLANTING. A NUMBER- AND
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM AS OPPOSED
TO JUST A ONE FOR ONE- AND OTHER
MEDICATIONS CAN BE DEVELOPED BY
LEAD AGENCIES BUT ONE TO ONE
TREE REPLACEMENT ALONE WE THAT
WE THINK CAN ONLY FULFIL- ABOUT
HALF THE TOTAL MITIGATION
EFFORTS JUST GIVEN THE TIME SPAN
OF THESE TREES AND THE VALUE
THEY PROVIDE AND THAT THE AGENT
TAKES TO ACTUALLY GET A SAPLING
TO A FULL OF WHEAT WE KNOW THE
THIS IS THE STORY OF. AN ACORN
FALLING- AND BECOMING A MIGHTY
OAK BUT IT SEEK WAS TIMELINE
ISN'T THE SAME AS NATURE'S AND
SO- WE THINK IS THIS MEASURES
CRITICAL TO PROTECTING WHAT
REMAINING HABITAT WE HAVE LEFT
ESPECIALLY IN THE WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE AND WE WANNA BE
RESPONSE TO THE NEEDS OF VARIOUS
LOCALITIES SO- ME TODAY HERE IS
DANCE OVER FROM THE INJURED
HABITATS LEE CALLING IN REMOTELY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I
THINK ALSO. NICK JENSEN MAYBE
HEAR FROM NAY TO SAY. THANK WHEN
IS PROCEED.
MOTOR YOU COULD YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP THE- THE FOLKS WHO ARE HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN OH FOUR I GUESS DAN
SILVER IN NICK JENSEN. I DO NOT
SHOW EITHER OF THEM HAVE
THOUSAND YES OKAY ALL RIGHT. DO
WE HAVE- FOLKS ONE OF VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL- IN PERSON
HERE OR ON ONLINE ON ON ON THE
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR. HIM FOR
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU
LIKE TO SPEAK WITH SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY
ALL RIGHT- LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION- SILVIA FERRARI JOHN
KENNEDY I UNDERSTAND WE'RE
GONNA. RAISE OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SILVIO FOR OUR IN BATH
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION- AFTER HEARING WHAT
SENATOR STERN SAID ABOUT
AMENDMENTS COMING THE BILL WE
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
BUT I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY GET AN INVITATION AND
TO WORK ON THOSE WITH YOU AND
FIGURE OUT WHERE THIS CAN
POTENTIALLY GO. I'LL JUST
SUMMARIZE OUR BIG THREE CONCERNS
NUMBER ONE SETTING A STATE WIDE
LEVEL OF SIGNIFICANCE- THAT IS
VERY CONCERNING BECAUSE YOU ALL
KNOW THERE IS NO SINGLE PART OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IS THE SAME
WHETHER IT'S- CLIMATIC
GEOGRAPHIC TOPOGRAPHIC HABITAT
AREAS WE DON'T HAVE TO PARTS OF
THE STATE BETTER SAME SO. WE'VE
EVEN SEEN. CONTACTS V. M. T. B.
AND ONE OF THEM EVEN AGENCIES
LIKE OPR HAVE RESISTED SETTING A
STATEWIDE LEVEL A SIGNIFICANT SO
WE CAUTION YOU AND WOULD LIKE TO
WORK ON THAT AS WELL. NUMBER
TWO- WE GOTTA HAVE LEAD AGENCIES
REALLY DRIVING THE SHIP ON. I
KNOW THOSE AREAS THE REMOVING
THEM FROM THAT IS TROUBLESOME-
AND LASTLY AND POSSIBLY MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE BILL STRIKES HE
WON. AND HE WON IS AN EXISTING
PROVISION THAT INSURERS AT WHAT
THE MITIGATION MEASURES ARE THAT
THE- LEAD AGENCY COMES UP WITH
WHEN WE COMPLY WITH THEM WE ARE
CONSIDERED TO BE IN COMPLIANCE
FOR DEEMED. FOR PORTION APPLIES
THE OAK AND OAK WOODLANDS-
MEDICATION THAT IS A PROTECTION
THAT HAS BEEN IN THERE IT HAS
WORKED WELL WE HAVE NOT HEARD OF
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THAT SO WE
WOULD ASK THE KIND OF THOSE
THREE THINGS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
KINDA BE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING JOHN KENNEDY WITH A
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THIRTY
NINE WORLD COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE POSE SB FOURTEEN OH
FOUR BECAUSE AS IT WAS SAID
IMPOSES A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
REGARDLESS OF LOCAL DIVERSITY-
AND A DIVERSITY OF COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND OPENS
THE DOOR TO EVEN MORE SEQUEL
LITIGATION OAKS IN WOODLANDS-
ABUNDANT THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND NOT AT SERIOUS RISK OF
CONVERSION AND MOST OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THERE ARE OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION TREES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE SPREAD OUT OVER
FIFTEEN MILLION ACRES OF OAK
WOODLANDS AND OAK FOREST AND YET
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES AN
ARBITRARY STANDARD OF THREE
TREES THAT ARE IMPACTED AND CUT
DOWN REGARDLESS OF THE SIZE OF
THE PROJECT REGARDLESS OF THE
NATURE OF THE PROJECT WHETHER
IT'S A HOUSING PROJECT SAFETY
PROJECT THE PARKER IMPROVE
PROJECT ANYTHING. AND AS WAS
SAID SEQUEL- ALREADY- REQUIRES
COUNTIES TO MITIGATE THE
PROJECT'S IMPACTS ON OAK
WOODLANDS. SO WE DON'T SEE THE
NEED FOR THE BILL WE DON'T SEE
THE FLAWS WITH THE EXISTING
PROGRAM- AND WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL
ELIMINATES A VERY IMPORTANT SAFE
HARBOR. SO IF WE DO GO IN AND
REQUIRE MEDICATION FOR PROJECTS
IMPACTS ON THE ENVIRONMENT.
THOSE PROJECTS OF AN INSULATED
FROM SEQUEL LITIGATION
CHALLENGING THE ADEQUACY OF THE-
EVALUATION AND ADEQUACY OF THOSE
MEDICATION REQUIREMENTS. THIS
BILL THROWS THAT OUT THE DOOR
AND ALLOWS GROUPS TO COME IN AND
CHALLENGE THE ADEQUACY OF OUR
DETERMINATION AND THE ADEQUACY
OF OUR MITIGATION MEASURES.
THEREBY EXTENDING PROJECT
TIMELINES INCREASED. OBJECTING
THEM TO LITIGATE THESE ARE THE
THAT WE CAN'T. SO LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN THE ANALYSIS I
THINK HELP BY FOCUSING LESS ON.
THE AGENCIES AND THE PUBLIC
RIGHT RIGHT THANK YOU YEAH. YEP
OKAY. THANK YOU MRS FOR IN
KENNEDY- OKAY LET'S. LET'S GO TO
THE ANYONE HERE IN PERSON WANTS
TO RAISE CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
IS SB FORTINO FOR. HI FOLKS ON
THE PHONE LINES ID LIKE TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT ABOUT IT FOURTEEN
FOR VOICE OPPOSITION. MODERATOR
GEN THE GERMAN THE FEEL JUST CAN
. OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEIR OWN. FIRST WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DOUG CARSTENS
I'M ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I PRESSED ONE ZERO TOO LATE
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR IT PLEASE. THANK YOU
. AND WE HAVE LINE EIGHTEEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS KELLY
CALIFORNIA REALTORS IN
OPPOSITION AS THE BILL CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. YES. AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU OKAY GREAT- OKAY
. WITH RESPECT TO THE COMMITTEE
I WANTED TO START BY MAKING A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS I MEAN I
THINK- YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE I'VE I
WANT TO START BY SAYING AND THAT
I. TOTALLY UNDERSTAND UNDERSTAND
AND APPRECIATE THE DESIRE TO
PROTECT OAK WOODLANDS AND
THEY'RE VERY VERY SPECIAL PART
OF OUR- ECOLOGY IN OUR
BIODIVERSITY HERE. IN CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY- LIVE IN IN WHILE I'M
UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND WEST
SACRAMENTO- IN THE SOUTHERN
PORTION OF A SACRAMENTO WHERE
THERE'S A BEAUTIFUL OAK WOODLAND
THAT WAS KIND OF. THEIR CLEARLY
I'VE GOT AN OLD GROWTH OAK IN MY
BACKYARD. AND AND SO NICE ABOUT
HOW HOW HOW THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PRESERVE SO MUCH OF THE WOMEN
EVEN AS THEY BUILD HOMES IN THE
IN THE AREA. HI I'M- SO I THINK
THAT'S A VERY LOFTY GOAL I THINK
THEY'RE A GOOD CALL I DO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE A WHOLE SLEW OF I
THINK THIS THREE. OAK TREE. I
AND NUMBER JUST DOES SEEM A BIT
ARBITRARY. I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THAT COMES FROM YEAH FIVE TREES
TWO TREES WHAT WHAT WHAT'S
SIGNIFICAN ABOUT THREE- AND I DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
THRESHOLD ITS POTENTIAL IMPACTS
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS- MISTER. MISTER
AUTHOR- TO EXPLORE DURING THE
APPLICATION THE THREE TREE
THRESHOLD ON TO CERTAIN AREAS OF
THE STATE ESPECIALLY AREAS THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO HABITAT LINKAGE.
AT THE VERY LEAST YOU ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED IS.
HAVING A SUPPLY NATIONAL
RECREATION AREAS- I THINK THAT
WOULD BE ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE
GIVEN THAT LOGICAL SENSITIVITY
THOSE REGIONS- I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT TRYING TO
LIMIT TO. ARE IS CRITICAL TO
HAVE THAT LINK IS NOT RESOURCES-
BUT I STILL THINK THAT THE- THE
CURRENT CONTEXT AT THE END OF
THE WITH THE WEIGHTS FRAME THIS
IS A BIT TOO BROAD. I'M IN IT
BUT I BUT I DO THINK THERE'S A
OF A REAL KERNEL OF VALUE HERE-
AN ACORN. PERHAPS OF VALUE- AND
SO I'M I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY THAT
SUPPORTED TODAY AND YOU KNOW WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE GONNA KEEP
WORKING ON IT IT'S GOING TO GO
TO NATURAL RESOURCES- WHERE I
SWEAR I SAID- BUT I DO I DO WANT
TO JUST VOICE. I'D BUY GET WILL
BE LET ME ASK YOU. WHERE DO WE
COME UP WITH THE THREE. THREE
OAK TREES LIKE WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT DID THAT NUMBER COME FROM.
I'M SORRY SO YOU'RE ASKING THAT
THE THRESHOLD IN THE BILL YEAH-
BASED ON SOME MINIMUM THRESHOLD
THAT HAS TO BE THERE BECAUSE
THEY'RE USING ONE TO ONE TO IS A
DEATH BY A THOUSAND CUTS. THE
ENTIRE OAK WOODLAND ECOSYSTEM OF
THE GREATER LA AREA. SO THE
CURRENT MITIGATION AND DESIGN
REVIEW BOARD PROCESS WITHIN THE
CITY AND THE COUNTY YOUR- ARE
USING- WOULD TREAT TREAT- SORT
OF MITIGATION PROCESS THAT THAT
LETS YOU SAID SHIRLEY CHIP AWAY
AT AN INTERCONNECTED. LINKED
HABITAT SYSTEM SO WE HAD TO PICK
SOME THRESHOLD THAT DIDN'T ALLOW
YOU TO JUST ONE FOR ONE. YOUR
PROCESS AND PUT A YOU KNOW
REPLACE A HUNDRED YEAR OAK WITH
A- ONE YEAR OLD SAPLINGS GONNA
TAKE A HUNDRED MORE YEARS AND
REYES WHOSE ALL THE FIRES OWN
BENEFITS IN THE PROCESS SO. WE
HAD TO PICK SOME THRESHOLD OVER
ONE YEAH WE WANT TO BE MODEST
ABOUT THAT BUT- RECOGNIZING YOU
KNOW I AM COMMITTED TO WHAT THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES SUGGEST
THOUGH IN TERMS OF. EITHER
FINDING ALTERNATIVE THRESHOLD-
IN TERMS OF NUMBER FOUR- TO THE
TO THE OPPOSITION'S BATON
TESTIMONY. YOU KNOW FINDING SOME
KIND OF NARROWING THAT WE CAN
FOCUS ON. WHAT IS SORT OF A
LOCALLY DRIVEN- SENSITIVITIES SO
NOT TRYING TO OVERRIDE
NECESSARILY THE INPUT. OF A OF A
LEAD AGENCY EUROPA LEAGUE
JURISDICTION A COUNTY OR CITY.
BUT INSTEAD. MY ON EITHER
LOCALLY ADOPTED MAPS OR
STATEWIDE MAPS THAT HIGHLIGHT
THESE AREAS OF CONCERN SO WE ARE
INSTANCE IN OUR AREA WE'VE GOT A
HABITAT LINKAGE MAP. RIGHT
THAT'S IDENTIFIED PARCELS
THROUGH SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY THROUGHOUT THE
REGION. THAT ARE BETTER. AT RISK
AND SO IF YOU TAKE THREE OAK
WOODLAND OAK YOU KNOW TREES OUT
OF THAT SORT OF INTERCONNECTED
WOODLAND YOU ARE GOING TO DO
DAMAGE. HOWEVER IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN AN ISOLATED
AREA THAT'S CUT OFF FROM OTHER.
YOU KNOW IT IS NOT WITHIN A AREA
BY DIVERSITY NOT WITHIN IT ASHA
NOT WITHIN COASTAL ZONE NOT
WITHIN A HABITAT LINKAGE MAP.
SORT OF SITTING ON ITS OWN WE
DON'T WANT AND WE WANT TO
TRIGGER- A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
FOR THAT KIND OF DEVELOPMENT
THAT KIND OF PROPERTY SO. I
THINK BY MAKING THAT DELINEATION
IN THESE AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE
GONNA WORK ON WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE HERE AND WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND I WOULD READILY
INVITE- TO MR FURRIES POINT- AND
MR KENNEDY'S POINT. PLEASE COME
TO THE TABLE I KNOW WE MET
INITIALLY YESTERDAY REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT DISCUSSION BUT-
WE- DON'T. WE FIFTY AS SOME OF
OUR- LITIGATE RISK- AND LOOK WE
KNOW THAT ALSO THE I. OURS ARE
NOT SET IN STONE ONCE THEY'RE
DONE IT'S NOT AS IF YOU'RE
COMPLETELY INSULATED FROM RISK
ALREADY WE KNOW IN OUR E. I. R.
WAS CERTIFIED IN LA RECENTLY TO
TRY TO DO ONE FOR ONE THOUGH
STRUCK DOWN RIGHT SO IT'S NOT AS
IF YOU'RE IMMUNE FROM LITIGATION
RISK ONCE YOU'VE COMPLETED YOUR
I. R. THAT WAS ONE EXCEPTION I
TAKE BUT RIGHT ANYWAY THAT
THAT'S- THAT'S THE HOPE FOR
THESE BILLS SO. WORK IN PROGRESS
IS THAT YOU KNOW THE CLASSIC
MONIKER BUT- I WITHOUT OWNERS.
I'M I'M I'M I'M ONCE HARRIS FOR
THE BILL AND IT CENTER WE
CASTING. ON THE- WELL THE STAFF
REPORT ASKED THE AUDITOR EXPLORE
ALTERNATIVE- THRESHOLDS MIGHT
THE AUTHOR BE LOOKING AT THE V.
A. E. I. R. SIDE OF IT ON THE
MEDICATION BECAUSE WE WE'VE
WE'VE IDENTIFIED THE ONE THE ONE
DOESN'T DOESN'T WORK AND WE- THE
STAFF REPORT PULLS OUT THAT
THERE ARE MORE SENSITIVE AREAS
THE NOT. MIGHT SOME OF THE
IMPROVEMENT BE LOOKING DEFINING
DOES SAYING THERE IS THE MINIMUM
MEDICATION IF YOU'RE TAKING OUT
OF THIS IS GOING TO BE THIS AND
IF YOU TAKE OUT MORE OAKS IS
GOING TO BE THAT AND FOR ON
THAT. THAT SIDE IT DOESN'T KNOW
THE CAN BE AND AN ABSOLUTE
NUMBER TWO I MEAN I IF I SEE
WHERE YOU WANT TO GO WITH US
BECAUSE YOU'RE LOOKING AT ARE
THE THIS IS A SENSITIVE AREA
THIS IS JUST. YOU KNOW SOME
RURAL COUNTY THAT'S GOT- AT OAKS
THERE AND I AGAIN I IT SEEMS TO
ME WERE NOW THE LEAD AGENCY CAN
SET THIS MINIMUM THRESHOLD TO
SAY THIS IS OUR MITIGATION AND
IT MIGHT BE INSTRUCTIVE TO
CHANGE THAT. THAT DIRECTION THIS
IS YOUR- THE- IF YOU DON'T MIND
CAN YOU GIVE ME THAT SO YOU'RE
SAYING WITHIN THE E. S. LIKE
WITHIN THE RECORD ITSELF WITHIN
THE I. R. SAID DON'T TOUCH ON
THE THRESHOLD OF SIGNIFICANCE AS
WE KNOW SOME THE STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE CONCERNS WITH SORT OF
SETTING THAT IN LAW BUT YOU'RE
SAYING SORT OF A NUDGE TOWARDS
THE I. R. DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
RIGHT WILL JUST SAYING ONE THE
ONE MITIGATION IS NOT IS NOT
ADEQUATE JUST THIS IS JUST THE
START UP IS A THRESHOLD IT'S
GOING TO BE SOMETHING MORE THAN
THAT AND IS IT TWO ONE THREE ONE
DEPENDING ON WHAT WORK WHERE
YOU'RE AT AND ARE YOU LOOKING.
ARE YOU RESTORING SENSITIVE
CATION FINAL VOTE LIKE TO HAVE
AN- CLOSE TO WHERE IT IS. THERE
MAY BE BENEFITS OF. OF IF YOU'RE
JUST LOOKING AT THE OAK PORTION.
TO SAY. HERE'S AN AREA THAT
NEEDS REPAIR. AND IF YOU TAKE
DOWN FOR. ONCE YOU PUT WE NEED
TWENTY SEVEN PLANET HERE AND YES
GOOD TAKE A HUNDRED ACRES. A
HUNDRED YEARS TO GET THERE BUT
THAT. THAT HELPS THAT.
RESTORATION PROCESS AT LEAST
IT'S SAID IT'S JUST AN IDEA.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN IT IS VERY
HELPFUL FEEDBACK AND HONESTLY
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FEEDBACK TO AND YOUR CONCERNS
NOT MISPLACED SO I'M NOT I DON'T
WANT TO DISMISS IT AT ALL AND
LET'S BEGIN AND GET TO WORK ON
THIS- YEP. I THINK MY QUESTIONS
HAVE ANSWERED BUT I THINK
RELATIVE TO WHAT THE OPPOSITION
IS BRINGING FORWARD ESPECIALLY
FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES I THINK IT
BECAUSE AND I KNOW YOU'RE-
WORKING ON THE THRESHOLD AND-
FIGURING THAT OUT AND- AND TYPES
OF. PROJECTS AS WELL IN IN
FIGURING OUT YOU KNOW OF COURSE
WHAT. THAT COULD LOOK LIKE AND I
KNOW YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION ON THAT AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT SO. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- I THINK I HEARD
A MOTION. FROM SENATORS ALSO YES
OKAY ALL RIGHT- AS- YOU MAY
CLOSE CENTER. THANK YOU I KNOW
YOU KNOW I KNOW IT. WE SORT OF
JUMP IN THE ORDER OF THINGS WE
DIDN'T HEAR FROM ALL THE
TESTIMONY I- AND APOLOGIZE FOR
THE TIMING OF ALL THIS AND I
HOPE THE NOT JUST THE PROPONENTS
BUT ALSO TO THE OPPONENTS NO IF
YOU IF YOU WEREN'T HERE TO
WHERE. WE STILL DO WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU SO EXPECT- BUT LET'S
HAVE SOME DISCUSSIONS BEFORE
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCE AND
WATER- I WOULD SEND THAT SIGNAL
TO LOOK AT THINGS LIKE HABITAT
LINKAGE MAPS- AS WELL AS FISH
AND WILDLIFE HAS. OVERLAYS IN
THEIR- STATEWIDE MAPPING THAT
COULD PROVIDE ALSO SOME OTHER
NARROWING PRINCIPLES AND I- AND
THEN I WILL TAKE TO HEART CENTER
WHITE HOUSE SKIS A SUGGESTION
AROUND WHAT WHAT SHOULDN'T COUNT
FOR ADEQUATE MITIGATION BUT NOT
NECESSARILY- BEING SO SURGICAL
ABOUT. WHAT MUST COUNT- SO I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD GUY POSE
FOR GOING FORWARD AND
APPRECIATE. THE DIFFERENCE THE
COMMITTEE AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU CENTER- SECRETARY PLEASE
COLOR. I THE NUMBER THIRTY. SB
FORTINO FOR BY SENATOR STERN.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER ALAN HI ALAN HI BATES.
DOLLY GONZALEZ AND SALAS I
SKINNER. STERN AYE STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI. WE KEEP. SORRY LET'S
GO LET'S GO AHEAD OF BELOW SIXTY
FOUR OKAY LET'S DO ITEM TWELVE-
OKAY. THIS YEAR A NEWMAN HEY MAN
. OKAY OUR COME ON UP YEAH HELLO
MY NAME IS NEWMAN LET'S DO THIS-
YES ITEM NINE YOU'RE VERY
WELCOME AND. BACK AT IT AGAIN
WOULD RECITE WITH BATTERY
RECYCLING WHEN ISSUE I
APPRECIATE YOU GETTING INVOLVED
WITH. THAT'S THAT'S AN
ENCOURAGING OF WAY TO STRETCH OF
THE EXCELLENT. MISTER CHAIR IN
MEMBERS I AM HERE BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
S. B. TWELVE FIFTEEN WHICH WOULD%
CREATE A CONVENIENCE STATEWIDE
PRODUCER FUNDED COLLECTION AND
RECYCLING PROGRAM FOR LOOSE AND
PRODUCT EMBEDDED BATTERIES
BEFORE  BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S MEMBERS.
AND THANK THE CONSULTANT- FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT SHE MAY
BE THERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE THOSE
ACROSS TO THE JURORS THE
BATTERIES CONTAIN CALIFORNIA
CLASSIFIES BATTERIES HAZARDOUS
WASTE AND EXPOSE THE BANS THE
DISPOSAL OF BATTERIES AND SOLID
WASTE. LANDFILLS AS A
CONSEQUENCE CONSUMERS ARE
EXPECTED TO SAVE IN STORE
EXPENDED BRASSERIES IN UNNEEDED
PORTABLE ELECTRONICS AND FIND
INAPPROPRIATE DISPOSAL OPTION
THIS ENFORCEMENT TENDS TO BE
MORE THE EXCEPTION THAN THE RULE
SINCE CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY LACKS
A STREAMLINED AND CONVENE A
COLLECTION AND RECYCLING SYSTEM.
FOR BATTERIES CONSIDERING THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT THE SAFETY
ISSUES AROUND BATTERIES THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY LESS THAN IDEAL- I
WOULD ASK YOU ALL AS A POINT OF
REFERENCE IN YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO THINK ABOUT
BATTERIES THINK ABOUT ALL THE
DOUBLE A. AND TRIPLE A. AND
OTHER TYPES OF BATTERIES THAT
YOU CYCLE THROUGH. IN A YEAR
POWER IN ALL THE MANY DEVICES
THAT ARE SO DEEPLY EMBEDDED IN
OUR THOROUGHLY MODERN LIVES ALL
THE REMOTE CONTROLS COMPUTER
KEYBOARDS THE MICE THE CLOCKS BY
SLICE YOUR KIDS TOYS IT GOES ON
AND ON. I NOW THINK ABOUT ALL
THE RHETORICAL DEVICES THAT ARE
PRECARIOUSLY. WELL EACH ONE WITH
. LITHIUM ION OR SIMILAR
RHETORICAL BATTERY NOW MULTI
SIXPENNY BATTERIES BY CALIFORNIA
POPULATION JUST UNDER FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE- AND THEN.
CHALLENGING IT IS. TO STOP THE
ALL OF THOSE BETTER. ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU CONSIDER. THE FACT THAT
THERE'S CURRENTLY NO UNIFIED
CONVENE SYSTEM AND FOR CAL. FOR
TWO SO. NOW CONSIDER THIS
IMPORTANT AN ALARMING FACT AS
WELL. EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE
MILLIONS OF BATTERIES CONTAINS
HAZARDOUS. TOXIC AND CORROSIVE
MATERIALS LIKE MERCURY CADMIUM
LITHIUM AND LET. WHEN IMPROPERLY
DISCARDED BATTERIES POSE A
SERIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARD
WHEN BATTERIES ARE TOSSED INTO
THE TRASH INSTEAD OF BEING
PROPERLY RECYCLED. THE END UP IN
LANDFILLS WITH. B. AND LEAK IS
TYPICAL BATTERIES CORRODE THEIR
CHEMICAL SOAK INTO SOILING
CONTAMINATE GROUNDWATER AND
SURFACE WATER. DELEGATE IN
ALREADY STRAINED ECOSYSTEMS ARE
COMPROMISED WHEN EXPOSED TO
BATTERY CHEMICALS WHEN WE TOOK.
OUR FAUCETS WE COULD BE
INGESTING DANGEROUS BILLS
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES THE KIND
MOST COMMONLY FOUND IN RECHARGE
ELECTRONIC DEVICES. CAN BE VERY
UNSTABLE WHEN DAMAGE TO CHRIST
AND WHEN IT PROPERLY DISPOSED OF
POST SERIOUS FIRE HEALTH AND
SAFETY HAZARDS. WHEN LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES BURNED THEY RELEASE
FLUORIDE GAS WHICH POSES SERIOUS
TOXIC THREATS TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF WORKERS. FIREFIGHTERS
IN THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY.
THE VERY PRICE COMPONENTS A BURN
BATTERIES ALSO GETTRAPPED IN
THE ATMOSPHERE AND POLLUTE LAKES
AND STREAMS IN THE FORM OF ACID
RAIN. AS AB TWO GLOBAL WARMING.
OVER PAST THE MASS IN OF
PROBABLY JUST. OF LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES INTO CALPERS WAY
STREAM HAS RESULTED IN AN
ALARMING NUMBER OF FIRES IN OUR
MATERIAL RECOVERY FACILITIES
WASTE COLLECTION TRUCKS. IN OUR
LANDFILLS GOD BLESS YOU.
ACCORDING TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL SURVEY. TWENTY OF THE
TWENTY SIX MATERIAL RECOVERY
FACILITIES SURVEYED HAD
EXPERIENCED EXPERIENCED AT LEAST
ONE FOR. DURING THE PREVIOUS TWO
YEARS OF WHICH 65% OR ALMOST TWO
THIRDS WERE ATTRIBUTED TO
IMPROPERLY RECYCLED BATTERIES.
BECAUSE OF A COMBINATION
INCREASE CONSUMPTION AND A LACK
OF CONVENE DISPOSAL OPTIONS
HIGHER LEVELS OF TOXIC BATTERIES
AND PRODUCTS ARE CONTINUALLY
ENTERING CALIFORNIA'S WAY
STREAM. WITHOUT DRAMATICALLY
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES ENTERING
CALIFORNIA'S WAY STREAM
CALIFORNIA WILL SUFFER EDITION
FIRES THAT WOULD JEOPARDIZE
WASTE OPERATIONS AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF WORKERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. UNDER ITS
PROVISIONS SB TWELVE FIFTEEN
WILL CREATE ACCORDING TO SYSTEM
OF FREE AND CONVENIENT
COLLECTION BINS FOR EXPANDED
LOSING PRODUCT IN BETTER
BATTERIES AT RETAIL LOCATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE. TO ALLOW
CONSUMERS REPLACE BATTERIES INTO
THE BINS FOR PROPER DISPOSAL
READ RATHER THAN DISCARDING THEM
ALONG WITH THE REST OF THEIR
HOUSEHOLD TRASH. THIS APPROACH
TO POLICY GENERALLY REFERRED TO
AS EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY WHICH SB TWELVE
FIFTEEN WILL APPLY TO CONSUMER
BATTERIES HAS FIRM ROUTE ROUTES
AND KEPT. HAS BEEN PREVIOUSLY
EMPLOYED TO EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY IMPROVE RECYCLING OF
AN ARRAY OF HARD TO RECYCLE
GOODS FROM MATTRESSES TO
AUTOMOBILE TIRES. TO NOT
COINCIDENTALLY CAR BATTERIES AS
WELL. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED BY NEARLY
UNANIMOUS VOTE SB TWO TWELVE
AUTHORED BY OUR COLLEAGUE FORMER
SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON
WHICH REQUIRES MANUFACTURERS IN
THE PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY TO
TAKE. UNUSED AND WASTED NEEDLES
AND DISCARDED DRUGS SB TWELVE
FIFTEEN REPLICATES THIS MODEL
FOR CYCLE BEFORE RE CHARGEABLE
BATTERIES AND LOOSE BATTERIES
AND CONTINUES THIS VERY POSITIVE
TREND. AS YOU MAY BE AWARE THIS
POLICY HAS BEEN TRIED A HANDFUL
OF TIMES IN PRESENTED TO THIS
COMMITTEE TWICE BEFORE. I AM
HAPPY TO HEAR THAT THIS YEAR
WE'VE BEEN PRODUCTIVELY ENGAGING
IN NEGOTIATING WITH THIS MANY
AFFECTED STAKEHOLDERS AS
POSSIBLE AND FOR THAT REASON
YOU'LL KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR
FRIENDS. WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
OPPOSED HAVE SINCE INDICATED A
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH. WHICH
I AM VERY. BY ENROLLING FOR. AS
A MORE EFFECT. THE S. OF A MORE
AFFECT AND SYSTEM FOR CONSUMER
BY WE CAN PREVENT FIRES
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIONS FROM
OCCURRING THEREBY SAVING ON THE
COST OF HIGHER GARBAGE RATES
WILL ALSO PROTECTING THE HEALTH
OF THE PUBLIC REDUCING THE RISK
TO WASTE FOR CITY WORKERS AND
BETTER SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA'S
LAND WATER AND AIR SB TWELVE
FIFTEEN WILL ALSO CREATE A
CONSUMER OUR REGION EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN. TO EDUCATE
CALIFORNIANS AND ENCOURAGES THE
PROPER DISPOSAL OF ALL BATTERIES
THE BILL'S SPONSORS AND  LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS WE
ARE SENSITIVE TO THE CURRENT
THEIR CONCERNS AND COMMITTED TO
SEX SUCCESSFULLY SECURING
SUPPORT OR NEUTRALITY AMONG ALL
PARTIES WERE LEAVING THE OVERALL
INTENT OF THE BILL INTACT. I'M
GRATEFUL THE CENTER WHAT COUNTS
YOU FOR BEING A CO AUTHOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY WITH ME IN PERSON TO
TESTIFY TODAY ARE KAYLA ROBINSON
ON BEHALF OF RETHINK WASTE AND
JASO SCHMELZER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP.
COUNCIL OKAY IN HI GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KILL
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF RETHINK
WASTE WASTE MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY
BASED IN SAN MATEO COUNTY THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND RESIDENCES
ELEVEN THOUSAND BUSINESSES AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE EXPERIENCED
FIRST HAND THE CATASTROPHIC
EFFECTS OF A LITHIUM ION BATTERY
INDUCED FIRE AT A RECYCLING
CENTER IT COMPLETELY DEVASTATED
OUR FACILITY SHUTTING US DOWN
FOR NINETY DAYS AND CAUSING
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN DAMAGES IT TOOK APPROXIMATELY
A YEAR TO FULLY RIGHT. THANK
PRIOR WE HAD ONE INSURANCE
PROVIDER NOW WE NEED SEVEN TO
FIND THE SAME KIND OF COVERAGE
INSURANCE WRITERS ARE FINDING IT
TOO RISKY TO COVER FACILITIES
LIKE OURS AFTER THE EXCESSIVE
DAMAGES IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES TO REMOVE BATTERIES
FROM OUR WAY STREAM BUT LAST
YEAR ALONE WE SUFFERED TWELVE
FIRES BETWEEN OUR MATERIAL
COVERING FACILITY AND TRANSFER
STATION TEN OF THEM COULD BE
ATTRIBUTED. BATTERIES IS
FIGHTERS COULD GROW TO A FIRE
LIKE THE ONE IN TWENTY. ANOTHER
MAJOR FIRE COULD CAUSE US TO
LOSE OUR INSURANCE COMPLETELY.
THESE BATTERIES THREATEN THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR PUBLICLY FUNDED
WASTE COLLECTION AND RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THESE FIRES
POSE A SAFETY HAZARD TO OUR
WORKERS. THIS ISSUE IMPACTS
MATERIAL RECOVERY FACILITIES AND
WASTE COLLECTION VEHICLES AND
EACH ONE OF YOUR DISTRICTS THIS
IS A CRISIS THAT NEEDS A
SOLUTION NOW AS WITH THE MINE
BATTERIES ARE BECOMING MORE AND
MORE COMMON EVERYDAY PRODUCTS.
SB TWELVE FIFTEEN IS CRITICAL TO
DIVERT FROM BATTERY PRODUCTS IN
THE WASTE STREAM TO PROTECT OUR
WORKERS OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OUR ENVIRONMENT- EFFECTS
RESPECTIVELY- TONIGHT OUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRUCE JASON SMELTER HERE- TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS YOU'RE TO COUNSEL ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
I WANNA BE CLEAR AT THE OUTSET
THAT THIS BILL ISN'T ABOUT
DEMONIZING ANY PARTICULAR
PRODUCT OR TYPE OF PRODUCT I
HAVE NO FEWER THAN THREE BATTERY
AND BETTER PRODUCTS ON MY
PERSON. AT THIS MOMENT OTHER
GREAT- THEY MAKE ALL OF OUR
LIVES BETTER- WHAT SB TWELVE
FIFTEEN IS ABOUT IT. I THINK
THAT THESE PRODUCTS HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL IMPACTS ON THE
SAFETY AND RESILIENCY. OF OUR
SOLID WASTE REJECT ANY MAKE OUR
LIVES BETTER- THEY- REALLY- THEY
HAVE A- AND RIGHT NOW. I GOT
HOME AFTER A STRAY. DAY I PLAYED
THIS GAME WITH MY THIRTEEN YEAR
OLD- BUT WASN'T YOUR SOCIAL BAY
PARTLY CAUSED BY THE BATTERY.
THIS MEANS ANY POTENTIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL AND- BUT IT'S JUST
A WRECK THAT THESE PER HAVE-
IMPACTS ON OUR SOLID WASTE
RECYCLING SYSTEM IN THE
PRODUCERS SHOULD SHARE IN THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF MITIGATING
THOSE IMPACTS ALL THE BILL'S
ABOUT- SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
BILL ITSELF PRIOR VERSIONS OF
THE BILL HAD THESE BATTERIES AND
BATTERY AND BETTER PRODUCTS IN
THE SAME EPR PROGRAM THT SEEMED
TO CAUSE SOME ANGST AMONGST THE
VARIOUS PRODUCERS. THIS VERSION
OF THE BILL SPLIT THEM INTO TWO
WHICH IS PRETTY USEFUL BECAUSE
IT ALLOWS US TO DEVELOP
PROGRAMMATIC ELEMENTS AND
COMPLIANCE STANDARDS FOR EACH
PRODUCT CATEGORY THAT WORKS
BETTER FOR THOSE PRODUCT
CATEGORIES THAT'S PRETTY USEFUL
I THINK THE- THE PRODUCT OF THAT
. NOTED THAT WE'VE GOT A MORE
CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATION GOING-
THIS YEAR SO AS THE SENATE
POINTED OUT AT THIS PRETTY CLOSE
TO EACH. WITH THE PRIOR PASSED-
MEDS IN SHARPSVILLE AFTER A FEW
YEARS AGO THAT DOES A FEW THINGS
THAT WERE FIRST PRODUCE. FUND IN
THE RECITE PROGRAM THE PRODUCTS
I CONTAINS A VERY. UP APPROVAL-
WITH DEPARTMENT I JUST DOUBLES
HIS CLEAR. FOR THE COLLECTION
NETWORK AND WHAT HAPPENS TO THAT
PRODUCTS ONCE THEY'RE COLLECTED.
CREATES AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE SO
STAKEHOLDERS CAN BE INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING THE
PLAN AND COMMENTING ON HOW IT'S
WORKING. IT'S NOT LOCATION ON
SOME RETAILERS. EIGHT AND TAKE
BACK PROGRAMS AND IT HAS STRONG
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS THAT ARE PRETTY TRIED
AND TRUE- AT THIS POINT SO I
WANT TO THANK THE DIVERSE GROUP
OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE WORKING
CONSTRUCTIVELY WITH US OUT ON
THE BILL. SOME OF WHOM WERE
PREVIOUSLY OPPOSED THE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN VERY
PRODUCTIVE THIS YEAR- BUT I
THERE ARE SOME DETAILS LEFT TO
WORK OUT I'M CONFIDENT THAT OUR
PROCESS IS GOING TO GET US
THERE. WE'VE GOT GREAT
LEADERSHIP- SO BUT I
RESPECTFULLY URGE DRIVERS TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LET'S GO TO
FOLKS WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL HERE IN PERSON. HI JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RC RC A GUN AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THIS TIME FOR ALL THE REASONS
ARTICULATED BY KAYLA AND JASON.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DIRECT OFTEN HAPPILY CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU. MICHAEL BATH
WITH REPUBLIC SERVICES IN
SUPPORT. READ ADDRESS ON BEHALF
OF C. R. AND R. WE'VE ACTUALLY
LOST VEHICLES TO THIS- IN STRONG
SUPPORT YEAH. INTERESTING THE-
PERILS OF SOME OF THE PLASTICS
WORK WE'RE DOING IN TERMS OF THE
FOLKS WHO LINE UP- OKAY
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THAT
TESTIMONY OF ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES YOU WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR ITS SENTIMENTS BILL. HM IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. SB
TWELVE FIFTEEN WE HAVE LINE.
SIXTY HI GOOD MORNING CARE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAKE LOTS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE WE'RE
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND WANTED TO
THANK THE AUTHOR- FOR CONVENING
STAKEHOLDERS RELATED DANCING THE
ISSUE THIS YEAR. AND THAT LINE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS REFLECTED
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
CLIENTS BUT FROM PASSED THE
WASTE MANAGEMENT FORTY ALAMEDA
SUBWAY AND NATIONAL ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND LINE SIX THE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
THAT IS SCHERING GREEN WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN ADDITION
DISTRICT HERE IN SUPPORT. AND I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN KILL. OKAY
THE LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL IF THERE IS ANY ANYONE
HERE IN PERSON WANT TO SPEAK
ABOUT CONCERNS YES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CAROLINE MY NAME IS
WALTER ALCORN AND THAT THE
CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
AND WE REPRESENT MANUFACTURERS
AND RETAILERS OF CONSUMER
ELECTRONICS- WE'RE VERY- VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SAME THINGS
I THINK THE BILL'S SPONSOR AND
THE ADVOCATES. ARE ABOUT IN
TERMS OF THE PRE FIRES- WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE WAY
THE BILL IS DRAFTED CURRENTLY-
AND I'M SPECIFICALLY GONNA DRESS
BATTERY EMBEDDED PRODUCTS. IN
THE WAY THAT- THE BILL IS
STRUCTURED- WE THINK THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THAT- GIVEN THE- THE BROAD
VARIETY OF PRODUCTS THAT
CURRENTLY HAVE EMBEDDED
BATTERIES. IN THAT THROUGH A
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
ORGANISATION WOULD BE- REALLY AN
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGE- I AM
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE EPR
SYSTEMS IN THE UNITED STATES ON
E. WASTE- OUR RECOMMENDATION IS
IF THERE DOES NEED TO BE.
EXTENDED THEIR WORK EXPANDED
COLLECTION AND RECYCLING OF
THESE BATTERY INVENTED PRODUCTS
THE BILL IN THE CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE BASICALLY THE
CURRENT COVERED ELECTRONIC WASTE
PROGRAM SHOULD BE EXPANDED TO
INCLUDE BATTERY EMBEDDED
PRODUCTS- WE'VE BEEN HAVING GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH- THE BILL'S
SPONSORS OFFICE AND SOME OF THE
ADVOCATES. ON THIS ISSUE WE WAY
TO COME TO RESOLUTION ON IT- BUT
OUR RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE TO
USE THAT IS THE STARTING POINT
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
TODAY. THANK YOU- LOVE DELAY GET
TEN SAID RESPOND SOME OF THAT IN
THE SECOND I ANYONE ELSE WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS WITH A BILL YOUR
PERSON. YEAH COME ON UP. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT
FIELDING GROUPS ABOUT COME
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT A LARGE
NUMBER OF MEDICAL DEVICE
MANUFACTURERS- IN A CLEAR
POSITION TODAY WE HAVE SOME
REMAINING TECHNICAL CONCERNS
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF THE
DEFINITION SO WE- APPRECIATE
THE- AMENDMENTS FOR CLASS TWO
AND CLASS THREE MEDICAL DEVICES
BUT HAVE REMAINING TECHNICAL
CONCERNS. ABOUT THAT THE SCOPE.
OF THE CLASS ONE MEDICAL DEVICES
ARE WORKING PRODUCTIVELY WITH
AUTHORED SPONSORS AND APPRECIATE
THAT COLLABORATIVE WORK SO FAR.
HOPE TO HAVE RESOLUTION BY
SESSIONS IN BUT- SO FAR SO GOOD
AND- THANK YOU THE AUTHOR I IN
SPOTS FOR WORKING WITH US THANK
YOU. THANK THE TERM MEMBERS JOHN
LINGER ON BEHALF OF THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
ADVAMED WERE THE NATIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR MEDICAL DEVICES
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME WE JUST
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
BYGONES LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS. THANK YOU.
FOR DINNER FEEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE OPPOSED FOR THE REASONS
PEOPLE YOU SEE MENTIONED AS WELL
AS IN OUR LETTER. SHE CONTINUED
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
SPONSORS. THANK YOU. WEITERE
COMMITTEE ADAM RIGHT WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ALSO REGISTERING A TWEENER
POSITION I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US WE THINK WE CAN
GET THERE ON THIS ONE BUT WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH SOME OF THE
RETAIL- ISSUES THAT- RETAILERS
HAVE EXPRESSED IN THE LETTER-
BUT OTHERWISE LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH THE OTHER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY OUR FOLKS ON ON ON THE
PHONE LINES LIKE TO VOICE
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS ABOUT SB
TWELVE FIFTEEN. IF YOU WISH
FIFTY REGARDING AT EIGHT TWELVE
FIFTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT WHILE I GET
MY NUMBERS.
BY TWENTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JACOB KATHY WITH
THE POSITION OF HOME APPLIANCE
MANUFACTURERS AND- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE AFOREMENTIONED
REASONS. AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
CAN Q. CRIME. OUR LISTING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMUNITY FOR
QUESTIONS AND THOUGHTS- WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU ASKED THE SENATOR THE
AUTHOR TO DO JUST GIVE. US HIS
PERSPECTIVE ON SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE OPPOSITION
IN YOUR SENSE OF THE-
CONVERSATIONS. YOUR PREFERRED
THAT SUIT SO DON'T THANK YOU
FIRST. OF ALL THE ADVOCATES AND
I THINK THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
HAS BEEN ONGOING FOR A YEAR IT'S
PROBABLY WORTH NOTINGTHERE'S A
PARALLEL BILL MOVING THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY THAT
AUTHORED BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN- BUT YOU KNOW IN WITH
GRATEFUL FOR THE YOU KNOW THE
VERY PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
BUT YET TO START- ON ON THE
BATTERY EMBEDDED PRODUCTS SIDE I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY THAT'S AN
INHERENTLY. CHALLENGING ISSUE-
IN AND PART OF IT COMES DOWN TO
PRODUCT DESIGN. AND I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY DISAGREEMENT
AMONG. THE PARTIES THAT WE
SHOULD FIGURE OUT BETTER WAYS.
TO MAKE SURE THESE BACK ON THEIR
WAY TO THE PROPER DISPOSAL.
SCENARIOS A AND SO WE YOU KNOW
WE ARE DELIVERY AGNOSTIC WHEN IT
COMES TO. A BUNCH OF ISSUES HERE
WITH BUT DO YOU KNOW THE BROADER
CONCERN REMAINS THAT- IT BETWEEN
THE ROD BATTERY THAT'D PRODUCTS
RIGHT SO AS LITHIUM ION BATTERY
SHOULD BECOME AT RISK OF BECOME.
MORE COMMON THEY DISPLACED. YOUR
YOU KNOW THE COULD LOSE
BATTERIES THAT WE ALL GREW UP
USED TO- THEY'VE THEY'RE THEY'RE
YOU KNOW THEY'RE DESIGNED INTO
PRODUCTS THEY'RE OFTEN HARD TO
TAKE IT OUT- DURING THE DISPOSAL
PROCESS- ANSWER. THE EPR MODEL
SEEMS TO BE THE ONLY WAY TO
REALLY ADDRESSES AT A SYSTEMIC
LEVEL- IN THE WAY THAT WE'VE
DONE AS A SPOKE TO MENTION FOR
OTHER PRODUCTS. AND SYLLABLES
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS HAVING-
BOTH A CLEAR INTEREST BUT ALSO A
CLEAR A CERTAIN ROLE WITHIN THAT
PROCESS SO YOU KNOW. HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION. I
APPRECIATE. SENATE AFFECT BY.
I'M ON THE MEDICAL DEVICES
SIMILAR RIGHT THERE A CLASS OF
MEDICAL BY WITH THE- BUT THERE'S
SOME TWEETERS STUFF RIDES AND
SOME THINGS THAT- YOU KNOW
TRICIA THE CLASS ONE LEVEL THAT
WE THINK THAT YOU KNOW SHOULD
PROBABLY BE MANAGED IN SOME WAY
THEN- IT'S CLEAR AS TO HOW WE
HOW WE COLLECTIVELY BUT ALSO THE
MANUFACTURES WOULD- SERVED
PARTICIPATE MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
BATTERIES ARE ACCESSIBLE BUT
THEN YOU KNOW THE SYSTEM IS FROM
AND- MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A
WAY IN A PLACE TO DISPOSE OF
THEM- YOU KNOW GLAD TO TAKE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS BUT I THINK THE
EMPHASIS HERE IS- THIS IS BEEN A
VERY. COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
THROUGHOUT- WE'VE LEARNED FROM
LAST YEAR I THINK IS ONE OF THE
WINDOWS VENTION I THOUGHT WE
MADE A DISTINCTION THIS YEAR
BETWEEN LOOSE AND A BETTER
BATTERIES AND WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW
CARILLO SIR PROCESSES FOR BOTH
BOTH ARE SUBJECT TO AMENDMENT
YOU KNOW IN WAYS THAT INCREASE
THE EFFICIENCY WITH THE END GOAL
OF GETTING SOMETHING THAT WORKS.
YEP OKAY. ALL RIGHT I'M- OKAY I
GET THE OTHER CONCERN THAT WAS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION IS A
GOOD PLACE TO START WOULD BE THE
EXISTING SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW- AND HELD THAT. YOU
KNOW HOW HOW DO YOU ENVISION
BECAUSE ALL EVERY EPA PROGRAM
SEARCH WHAT'S ON THE GROUND WHAT
WE DO IN RIGHT NOW AND THEN
EVOLVES INTO- ANOTHER COLLECTION
AND DISPOSAL PROCESS BUT YOU
STILL. YES HIGHLIGHT THE BEST
PRACTICES IF THERE ARE SOME BEST
PRACTICE AND WE COLLECT
BATTERIES HERE RIGHT ON THE-
YEAH YOU KNOW THEY'RE- CERTAINLY
THERE ARE BEST PRACTICES FOR
BATTERIES ABOVE A CERTAIN SIZE-
BUT WHAT WE ARE SEEING. ACROSS
THE WASTE STREAM IS CLEARLY YOU
KNOW THE- YOU KNOW THE SUPPLY OF
BATTERIES COMING INTO THE WASTE
STREAM IMPROBABLY SUPPOSED THIS
IS OVERWHELMING BILITY. TO
HANDLE THEM A. N. O. N. AT REAL
RISK- TIMMER STRIDES WE INTEND
TO TRUST THAT TO TRANSPORT TRASH
SO IS THIS IS REAL RIGHT YOU
KNOW THE OF THESE FIRES A
REALISTIC YOU HURT SOMEONE WHO
INSISTS- A FIRE AT A DISPOSAL
FACILITY IS BOTH DANGEROUS BUT
IT CAN WHAT IT CAN RESULT IN
SHUTTING DOWN THAT FACILITY.
PRECIPITATION AT A TIME YOU CAN
RESULT IN THAT FACILITY LOSING
ITS INSURANCE- AND HAS AND HE
HAS A BIG SORT OF THE COULD
KENNEDY EFFECT THROUGHOUT THE
YOU KNOW THE WHOLE SYSTEM. AND
SO IT YOU KNOW DO GLAD TO BUILD
ON ANYTHING THAT WORKS BUT I
THINK THE OBSERVATION IS. AS IT
RELATES TO BATTERIES IS THERE'S
NEED HERE THE NEEDS DRESS IN THE
ONLY. SERVE LOGICAL APPROACH IS
AN EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY MODEL. I MEAN I
THINK THE U. YOU GIVE. THE
PRODUCERS THE LEAD RESPONSIBLE
BUT YOU STILL HAVE. YOU STILL
GOT IT SOME STUFF IS EVEN MORE
WITH. THE PR THERE STILL COULD
BE SOME THINGS THAT THE CONSUMER
THROWS INTO. THE WE STREAM SO
PART OF THAT IS EDUCATING THE
CONSUMER. MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE FOR
THAT IN AND WORKING WITH OUR-
THE MERCENARY BECAUSE OF THE
REMAINDER THAT COULD SEND. THAT
NOW IS PART OF THE PRODUCERS
RESPONSIBILITY TO DEAL WITH THAT
NOT. WASTE MANAGEMENT OR
REPUBLICAN THERE'S GOT TO BE
SOME COORDINATION WITH THOSE
GUYS TO WHICH HOPEFULLY IT
SHRINKS BUT THEN. BUT THEN WE
FIGURE OUT THE BEST PRACTICES ON
HOW TO. REMOVE THE REMOVE THAT
STUFF WHEN THERE'S LESS OF IT I
GUESS TO TOTALLY AGREE AND I
THINK PART OF THE- CERTIFICATION
COMPONENT- BUT PART OF IT IS
BINDING PRODUCERS TO. YOU KNOW
TO THE BROADER PROCESS OF
EDUCATING USERS TO HELP. HER
PROBABLY RECYCLE THESE BATTERIES
. I'M OF THE BILL. OKAY THE
BILLS A MOVE BY CASKEY- THE
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS FROM THE
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY ME CLOSE YEAH I
JUST WITH THAT AGAIN YOU KNOW
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANKS TO ALL THE PARTICIPANTS
THIS BAR- AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MICHAEL. GRAHAM CONTEMPLATES
CALL THE ROLL I REMEMBER NINE SB
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALAN HI ALAN I BATES. DOLLY
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I SKINNER
STERN. MAKOWSKI HIGH. OKAY SO
LEAVE THE ROTH AND FOR- FOR
FOLKS TO ANNA THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU SENATOR OKAY- WE'VE
GOT TO COME TO EUROPE HERE TO
PRESENT. SB ELEVEN A ONE THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IN YOUR AGENDA
PACKETS MEMBERS.
YEP YOU MAY PROCEED CENTER GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ELEVEN A ONE. WHICH
SEEKS TO FURTHER CALIFORNIA'S
POLICY GOALS TO REACH ECONOMY
WIDE CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE BY SUPPORTING CARBON
CAPTURE SEQUESTRATION AND
UTILIZATION PROJECTS. WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORK ON THE BILL- AS
WELL AS THE COMMITTEE CHAIR I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE AND NET
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS THEREAFTER
WILL REQUIRE A MULTITUDE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE INITIATIVES ONE
THAT IS VITAL TO OUR STATE
SUCCESS IS CARBON CAPTURE
UTILIZATION. AND SEQUESTRATION
OR C. C. U. S. THIS IS A
SENTIMENT SHARED WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
AMBITIOUS DOMESTIC CLIMATE GOAL
OF NET ZERO EMISSIONS ECONOMY
WIDE BY TWENTY FIFTY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION PROJECTS THE NEED
TO CAPTURE. TRANSPORT AND
PERMANENTLY SEQUESTER
SIGNIFICANT QUANTITIES OF CARBON
DIOXIDE. THERE IS ROOM A REAL
TIME BENEFIT. THAT C. C. U. S.
PROVIDES ENVIRONMENTALLY THE
PROCESS CAPTURES CARBON DIOXIDE
EMISSIONS STRAIGHT FROM THE
SOURCE TO AVOID RELEASED INTO
THE ATMOSPHERE. IN FACT CARBON
CAPTURE METHODS SEQUESTER MORE
THAN 90% OF CO TWO EMISSIONS
FROM POWER PLANTS AND INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES 90% OF WHAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE RELEASED. THIS IS
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ROLE IN A
PRACTICAL METHOD. ESTIMATES ALSO
INDICATE APPROXIMATELY 15% OF
THE STATE'S TOTAL CO TWO
EMISSIONS CAN BE CAPTURED AND
STORED WITH C. C. U. S. C. C. U.
S. HAS BENEFITS ENVIRONMENTALLY
BUT ALSO FOR OUR WORKFORCE AND
OVERALL ECONOMY. THE USE OF C.
C. U. S. COULD ENABLE DIFFICULT
TO DECARBONISE INDUSTRIES TO
STAY IN BUSINESS AND CONTINUE TO
MAKE LARGE CONTRIBUTIONS THE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY WHILE
DRAMATICALLY REDUCING THEIR GHG
EMISSIONS. C. C. U. S.
ACTIVITIES WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
JOBS FOR CALIFORNIA WITH BURKE
CALIFORNIANS WITH SKILL SETS
THAT MAY BECOME OBSOLETE IN THE
CLEAN ENERGY TRANSIT AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE BIG IS THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IS THIS
TRANSITION. AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS TO- A GREENER ECONOMY AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE WORK%
FORCE. ON THE BALLOT WOULD BE-
AFFECTED BY THAT. AND
PARTICULARLY IN MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT HAPPENED
HOW'S THAT WORK FORCE. ALSO
CONSIDER THAT MANY ORGANIZATION
AND COMMERCIALIZE SECTORS ARE
READILY ABLE TO APPLY C. C. U.
S. TECHNOLOGIES TO THEIR
OPERATIONS WHAT IS NEEDED IS
STATE SUPPORT IN THE FORM OF
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK. SB TEN OH
ONE PURSUES THIS GOAL BY
ESTABLISHING CARBON CAPTURE YOU
ASIAN SEQUESTRATION PROGRAM.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. I MERRY
OBJECTIVE OF WHICH IS TO ASSIST
IN THE DEPLOYMENT OF PROJECTS
THAT WILL ACCELERATE THE
DEVELOPMENT. DEPLOYMENT AND
COMMERCIALIZATION OF ADVANCED
NEW TECHNOLOGIES THE CAPTURE AND
SEQUESTER CARBON DIOXIDE
ADMISSION EMISSIONS IN
INDUSTRIAL AND COMMERCIAL
FACILITIES. THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD HAS ALREADY
RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF C.
C. U. S. THE HELP THE STATE MEET
ITS GOALS RELATED TO GHG
REDUCTIONS BY INCLUDING IT IN
ITS SCOPING PLAN. AS AN
IMPORTANT CLIMATE CHANGE
SOLUTION. ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
WILL ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
UNDERGROUND POOR SPACE FOR
CARBON STORAGE TO BE
SEQUESTERED. IN MOST STATES
OWNERSHIP OF SUBSURFACE PORE
SPACE PER PROPERTY RIGHTS
GENERALLY BELONG TO THE OWNER
AND OFFICE. RIGHT BOB HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY LACKS A
CLEAR AND DEFINED LEGAL
FRAMEWORK FOR POOR SPACE
OWNERSHIP FOR CARBON DIOXIDE
SEQUESTRATION. CLARIFICATION OF
POOR SPACE OWNERSHIP WILL ALLOW
CARBON CAPTURE PROJECTS TO
QUALIFY UNDER THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE CALIFORNIA. UNDER THE
REQUIREMENTS OF CALIFORNIA'S LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD SO
COMPANIES CAN APPLY THE- URBAN
TARGETS THAT BY CARPENTER THE
STANDARD. AND ALIGNING ONE STEP
WITH THE FEDERAL CSU. WHEN IT
WILL ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA IS
WORKING WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS IN AN EFFICIENT AND
LOGICAL FASHION. CALIFORNIA
COULD BECOME A GLOBAL LEADER IN
C. C. U. S. DEVELOPMENT AND
DEPLOYMENT TO ACHIEVE ITS
CLIMATE GOALS AS IT HAS IN OTHER
CLEAN ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES BUT TO
DO SO IT NEEDS TO ACT. AND TO
ACT COMPREHENSIVELY BY
SUPPORTING MEASURES THAT
ENDEAVOR TO UTILIZE C. C. AT C.
C. U. S. TO THE STATE'S BENEFIT
WE CAN CREATE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHILE WE WORK TO ATTAIN OUR
CLIMATE. OUR STATES CLIMATE
CHANGE CALLS ON ONE OF THE
THINGS AB AND WHEN ONE OF THE
DIFFICULT THINGS ABOUT BEING
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW
IS THAT- WE'VE HAD A WORKING
GROUP THAT IS LOOKING AT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND- ONE OF THE ISSUES
WE'VE- BEEN WAITING TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT. IS EXACTLY
THE PARAMETERS THAT WE BE USING
UP FOR C. C. U. S. THE BILL
REACH THIS COMMITTEE PRIOR TO
THE END OF THE NEGOTIATIONS I
EXPECT THAT- ONCE WE CONCLUDE
WITH ALL OF THAT WHICH SHOULD BE
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS- THE BILL
MAY CHANGE AND I SAY THAT
HESITANTLY BECAUSE- WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN THERE YET. AND IT IS-
LEADERSHIP THAT THE COMMITTEE
WAS PUT TOGETHER BY LEADERSHIP
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY
DILIGENTLY ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE BUT- ANY. OF MY CAR. IS
THAT- I WANT TO SHARE THIS
COMMITTEE THAT NUMBER ONE I'M
NOT INTERESTED IN EXPANDING THIS
T. O. R. WHICH IS THE ENHANCED
OIL RECOVERY- BUT BUT THERE ARE
NEGOTIATIONS NOT BEEN IN THE
OCEANS GOING ON AND YOU DON'T
GIVE UP SOMETHING THAT HASN'T
BEEN THAT IS PART OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT- THAT YEAH IS
A DELICATE BALANCE BETWEEN ALL
THE DIFFERENT ENTITIES THAT ARE
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION SO I IT
JUST I RAISE THAT ISSUE- I
MISTER CARE YOU ASK ME IN A IN A
CONVERSATION IN REGARDS TO- THIS
BILL- ABOUT THE FEDERAL FUNDING
PROGRAM WHICH IS TAX. CREDIT
PROGRAM WHICH IS THE FORTY FIVE
Q. MY UNDERSTANDING I HAD STAFF
GO BACK IN AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT FUNDING IS THAT THE CURRENT
BILL THAT PASSES THAT PASSED
DOES NOT ALLOW- EOR ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY UNDER THE FORTY FIVE Q.
PROGRAM THE ONE THAT IS PROPOSED
THAT IS IN NEGOTIATION DOES- AT
A LOWER RATE BUT BUT- I WISH
TRYING TO ALIGN THE ARE BUILT
WITH THE FEDERAL- PROGRAM SO
THAT- FOR EFFICIENCY AND BECAUSE
IT MAKES GOOD SENSE- IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS GOOD
THEY'RE MOVING ON THIS AND IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE FOR. ISSUING
FINES AND IN IN THE M. TAX
CREDIT ARENA THEN WE OUGHT TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT WORKS AND-
AND TRY TO ALIGN OURS VERY
SIMILAR TO A CELL IT I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE I GOT BACK TO YOU ON
THAT YEAH I'M HERE I AM HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY REMOTELY IS DR
SARAH SALTER MANAGING DIRECTOR
AT THE STANFORD CENTER FOR
CARBON STORAGE AND IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS CHRIS HANNON
WITH THE LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDINGS AND
CONSTRUCTION. CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. SURE OKAY
MODERATED YOU WANTED START WITH-
SIR SALTER. OKAY SIR AUTHOR I AM
ASSUMING YOU CAN HEAR ME YES WE
CAN YOU. OKAY GREAT OKAY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR INVITING
ME TO BE HERE TODAY. UNIVERSITY
AN ENERGY FUTURES INITIATIVE
RECENTLY COMPLETED A STUDY ON
PCS OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU A
COUPLE YOU FIND THINGS AND THEN
ADDRESS HAS SENATE BILL ELEVEN A
ONE CAN HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THE
KEY CHALLENGES IF YOU SEE US IN
THE STATE. L. AND ELECTRICITY
SECTOR CALIFORNIA. I MET MOST
FORTY FOR. OF CALIFORNIA ANNUAL
EMISSIONS. IN OUR STUDY WE
IDENTIFIED SEVENTY SIX LARGE
EMITTERS THAT ARE IDEAL
CANDIDATES FOR CAP CARBON
CAPTURE RETROFIT. AND COULD
ADDRESS 15% OF THE STATE THE
MISSIONS. OF COURSE CAPTURE HERE
TO BE GOOD IF YOU WITH THAT. ARE
AT THE OFFICE AT THE STORAGE
OPPORTUNITY AND CALIFORNIA HAS
ONE OF THE LARGEST GEOLOGIC
STORAGE TENSIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT THE CAPACITY TO
STORE OVER SEVENTY GIGATONS. OF
CO TWO. I NOTICED THAT I
SWITCHED FROM MEGATONS. TO KICK
IT TURNS. OUR THE OPPORTUNITY
THIS YES THE STATE OF PA. ISSUE
BUT START THE CHALLENGE. AND HOW
. THERE IS. OF WHO THE STATE.
FIFTY S. PROJECT INJECT CO TWO
WELL INTO THE FORTY EIGHT DEEP
BELOW THE SURFACE. A AT THREE
THOUSAND FEET OR MORE. IMPORTANT
PHASE HER FIRST TO THE VOICE IN
THE BY THAT NOT FAR BY SOLID
MATTER IN WHICH BE USED FIRST
CAR ABOUT. NOW AN UNDERGROUND
PLUMAS TWO SYSTEM ACTED SPREAD
OVER A WIDE AREA AFFECTING MANY
POTENTIAL TO RIGHTS HOLDERS. AND
IN ORDER TO PROMOTE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A CARBON-
GEOLOGIC SEQUESTRATION IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S NEED FOR A
CREEK CLEAR RESOLUTION INTO THE
PROPERTY LOSS ISSUES. IDEALLY
ALLOWING OPERATORS TO ESTABLISH
THE NEEDED RIGHTS AT MINIMUM
FINANCIAL AND TRANSACTIONAL
COST. IN ADDITION CARBS CCS
PROTOCOL REQUIRES OF THE PROJECT
OPERATOR MUST SHOW PROOF OF
EXCLUSIVE RIGHT TO USE THE SPORT
PORTS BASED IN THE STORAGE DOWN.
IN ORDER TO OBTAIN LC-MS CREDIT
WHICH AS WE KNOW ARE CRITICAL TO
THE FINANCIAL VIABILITY OF MOST
PCS PROJECTS. THIS LACK OF LEGAL
CARE CLARITY ON GEOLOGIC PORK
BASED OWNERSHIP CREATES REALLY A
WHOLE PACKET OF LEGAL ISSUES FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF CO TWO STORAGE
PROJECTS. APPLE THIS LACK OF
CLEAR OF COURSE BASED ON A COMP
. SCENARIO IN WHICH IS ZERO TWO
PLUME STAY MIGRATES ANOTHER
LOCATION IN THE RESERVOIR
FORCING THE PROJECT DEVELOPER TO
SEEK ADDITIONAL AND UNNECESSARY
CENTER IF YOU COULD IF YOU COULD
JUST WRAP UP YOUR COMMENTS. YES
OKAY- ARE SENATE BILL WHAT
ELEVEN A ONE WOULD PROVIDE
GREATER PREDICTABILITY PRETTY
FAST OPERATORS. AND ALLEVIATE A
MAJOR ROADBLOCK TO INVESTMENT IN
CCS PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LET'S GO TO CHRIS
HANNAN WHO I BELIEVE HERE.
GOOD MOVE GOOD MORNING
HONORABLE- COMMITTEE CHAIR
HONORABLE SENATORS MY NAME IS
CHRIS HANNAN- THE EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY OF THE LOS ANGELES
ORANGE COUNTY'S BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL-
THIS MORNING I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL- STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
REPRESENTS. APPROXIMATE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THE BEST
TRAINED MEN AND WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION. ANYWHERE PROXY
SEVENTY THOUSAND OF THOSE
MEMBERS ARE PRACTICES THAT ARE
LEARNING THEIR CRAFTS- MANY.
BEING GIVEN OPPORTUNITIES- FROM-
PRESSURE BRADY IS PROGRAMS LIKE
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION GIVING A
SECOND CHANCE. TO PEOPLE AND-
MANY MANY CHANCES AS WELL TO
VETERANS ARE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
REPRESENTS NEARLY A THIRD OF ALL
UNION CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THIS- SOLUTION FORWARD
. WE NEED ALL HANDS ON DECK TO
MEET THE CLIMATE GOALS SET BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
TWENTY THIRTY. REDUCTION LEVELS
THAT NEED TO BE MATTER IN LESS
THAN EIGHT YEARS WE NEED TO LOOK
AT ALL OPPORTUNITIES TO LOWER
EMISSIONS CARBON CAPTURE CAN NOT
ONLY. REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES
FROM EXISTING FACILITIES NEW
FACILITIES AS WELL AS REVERSE
SOME OF THE ALREADY POLLUTANTS
THAT ARE IN THERE TODAY. WITHOUT
LOCAL MANUFACTURING LOCAL ENERGY
AND LOCAL SOURCES FOR
CALIFORNIA. WORKING FAMILIES ARE
IMPACTED- UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ARE IMPACTED THE
POLLUTION YES IMPACTS ALSO THE
LOSS OF OPPORTUNITY THE LOSS OF
JOBS RECENTLY IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AT THE ACL US SOLAR
PROJECT. FIVE HUNDRED BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES MEMBERS
INCLUDING NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
IBEW ELECTRICIANS WORKING ON A
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY MEGAWATT.
PROJECT THAT INCLUDED BATTERY
STORAGE WERE LAID OFF JUST
BEFORE THANKSGIVING AND THROUGH
CHRISTMAS TIME THEY WERE LAID
OFF BECAUSE IMPORTED MATERIAL
WAS BACKED UP IN THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH AND IT COULD GET
THROUGH WITHOUT LOCAL
MANUFACTURING FOR STEEL
CONCRETE. ENERGY MANY OF US ARE
FACING AN UPHILL BATTLE I THAT
WE CAN'T ACHIEVE OUR STATE'S
CLIMATE GOALS WERE ALL HANDS ON
DECK TO WORK WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. MEET AND SURPASS OUR
GOALS BUT WE NEED ALL OPTIONS
AND CARBON CAPTURE IS A
NECESSARY AND THOUGHTFUL WAY OF
ADDRESSING SOME OF THOSE-
IMPACTS OKAY THANK YOU BETWEEN
SAN. IS IT ALRIGHT OF FOLKS WANT
TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
WANT TO COME UP TO THEM I CAN
JUST. WITH YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS-
VIRGIL WELCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CARBON CAPTURE
COALITION- VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THIS CRITICAL MEASURE AND
WANT TO THANK GOD THE CENTER FOR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE- PAY-
SERVERS AND CALPINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ZACH LARRY ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATIONS HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE- OWN AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOTWHICH ON BEHALF THE
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL. IN THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT. THE
EXTRA OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO
GRAYSON AT WHAT OUR MODERATOR
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL ON THE
PHONE LINES. YES SIR FOR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY A
ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBERS SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL YEAH
THIS IS- JEFF HUNTER LOCK WITH
THE OPERATING ENGINEERS AND THE
HUMBOLDT- DEL NOR BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. WE GO TO LINE NUMBER. SIXTY
NINE SIX NINE. YES SIR GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DAVID BEATTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE SANTA
CLARA AND SAN BENITO COUNTIES
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE STAND IN SUPPORT. AND
SOLIDARITY WITH CHRIS HANNAN AND
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL. THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ONE NUMBER FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. EACH MORNING ROB NO TOP
QUALITY DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR WE REPRESENT EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS TIMOTHY JEFFREY THEIR
NATIONAL BUBBLE OF LAWMAKERS
REPRESENTED WEST COAST- WESTERN
STATES HERE- STANDING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WITH THE-
STATE BUILDING TRACE THANK. WE
GO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE ROB
STOKER REPRESENTING THE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND THE SHEET
METAL WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
BENITO ROLLED OF WITH BELIEVERS
DISTRICT COUNCIL IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND- WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
TO THE LINE NUMBER FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORE THIS
MIGHT REALLY WITH THE BEARS
KNOWLEDGE RATES DISCOUNTS. WAS
JAILED STAPLE TRIED BOTH. FIND
NUMBER THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RICK SMILES AT
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL LIVERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE FILM AT THE LEVEL ONE
THANK YOU. ONE NUMBER SIXTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS- WE'VE GOT A MODEL BILL
MATTER OF ALL OF MAKERS LOCAL
RIGHT TO A PART OF THE L. A. O.
C. BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL ONE
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN
OH ONE. THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
THREE LINE IS OPEN THIRTY THREE.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FROM
THE HELP OF BY LOCALS ELEVEN AND
ONE COUNTY. SUPPORT THANK YOU. I
AM PRESENTLY NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
HI THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ANYONE WHO WANTS TO VOICE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL. ANYONE
ON THE PHONE WITH. FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ONE AND ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND.
WELL I'M JUST GONNA GO AHEAD AND
OPEN UP A LINE.
HELLO. YEAH YES WE CAN LEASE.
NORTH ROMERO OF CALIFORNIAN
BERMAN PROVIDERS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT- AND-
FEDERAL CASKEY. SO I APPLAUD THE
DESIRABILITY TO GET GREATER
PREDICTABILITY HERE AND I'M NOT
CORRECT. COMMENT ON THE BORDER
OWNERSHIP BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S
GOING TO NATURAL RESOURCES IN A
WHILE AS I UNDERSTAND. THERE'S
THREE BILLS I HAVE A BILL MISTER
HAS BILL YOU HAVE BILL THE
SKINNER HAS THREE CEMENT PLANTS
I HAVE THREE PUNY LITTLE PLANTS
AND THEN THE OTHER HUNDRED
SEVENTY PLANTS WOULD COME UNDER
AT LEAST THE GUIDELINES THAT
WILL BE SPELLED OUT HERE SO THE
IMPORTANCE OF- GETTING IT RIGHT.
IS KEY. YOU'VE CHOSEN TO HOUSE
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE C. C.
U. S. PROGRAM WITH THE AIRPORT
AND I SEE THE INITIAL
DESIRABILITY BECAUSE MOST OF THE
FOLKS THAT HAVE TESTIFIED OR
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD SO. THAT'S WHERE
THAT THAT PROGRAMS THAT HOUSE
AND THEY ARE GOING THROUGH THEIR
SCOPING PLAN AND- I AM FOREVER.
HOPEFUL THAT SOMETHING GOOD
COMES OUT THE SCOPING PLAN THIS
TIME BUT WE KNOW THAT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION ACTUALLY DOES THE
CITING OF THESE FACILITIES WE
KNOW THE- STATE WATER RESOURCES
BOARD IS DEALING WITH. WATER-
CONCERNS WE HAVE OTHER STATE
AGENCIES THAT HAVE JURISDICTION
OVER THESE THESE PLANTS- PENCE.
AND SOME OPERATIONS ACTUALLY
DON'T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD BECAUSE OF
BECAUSE THE USE. WHAT DO YOU YOU
SAY ABOUT. COORD OKAY WITH THAT
SAID. DO YOU THINK THAT THERE'S
A DOES OUR ABILITY OR AN
IMPROVEMENT THAT WE WOULD HAVE
THE IN COORDINATION WITH THESE
OTHER STATE AGENCIES THAT HAVE.
RESTRICTION OVER OVER IT- YEAH
OVER CITING BECAUSE PART OF THIS
IS JUST CITING AND- AND-
RESERVOIR- LOCATIONS AND THAT
CALCIUM IS ANOTHER STATE AGENCY
THAT THAT PLACE IN THIS ARENA.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND THE
OTHER AGENCY THAT'S GOING TO BE
PART OF THE DISCUSSION IS THE
STATE FARM FIRE MARSHAL BECAUSE
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR PIPES-
AND- THE SAFETY OF A- OF
CONDUCTING A- THE PRODUCT
THROUGH PIPES- IT'S A SUBJECT OF
A OF A LOT OF DISCUSSION THAT
THE WHOLE IDEA OF PUTTING IT
THROUGH TO THE IN THE AIRBOAR
IS BECAUSE THEY ARE THEY'RE
DOING THEY'RE SCOPING ANALYSIS
AND YOU HAVEN'T LCMS. BUT ALSO
ONE OF THE UP- REQUIREMENTS IS
THAT- IT LEAST AS WE AS I
ENVISION IT IS THAT WE ACTUALLY
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO DO CCS
THAT WE ALSO ENSURE THAT THE-
PARTICULATE. OF BY PRODUCTS- ARE
CAPTURED AND ARE REDUCED AS WELL
IN OTHER WORDS WE'RE NOT GIVING
UP ONE FOR THE OTHER AND THAT'S
REALLY IN THE JURISDICTION OF
THE AIRPORT AND SO IT'S THE
REASON THAT WAS THE REASONING
BEHIND PUTTING IT IN THE AIRPORT
BUT BUT ULTIMATELY- I BELIEVE
IT- WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO. A-
HAVE A PROCESS WHERE ALL THE
PERMITTING HAPPENS IN IN
TOGETHER- SIMULTANEOUSLY AND
THAT THE AGENCIES WORK TOGETHER.
YEAH I MEAN IF THE CHURCH IS ONE
OF THE ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE HEARD THAT THE DESIRE
STATED GOALS IS TO DEVELOPING
THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES OR AN ID
I HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
AIRPORT BEING THE LEAD. ON THE
DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGIES YOU KNOW
I MEAN I MIGHT BUILT USES THE
ENERGY COMMISSION TODAY TO DO IT
WITH THE CAN CONSULTATION FOR
EXACTLY I WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
PARTICULATES ARE REMOVED BUT
THEY-
LATER BUT THEY SAY OKAY. AFTER
THE PROJECT IS THERE. TELL THE
AIRPORT HOW IT REDUCES THE
PARTICULATE MATTER SINCE IT
DOESN'T IN THE AIRPORTS AS OKAY
YOU HAVE TO DO THAT- IT'S A- HEY
IT'S A GOOD FRAMEWORK I MEAN I'M
GOING TO ALL ARE MOVED TO BILL
HERE- IS I KNOW THAT THERE'S
WORK THAT HAS AT HAS TO BE DONE.
ON IT BUT I THINK THAT
PREDICTABILITY AND ALSO THE
MESSAGE THAT CALIFORNIA IS GOING
TO HAVE SOME FORM OF C. C. U. S.
RIGHT IN IN OUR PORTFOLIO
WHATEVER WHATEVER THAT HOWEVER
THAT GETS DEVELOPED IN I KNOW
THAT THE NEXT COMMITTEE HAS A
VERY BIG JOB ON THE BORDER
OWNERSHIP AND HELP THAT- IS
PLACE AND AGAIN THE PIPELINES IS
A WHOLE OTHER. THE DEAL THAT
WE'RE JUST NOT. IT'S YOU FOCUSED
ON IT YOU'VE TOUCHED ON IT BUT I
THINK THAT THAT'S NEEDS. SOME
WORK SO THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS.
YEAH I MISTER. FROM. THANKS
URBAN THIRTY APPRECIATE YOUR
OPENING REMARKS ESPECIALLY
SENATOR JUSTIN IN TERMS OF THE
NATURE OF THE WHOLE DISCUSSION
AND YOU PUT YOUR SHOULDER TO THE
WHEEL AND PUT IN SOME REALLY
SUBSTANTIVE FORD SO I APPRECIATE
THAT BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO I
WANT TO DO THE TO DIG INTO THE
PORE SPACE- DISCUSSION TOO MUCH
RIGHT NOW JUST GETTING INTO THE
NITTY GRITTY BECAUSE I'M HOPEFUL
WE CAN O THAT THROUGH. NATURAL
RESOURCES AND- JUST. HOW HOW TO
ACTUALLY MAKE IT WORK RIGHT IN A
MINERAL ESTATE AND THE LAND IS
STATE AND CONTRACTS PRIOR TO
THAT AND- SO. I WANT TO SET THAT
ONE ASIDE FOR THE- FUTURE THE-
THE QUESTIONS OR OR CONCERNS I
HAVE I THINK WE'RE- REALLY WILL
EXPLAIN THE HUMAN ANALYSIS I
MEAN I. IT ON PAGE- WHAT IS IT
ON PAGE FIVE VISITS- THE. YES
EIGHT FIVE I DIDN'T HEAR AYE AYE
MAYBE IT WAS A LISTENING CLOSELY
BUT- THERE'S A FEW QUESTIONS
ABOUT NOT JUST THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GOALS BUT AROUND- EOR
AND FOSSIL FUEL PRODUCTION I ASK
THE SAME QUESTION AS SENATOR
SKINNER WHEN HER BILL CAME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. SO THE
CONCERN I'VE HAD I HAVEN'T YOU
CAN. YOU DON'T YOU CAN DECIDE
HOW YOU WANT TO ADDRESS IT IT'S
MORE OF A COMMENT THAT A
QUESTION BUT- ESPECIALLYYOUR
CONTACTS WE GET A LOT OF CARBON
LOS. WHEN THE WHEN THE FIELDS
ARE OPEN RIGHT THAT CAN HAPPEN.
HOW DO WE CHAU CERTAINTY THAT
THAT CARBON'S ACTUALLY STAYING
THERE PERMANENTLY- SO LOOKING
FOR PERMANENCE AND LOOKING FOR
SOME KIND OF BACKSTOP ON THAT
PERMITS TO MAKE SURE THAT-
FOLKS. STATEWIDE NOT NINE DOES
NOT A LOCAL POLLUTION ISSUE BUT
STATEWIDE ARE ASSURED THAT A TON
IS REALLY A TON IN THE GROUND
THERE. AND YOU KNOW I KNOW THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THEY'VE LOOKED AT
SOME SUGGESTIONS AROUND BACKSTOP
OR SOME KIND OF PULLING YOUR
BUFFER ACCOUNT SO THAT IF
THERE'S A RELEASE. YOU'LL HAVE
SOME KIND OF RECOURSE FROM THE
OPERATOR SO THAT YOU'RE NOT SORT
OF STUCK IN THE SAME WITH
FORESTRY. PROJECTS WE'VE HAD
TROUBLE WITH WHERE YOU KNOW YOU
YOU BY A FEW MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE OFFICE AND IT BURNS UP AND
THEN. WE'RE LEVEL IN THE BACK SO
HOW TO SORT OF. BUILD THAT
CARBON RECOURSE IF YOU WILL.
INTO IT. SO THAT'S PERMITS ON
THE MORE STATEWIDE LEVEL I THINK
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE CONCERNS
I HAVE A REALLY ABOUT. THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THESE WORK
THROUGH THESE PROJECTS. THE
GOALS IN THE BILL DON'T DON'T
REALLY DELVE INTO- QUALITY AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUE- AND
I KNOW THAT THIS THE ANALYSIS.
FLOATED ALREADY BUT IN SOME
CASES YOU KNOW THESE ARE VERY
ENERGY INTENSIVE PROJECTS
CERTAINLY ON THE CAPTURE SIDE-
AND IT CAN BE ON THE STORAGE
SIDE AS WELL. AND WITH THAT
ENERGY USE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
GENERATE THAT POWER FROM
SOMEWHERE SO THESE ARE PROJECTS
THAT INTERIOR GOING TO HAVE. AIR
QUALITY IMPACTS ON ALREADY
BURDENED COMMUNITIES- AND I WANT
TO BE. SURE THAT. I'M WE'RE NOT
EXTENDING. WERE SUBSIDIZING IN
ANY WAY- PROJECTS THAT YOU KNOW
OR OTHERWISE DETRIMENTAL TO THE
COMMUNITY SO- I AM CONCERNED IF
WE'RE GOING TO BE SAY ENHANCING
THE REVENUES OF AN OIL COMPANY.
FOR THEIR ENHANCE STORE RECOVERY
PROJECT THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
TAKE CREDIT FOR IT FROM FORTY
FIVE Q. ON THE ONE END. AND THEN
FROM SB THIRTY TWO ON THE OTHER
AND THEN THE COMMUNITY ITSELF
WILL GET LEFT BEHIND AND SO
THAT'S THE SORT OF ESSENCE OF MY
CONCERN. BUT I JUST WANT TO. I
KNOW THAT THESE ARE TOUGH
POLITICS I KNOW THAT THESE
THERE'S TOUGH POLICY HERE TO. I
APPRECIATE. YOU KNOW. YOUR YOUR
LABORING ON THIS AND- AND I
THINK THERE'S A WAY TO DO IT-
BUT BUT HAVING THOSE ASSURANCES
AROUND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
AND THEN HAVE IT BE HAVING SOME
CERTAINTY AROUND THE BROADER
CARBON PERMANENCE I THINK FOR
MANY Q. PERSPECTIVE OR MY MAIN
ISSUES AT THIS POINT. THANKS FOR
THE THANKS FOR TO THE COMMITTEE
STEP BY THE WAY FOR THEIR DEEP
DIVE ANY ANALYSIS IT'S VERY
INFORMATIVE GOING FOR TWO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I TO WANNA
I WANNA THANK YOU SENATOR I KNOW
WE HAVE BEEN IN THIS GROUP FOR
SOME TIME AND THIS. CAME UP- AND
YOUR WORKING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS SO I THINK YOU KNOW
YOU'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK IN
THIS AND I KNOW YOU'RE
COMMITTED. TO CONTINUING TO
NEGOTIATE AND- I JUST HAVE TO
GET CLEAR ON A FEW THINGS AND
ASK A FEW QUESTIONS- BUT THE
FIRST IS OF COURSE ON THE
ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
STILL NEGOTIATING THAT. IT
NEARLY IN THIS BILL IS IT AND AS
AND AS IT IS IN PRINT JUST THE
PRIORITIZE IS AT THIS POINT. NOT
IT STILL ALLOWS ESSENTIALLY- SO
THAT TO ME IS A HUGE ISSUE JUST
GIVEN. A LOT OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
OBVIOUSLY I KNOW YOU KNOW THAT-
BUT WHAT. IS THE VISION FOR THIS
IF IT'S NOT GOING TO BE ENHANCED
OIL RECOVERY. I MEAN I KNOW WE
WANT TO REDUCE. EMISSIONS OF
COURSE BUT HOW I MEAN WHAT. AND
HOW DOES THAT REFLECT WHEN. WITH
THESE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES MANY OF WHICH I
REPRESENT YOU REPRESENT MANY OF
US DO. TO SELL THIS BACK HOME TO
SAY YOU KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN INVEST IN KNOWING
THAT THERE'S NEW TECHNOLOGY ON
THE HORIZON THAT MAY BE MORE
BENEFICIAL FOR THEM AND I KNOW
WE'VE GOT TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN I'VE HEARD. LOUD AND CLEAR
FROM EVERYONE WE HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN. BUT WHAT WHAT
IS THAT VISION FOR THEM. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
APPRECIATE IT. SO I THOUGHT THAT
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DID A
REALLY ELEGANT. JOB OF THEM AND
I AGREE WITH SENATOR STERN I
THOUGHT THE ANALYSIS WAS REALLY
WELL DONE IT'S A COMPLICATED
ISSUE. BECAUSE CARBON
SEQUESTRATION CAN- CAN.
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE POLLUTION
IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES- SO LET ME JUST START
OFF BY SAYING IT'S NOT MY
INTENT. WELL SO WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS DONE I'M GOOD AT
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO DO WITH
THIS BILL RIGHT NOW- GIVEN THAT
WE HAVEN'T FINISHED THE
NEGOTIATION PROCESS. IS TO
MIRROR WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS DOING. BECAUSE
LIKE IT OR NOT IT IS IT IS
COMING THEY ARE ACCEPTING
APPLICATIONS AND THEY'RE WORKING
THROUGH A PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO
PERMIT- CARBON CAPTURE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AND SO WE
NEED TO MEET THEM AS PARTNERS
AND FIGURE OUT EXACTLY HOW YOU
WANT IT TO OPERATE. FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL- THERE THERE
FUNDING PROGRAM IS- A TAX CREDIT
IT'S CALLED FORTY FIVE Q. AND
THAT FORTY FIVE Q. AS IT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT AS IT IS PASSED
TODAY THE FUNDING FOR THAT.DID
NOT INCLUDE ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY- I'M AND- M. IT MIGHT
MY COMMITMENT IN TERMS OF STATE
FUNDS AND MY A BILL DOES NOT
TALK. TO STATE FUNDS IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE A- A REQUIREMENT THAT
THE STATE PONY UP SOME MONEY I
EXPECT AT SOME POINT POINT WHAT
IT IT WILL BUT- IF IT DID IT IT
WOULD MAYOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- AND. NOT- NOT ALLOW
. THE STATE TO USE ANY OF THE
RESOURCES FOR ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY I THINK IT I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S- CONSISTENT WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND I'M
OKAY WITH THAT- THE- ANY
NEGOTIATION REQUIRES GIVE AND
TAKE SO I GIVE YOU SOMETHING
THAT I GET SOMETHING IN RETURN
AND SO THAT'S PART OF THE
NEGOTIATION ON THE ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY JUST AS A STATEMENT IN
A BILL- AND THAT'S PART OF THE
NEGOTIATION I EXPECT IT'S GOING
TO BE FINISHED- AND THAT THAT
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE TWO TO
THREE WEEKS WILL HAVE THE
STATEMENT ABOUT WHERE WE WANT-
ALL ALL OF. OUR- DISCUSSION
ABOUT BOTH CARBON CAPTURE AND
BIOMASS AND IN OTHER WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE GRID
RELIABILITY. AND THAT WE'RE
CLEANING OUR AIR AND WE'RE
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS ALL OF
THAT WILL BE WILL BE WRAPPED UP
SO. AM I IT'S A IT'S A WAY
AROUND THE BACK DOOR TO EXPLAIN.
AN ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY BUT I'M
IT IT IS NOT- I FIND THE
EMPHASIZING ENERGY PRIORITIZING
IT MAKING IT THE ABSOLUTE LAST
PRIORITY- S. AS THAT A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT WAS IT WAS AN ELEGANT
WAY TO DEAL WITH IT AND- YOU
KNOW BEEN FRANKLY I WANT I WANT
THE BILL TO MOVE SO THAT WE CAN
FINISH THE NEGOTIATIONS AND- AND
THEN. TO DO WHATEVER WE NEED TO
DO WITH ENHANCE OUR RECOVERY.
YES AND I THINK THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF THAT AND I THINK
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT THE
ANALYSIS DID INCLUDE- A LOT OF
GREAT INFORMATION I THINK FOR ME
AT LEAST IN TERMS OF THE NEW
TECH I WAS TRY TO LOOK AHEAD YOU
KNOW. THE NEW TECHNOLOGY WHAT
CAN BE IMPROVED- AND HOW WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THERE'S JOBS THERE
BUT THAT ARE ALSO REDUCING IN
CAPTURING EMISSIONS DOING BOTH
NOT JUST THE REDUCTION BUT
CAPTURING MA'AM AND- DOING ALL
OF THAT BUT- I THINK SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE GET MENTIONED IN HIS
BILL I THINK BECAUSE THERE'S
QUITE A FEW MOVING IN THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE KNOW. THERE
IS- A HE'S LOOKING AT THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY SORT OF SIDE OF
THINGS AT A TO BE HOUSED WITHIN
THE ENERGY COMMISSION WHICH I
THINK THIS MIGHT BE YOU KNOW
BETTER OPPORTUNITY BUT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT OTHER. IT I DON'T KNOW
IF MAYBE YOUR SUPPORTERS AS WELL
COULD MAYBE ANSWER THIS TO LIKE
WHAT IS THE HORIZON FOR THAT NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND HEARING DIFFERENT
THINGS LIKE WHAT CAN WE LOOK FOR
TO IN TERMS OF THE TIMELINE FOR
THAT STRATEGY HORIZON. IN IN NEW
TECHNOLOGY- I MY EXPERT ON THE
ON THE PHONE I'M NOT SURE SHE
SAID ON THE PHONE- BUT- I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION. I
CAN ANSWER IT MYSELF I WHAT I DO
KNOW HERE HERE'S HERE'S- MY
ANALYSIS OF THAT. OF AN ANSWER
THAT'S NOT TOTALLY COMPLETE BUT-
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE- THE
THINGS I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IS. A GRID RELIABILITY
FOR ME MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
WORK FORCE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
INTO A GREEN TECHNOLOGY. AT THE
LEVEL AT WHICH THEY HAVE BEEN
TRAINED RATHER THAN AT A AT A
REALLY LOWER LEVEL WHERE THEY
CANNOT SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES.
BUT THE OTHER PART IS TO SIGNAL
TO THE MARKET IF THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITTED TO. SO THAT WE GET THE
INVESTMENT APART FROM THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- IN TECHNOLOGY
THAT WILL HELP US TO ACHIEVE OUR
GOALS AND THAT'S- THAT'S PART OF
A TICKET REALLY BEING ABLE TO
SAY WE THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THESE GOALS WE
SET GOALS WITHOUT KNOWING IF
WE'D EVER GET THERE. AND WE SET
GOALS WITHOUT HAVING ANY OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. THAT WOULD THAT YOU
COULD POINT TO SAY WE'RE GONNA
GET THERE- WE JUST KNEW WE HAD
TO WE HAD TO DO IT AND THIS IS
PART OF THAT. THAT MOVEMENT
WHICH IS TO SIGNAL TO THE MARKET
THE CALIFORNIA IS- IS. WE EXPECT
THE HIGHEST QUALITY WE EXPECT
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO MEET YOUR-
YOUR- YOUR TARGETS AND- WILL
HOLD YOU TO THEM. AND WHAT WILL
SET SOME REAL HIGH STANDARDS FOR
IT AND THAT'S WHAT WE DO THE
BEST AND SO THAT'S WHY THIS IS.
IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
REALLY DOES CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. TO HAVE THE
INVESTMENT HAPPENING CALIFORNIA
AND TO HAVE IT IT- ARE LEADING
SCIENTISTS INVOLVED. AND AS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE OUR MAJOR
UNIVERSITIES THAT ARE WORKING ON
ON ON THIS ON THE TECHNOLOGY AND
THAT ARE ARE. TALKING ABOUT IT.
I THINK THERE I AM FROM ANOTHER
A NEW TECHNOLOGY TO TALK ABOUT
ARE THINGS LIKE DIRECT AIR
CAPTURE AND THE HYDROGEN ECONOMY
AND HONESTLY- DIRECTOR CAPTURED
CAPTURED HERE TO FROM AMBIENT
AIR YOU'LL STILL NEED A PLACE TO
PUT IT USED ON THE THAT'S THE
QUESTION- AT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS COMING IN THE FUTURE IT
WILL BE HUGE HOWEVER WE STILL
NEED TO GET THE GEOLOGIC
SEQUESTRATION PROGRAM UP AND
RUNNING SO THAT WE CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THINGS LIKE THAT IN
THE FUTURE. I THINK THAT CHRIS
HAD SOMETHING ELSE TO MENTION AS
WELL. THE YOU KNOW SERWIS-
REPRESENTATION OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES. THERE THERE'S MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS WERE GREENHOUSE
GASES ARE EMITTED SOME IS FROM
TRANSPORTATION SOME AS FROM-
ENERGY PRODUCTION SOME IS FOR
MANUFACTURING SOMERS FROM
AGRICULTURE- THERE'S THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE BETTER WITH
GREEN HYDROGEN STEEL PRODUCTION-
CEMENT PRODUCTION BUT YOU CANNOT
ELIMINATE- GREENHOUSE GASES
COMPLETELY YESTERDAY I WAS AT A
GROUNDBREAKING FOR A LIGHT RAIL
LINE IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
WHICH IS GONNA NEED STEEL IT'S
GONNA NEED CONCRETE. TO BE ABLE
TO HELP US MOVE TRANSPORTATION
AND MOVE CLEANER TRANSPORTATION
BUT WE STILL NEED STEEL AND WE
NEED STILL THAT'S PRODUCED
LOCALLY WE STILL NEED CONCRETE
AND THERE THERE'S JUST CERTAIN
THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO I MET
GREENHOUSE GASES CARBON CAPTURE
MITIGATES THOSE AND THAT'S THE
TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE NOW WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE WORKING
TOGETHER LIKE WE ARE IN THE
APPLICATION. TO EXPAND GREEN
HIGHER CHEN AND HAVE CALIFORNIA
BE A LEADER ON IT AS WELL AS ALL
OTHER FORMS BUT YOU KNOW THAT
THERE THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS
WE NEED- AND WE NEED.
ALTERNATIVE FUELS NOW AND WE
NEED. CARBON CAPTURE NOW FOR
THAT THANK YOU. YEAH I THANK YOU
AND I AND I WOULD I LIKE TO KIND
OF KEEP PLEASE FEEL FREE TO JUMP
BACK IN- CENTER GONZALEZ AS
BECAUSE I DO WANNA SPEND MORE
TIME DISCUSSING. THIS YOU
CONTROVERSIAL BILL I MEAN I
THINK I'M HERE TO BE HONEST I AM
. YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN OUR GENERAL
FEELING AS A COMMITTEE THAT- WE
OUGHT TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP WORKING ON
THIS WE UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF VERY INTENSE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH. CENTER THE
MONNING CENTER MCGUIRE IS PART
OF THIS SUB COMMITTEE OF THE
CLIMATE WORKING GROUP OF WHICH
MANY OF US ARE A MEMBER- THERE'S
A- KIND OF A- POTENTIAL GRAND
BARGAIN TO BE STRUCK I THINK
THEY'VE CENTER LEMOND'S BILLS A
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THAT.
THAT STORY- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE. YOUR STIPULATION AND
AGREEMENT THAT THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT THAT THERE WILL CERTAINLY
BE NO STATE MONEY ASSOCIATED
WITH THE L. R. ASSOCIATE WITH
THIS BILL- YOU KNOW THAT THE SO
THAT THAT THAT'S CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT AND WE ALSO KNOW
COURSE THE BILL'S GOING OVER TO
NATURISTS HORSES AND I WOULD.
HAVE BEEN CERTAINLY ASK AND
EXPECT YOU TO WORK WITH THE
CHAIR TO MAKE SURE THAT A NUMBER
OF THE- RECOVERY OIL EXTRACTION
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BOTH IN THE ANALYSIS. AND BY THE
PREVIOUS TWO. I SPEAKERS WILL BE
WILL BE WORKED ON AND ADDRESS
AND I MEAN I THINK ULTIMATELY
THIS IS AN UNUSUAL KIND OF BILL
IT'S NOT A STANDALONE BILL
BECAUSE IT'S PART OF THE BROADER
CONTEXT OF THIS. CLIMATE WORKING
GROUP NEGOTIATION AND WE WANT TO
GIVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO. TAKE
TO KEEP YOUR VEHICLE MOVING-
WITHIN THAT CONTEXT- SO
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING THAT I'M ON IT
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY- I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE- NATURIST
ARSES IN WATER COMMITTEE AND-
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
ABLE TO STRIKE A DEAL. ON ON
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT I'VE
BEEN RAISED BY. THE CHAIR OF
THAT COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW WHEN A
BILL GOES OVER THERE. I'M I MAY
DO I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU'RE HEARING.
CONSISTENTLY HERE IS. YOU KNOW
ENSURING AND I WAS ABOUT A LOT
OF FRIENDS FROM THE OIL INDUSTRY
THAT ARE HERE THAT ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN THIS BILL. I AND-
YOU KNOW WHILE IT'S BEING
PRESENTED AS A PRO CLIMATE
MEASURE RIGHT WE NEED TO. ENGAGE
IN THIS TO ADDRESS OUR CLIMATE
NEEDS IS AS ELOQUENTLY STATED BY
OUR FRIEND FROM THE BUILDING
TRADES- WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THIS IS NOT USED AS A-
EXCUSE TO OR OR OR JUSTIFICATION
FOR. DOUBLING DOWN ON. ON FOSSIL
FUELS. ARE WHICH WE NOW ARE YOU
KNOW SUCH A DRAMATIC CONTRIBUTOR
TO THE CLIMATE CHANGE AND THAT'S
I THINK THE CHALLENGE HERE RIGHT
ABOUT THAT SADDAM'S WITH YOUR
BILL TO BE HONEST. I'M GIVEN THE
POSTURE OF OUR COMMITTEE AND OUR
CONCERNS HERE ON ON ON THE
CLIMATE ISSUES AND SO. ON IF I
COULD I GUESS PLEASE I AGREE
WITH THAT I MEAN I DO I A. M. I
UNDERSTAND. THE CONCERN- I THINK
THAT THAT THE BILL RIGHT NOW. IT
DOESN'T- IT IT IT'S NOT A SIGNAL
THAT THAT YOU ARE IS- THE
ENHANCE OUR RECOVERY IS-
SOMETHING THAT EITHER IS GOING
TO BE FUNDED BY THE STATE OR
THIS GOING TO BE PART OF THE
FRAMEWORK THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
HERE TODAY- BUT- AND I HATE.
WHEN I'M LOOKING FOR IS A
TRANSITION AWAY FROM. FOSSIL
FUELS THAT GIVES US SOME STEPS
TO BE ABLE TO GET THERE. I'M
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO IS. I
THINK I THINK ALL THE EXPERTS
AGREE. THAT WE CAN'T REACH OUR
CLIMATE GOALS GIVEN WHERE WE'RE
AT TODAY. ME NOT THAT I HAVEN'T
HEARD ANY DISAGREEMENT WHERE
PEOPLE SAY YEAH YOU COULD- AND
YOU CAN DO IT IN A WAY THAT THAT
IS IN A CRIPPLING THE ECONOMY.
AND SO WE NEED TO I MEAN THAT
THIS IS IF THERE'S ONE THING
ABOUT CALIFORNIA IT'S THAT WE'RE
WE'RE RISK TAKERS AND WE GET OUT
THERE WE GET THINGS DONE. RIGHT
I GUESS WE DO WANT TO BE CAREFUL
TO CONSIDER THE RISK RIGHT I
MEAN I GUESS ABSOLUTE I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS THAT HOW DO WE
MAKE I MEAN HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT THAT. YOUR EFFORTS. I'M
DON'T END UP- LOCKING IN LIKE A
LONGER TERM DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL
FUEL. I DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL
FUELS VIA I MEAN I IT'S C. I.
CALIFORNIA I MEAN I LOOK AT IT
AS- WE HAVE MADE A COMMITMENT TO
BE GREENER. BUT BUT BUT PART OF
THAT COMMITMENT HAS BEEN TO
EXCLUDE. SOLUTIONS BETTER
LOGICAL AND THEY GET US THE IN
IN IN INCREMENTAL STEPS TO WHERE
WE WANT TO GO. AND IT'S EITHER
SOLAR OR ITS WIND AND THAT'S ALL
THERE IS AND YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME IS WE
NEVER TALK ABOUT THEM WILDLIFE
IMPACTS OF THOSE TWO TYPES OF
ENERGY. I DON'T ONE IS YOU KNOW
MAKE A BIG DEAL ABOUT IT BUT
WHEN YOU'RE KILLING BIRDS AND
THEN YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE HAVING
TO. TECT SOLAR- ARRAYS BY
PUTTING UP FENCES YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE DISTURBING WILDLIFE
YOU'RE NOT YEAH- ALLOWING THE
LAND IS WHY YOU'RE BIG
SUPPORTIVE ROOFTOP SO INSTEAD OF
IT DOES YEAH ABSOLUTELY I AM I
AM OKAY I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF
THE P. S. B. YOU SEE THAT NO I
WILL I WILL CERTAINLY BUT BUT
BUT BUT IT'S GOT ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES AND SO WE CAN'T BE
PURISTS IN THAT IN THE IN THE
STRICTEST SENSE WE'VE GOT TO BE
LOGICAL IT'S GOTTA MAKE SENSE
WE'VE GT TO BE DOING THINGS
THAT- THAT WE WERE WE TO REDUCE
THE RISK THE RISK OF BLACKOUTS
AND BROWNOUTS- THE RISK. THAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO PAY. THE
RATES ARE GOING TO BE SO HIGH
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE EATEN NOT
ECONOMICAL FOR THEM AND HEATER
OR TO CALL THEIR THEIR UNITS IN
IN MY DISTRICT HAS SOME OF THE
HOTTEST TEMPERATURES IN THE
SUMMER IN THE COLDEST
TEMPERATURES IN THE WINTER. SO I
WANT A GRADE THAT'S RELIABLE I
WANT. JAVA JOBS FOR PEOPLE AND I
AND I WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
TRANSITION NATURALLY WITHOUT
HAVING TO CREATE A FUND. SO THAT
WHEN THEY BECOME UNEMPLOYED WE
GIVE THEM A HAND OUT THAT'S ONE
HUNDRED AND YOURSELF. PARDON ME
OF EQUITY FUND IS IN THE BILL
YOU'RE DOING WITH CENTER LAYERED
IT IS NOT IT IS THAT THERE THIRD
THERE ARE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
MOVING PIECES AND SO THE- I MEAN
YES THAT WE GOT TO THAT RIGHT
AWAY AND I WILL TELL YOU MY
FRUSTRATION IS THAT. WE PUT
CARBON CAPTURE BECAUSE IT WAS SO
CLOSE SO COMPLICATED AS ONE OF
THE LAST THINGS THAT WE LOOK AT
AND WE IT'S JUST HASN'T HAPPENED
AND SO. YEAH IT'S A IT'S A
CIRCUMSTANCE OF TIMING AND SO I
DO A POP I UNDERSTAND. HOW HOW-
HOW CHALLENGE THIS IS- FOR SOME
PEOPLE BUT I'M JUST ASKING FOR
SOME PRACTICAL- AT FIRST FOR A
PRACTICAL. LOOK AT HOW THIS
WOULD WORK. AND WE'RE NOT DONE
YET. YOU KNOW WHAT. I'VE GOT TO
GET PAST AS SENATOR STERN. YOU
KNOW. AND AND I THINK BY THE
TIME TIME WELL. DEPENDS ON WHEN
THE HEARING. BUT BUT BUT I YOU
KNOW THERE WILL BE CHANGED TO
THE BILL. THAT'S THE POINT. OKAY
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I AND IS
THIS A AYE. AYE- YEAH. AND
HONESTLY TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
I DON'T SEE THIS BILL AS A- GO
PAST WHAT IS IT GO PAST JAIL OR
WHATEVER GET OUT OF JAIL- TO THE
OIL INDUSTRY AT ALL RIGHT ARE
THEY INTERESTED IN THIS
ABSOLUTELY AND- AND BUT BUT THIS
BILL DOESN'T DOESN'T ADDRESS.
DOESN'T GIVE THEM THAT GO PAST-
GET GET OUT OF JERICHO I THINK
THE KIDS ARE I MEAN LOOK WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY IN
OUR CONVERSATION. ON THE
CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY- OUR
LITTLE ON THE PHONE BUT I'VE HAD
A MEETING WITH THEM SO I GOT TO
HEAR SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THEM IS THAT. THIS
TECHNOLOGY PROMISES A LOT AND
DOESN'T END UP DELIVERING IN ITS
APPLICATION. I'M CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW- YOU KNOW. HERE I AM
WORKING ON A PLASTICS BILL
THAT'S ULTIMATELY VERY.
DEPENDENT UPON INNOVATOR
STEPPING UP AND YOU KNOW BEING
ABLE TO SCALE. OUR TECHNOLOGY
THAT- THAT REALLY WILL MEET THE
GOALS THAT WE HAVE. OF COURSE IN
THAT CASE- THEY'VE GOT. EXIT
ARE. YOU READY TO GO TO MARKET-
BUT ONE OF THE POINTS THAT SOME
OF THE FOLKS IN THE FINAL
COMMITTEE OF RACES THAT- THAT
DAILY SO FAR. WITH THE UCCS HAS
HAS CONSISTENTLY UNDER DELIVERED
IN TERMS OF. OF ITS OF ITS
CLIMATE- BENEFITS ADOPTING SAID
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO INNOVATE INTO
BETTER. I'M WE DO NEED. A LOTS
OF TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL. AND
I'M IN THE END OF THE DAY YOU
KNOW I KNOW THAT YOU'RE- YEAH I
KNOW I KNOW YOU'RE NOT A- MEMBER
OF THIS OF THIS CLUB IS WORKING
GROUP IN AND WORKING REALLY HARD
ON THE INTERNET. TO GET- OF
THESE ISSUES RESOLVED WITH
SENATOR LIMÓN AND OTHERS SO- SO
. YEAH SENATE ON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND SENATOR- I'M
OR START THIS BILL HAS A LOT OF
THE- WHICH I AM. EXCITED ABOUT
I'M EXCITED ABOUT HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS WE SHOULD HAVE HAD
. BEFORE WE SET TARGETS AND TALK
ABOUT AND I KNOW THERE'S A NEW
TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN THIS THIS BILL
BUT I JUST WANT TO GO ON RECORD.
FOR THE COMMITTEE THAT HAS. HAS
GRAPPLED WITH OIL IN CALIFORNIA
AND I AND I HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR
SOME TIME AND WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT EXECUTIVE ORDERS WE TALK
ABOUT GETTING WHERE WE WANT TO
GO IN CALIFORNIA LEADING AS A
STATE AND TRYING TO LEAD THE
WORLD. IN THIS DIRECTION WE PUT
WE PRODUCE 1% OF THE GHG FOR THE
WORLD. BUT WE ALSO HAVE TARGET
TO SAY BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE NON
COMBUSTIBLE. NOT FOR SALE IN
CALIFORNIA CARS THAT ARE USED
COMMERCIAL INTERESTS THAT IS
AGGRESSIVE. WHEN WE HAVE A GREAT
DAY DOESN'T WORK AND TEACH YOU
WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT ABOUT WE
LOVE SOLAR WE LOVE NGUYEN.
BIOMASS NOT SO MUCH A LOT OF A
LOT OF FOLKS OUT THERE DON'T
LIKE THAT EVEN THOUGH. WE KNOW
THAT WE CAN SEQUESTER CARBON AT
A HIGHER RATE WE ACTUALLY THIN
THE FOREST. BECAUSE THE TREES
GROW FASTER NAY SEQUESTER CARBON
THAT CARBON STORAGE. AND WE
DON'T LOOK AT THAT AND THEN AND
THEN INTO. THE SENATOR STERN'S
COMMENTS ABOUT WE BUY THOSE
CREDITS IN AN IT BURNS UP AND
THEN WE WOULD- THOSE THOSE ARE
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
HAD. A LONG BEFORE WE'RE HERE
WE'RE AT TODAY. AND WE DON'T
HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS AS WE SET
TARGETS. AS CALIFORNIA'S IN THE
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHERE WE'RE
GOING. AND SO I COMMEND YOU. FOR
TAKING ON A TOPIC AND I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME OTHER MEMBERS
THAT ARE CARRYING LEGISLATION
BUT I THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY. AT THE END OF THE DAY WHEN
IT COMES TO CALIFORNIANS. WHO
ARE. DEALING WITH THE COST OF
FUEL TODAY. BECAUSE OF OUR
POLICIES. AND THEN LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT WHEN WE
IMPORT. OIL FROM ECUADOR HAS NO
REGULATIONS ON IT AT ALL LIKE
THEY DO IN CALIFORNIA AND
DESTROYING THE AMAZON RAINFOREST
WHILE WE HAVE. LABOR AND FOLKS
WHO CAN EXTRACT OIL IN
CALIFORNIA'S SAFER THAN ANYWHERE
IN THE WORLD. AND NOT HAVE TO
PUT IT ON A SHIP. BRING IT HERE
AND WE FIND IT HERE. THIS IS
CYCLE THAT'S CRAZY WHAT WE
TALKING ABOUT HERE LET'S TALK
COMMON SENSE AND THUS GET DOWN
AND WORK ON THESE ISSUES AND-
STOP ARE BIASED TOWARDS. ONE
TECHNOLOGY OR OR ANOTHER. AND
LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO GET WE'RE GOING TO GO SO IF
WE WANT TO GET TO WHERE I WANT
TO GET IS I'D LOVE TO GET TO.
ELECTRIC CARS BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET
THERE BECAUSE OUR GRID. IS NOT
THE SHAPE IT NEEDS TO BE IN WE
QUITE FRANKLY BILL TRANSMISSION
LINES IN THE STATE. WE ARE OVER
PRODUCING POWER. IN SOME PARTS
OF OUR STATE BECAUSE WE HAVE
MORE SOLAR THERE THAN AND WE
CAN'T GET THE POWER TO WHERE WE
NEED IT. DURING THE TIME OF DAY
THAT WE NEED ALL WE HAVE TO DO
IS. BUILD A TRANSMISSION LINE.
AND WE HAVE THE LABOR FORCE TO
DO IT. BUT WE HAVE WE DON'T HAVE
THE ENVIRONMENT HE STOPS LL
THOSE. BOTH WAYS TO GET THERE IF
YOU REALLY WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT TO LOOK AT THE
STATE HOLISTICALLY. AND SAY
WHERE DO WE NEED THE POWER WHEN
WE NEED IT AND- HOW ARE WE GOING
TO GET THERE SO. I'VE BEEN SO
FRUSTRATED OVER THE YEARS
SITTING ON THIS COMMITTEE
TALKING ABOUT ONE. ONE SOLUTION.
TO A REALLY COMPLICATED PROBLEM.
STATEWIDE I THINK YOU'RE ON TO
SOMETHING HERE AND I THINK WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT OIL. I THINK WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT. CALIFORNIA
WILL. PRODUCING OIL HERE UNTIL
WE CAN GET TO THE POINT WHERE WE
DON'T NEED IT. WHICH WE WILL
NEVER GET THERE. YOU'RE NOT
GONNA FLY ELECTRIC PLANUM TELL
YOU THAT RIGHT NOW. IT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN AGAIN ONLINE. YEAH
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN SO LET'S
BE REAL AND LET'S BE HONEST WITH
CALIFORNIANS. BECAUSE THEY'RE
QUESTIONING WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE
THE ELECTRIC RATES ARE HIGH.
THEIR FUEL IS HIGH AND IT'S
BECAUSE THE POLICIES THAT COME
OUT HERE. SO I'M ON YOUR TEAM
I'M GONNA VOTE FOR YOUR BILL
TODAY AND I'M I KNOW ONE IS SEND
A MESSAGE TO THE LABOR
COMMUNITY. INTO THE OIL
COMMUNITY. BECAUSE THEY'RE LINED
UP TODAY. BUT WE NEED WE NEED
REAL SOLUTIONS WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT. THE GRID. WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT BIOMASS WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE TO
REEK TO CAPTURE FROM THESE ARE
ALL SHOULD BE IN THIS IN THESE
TALKING POINTS AND I KNOW THAT
IT'S GOING TO NOT TO RESOURCES
WERE A LOT OF THAT CONVERSATION
IS GOING TO BE HAD BUT WE CAN'T
JUST BE PURIST IN CALIFORNIA AND
SAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE THAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IT THIS WAY WHEN
IT'S REALLY COMPLICATED AND WE-
WE NEED TO WEAN OURSELVES. OFF
OF. THESE PRODUCTS THAT WE USE
IN A MANNER THAT KEEPS
CALIFORNIANS. ABLE TO LIVE HERE
IF YOU'RE ON A FIXED INCOME. IF
YOU RETIRED ON A FIXED INCOME
YOUR STRUGGLING IN CALIFORNIA
DAY AND IS QUITE FRANKLY
BECAUSE- OUR ENERGY COST AND ARE
IN A COST OF LIVING I HIGH IN
CALIFORNIA IF YOU'RE A WILL
HOURLY WAGE EARNER. YOU HAVE THE
SAME PROBLEM. WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON THOSE FOLKS BECAUSE THEY'RE
HURTING. HURTING REALLY BAD
TODAY AND SO I'M HAPPY TO SEE
THIS MOVEMENT FOR I'M SUPPORT
TODAY BUT I THINK WE REALLY NEED
TO SIT DOWN AND OUT I DON'T KNOW
THERE'S A WORKING GROUP BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO NOT HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS I MEAN YOU SAY YES
TO SOME THINGS THAT'LL GET US
THERE OVER THE LONG HAUL SO. I
COMMEND YOU I AND I AM EXCITED
ABOUT RELEASE I KNOW YOU'LL DIG
IN IT AND AS THE CENTER SAID PUT
YOUR SHOULDER TO THE WHEEL WHEN
IT COMES TO MAKING HARD
DECISIONS YOU YOU CARE THOSE
KIND OF BILLS AND I WANT TO BE
ON YOUR TEAM TO GET US THERE SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SKINNER
THANK YOU. MICHAEL THANK YOU I'M
HAS ANYONE MOVE THE BILL YET. I
HAVE. BUT NO I CAN'T WE CAN'T
I'M SORRY YOUR CALF YEAH SORRY
GREAT BECAUSE OTHERWISE I WAS
GOING WITH THE BILL YEAH- HEY.
FIVE THE CLIMATE CRISIS IS SO
SEVERE WE NEED EVERY TOOL AND WE
ARE I AM A COMPLETE- IT
COMPLETELY COMMITTED TO
TRANSITIONING OFF FOSSIL FUELS
BUT WE ARE IN THE MIDST RIGHT
NOW OF STILL NEEDING. WHETHER
IT'S CEMENT CONCRETE STEEL YOU
NAME IT FOUR WHETHER IT'S TO-
YOU KNOW FIX OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILD NEW HOUSING. AND WE'RE NOT
AT THE PLACE WHERE WE HAVE
EITHER FIGURED OUT HOW TO DO
THOSE PRODUCTIONS WITHOUT ANY
FOSSIL FUEL OR WITHOUT ANY
CARBON EMISSIONS I MEAN CEMENT
FOR EXAMPLE HAS IT IN PROCESS
EMISSIONS- AND- YET WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO HAVE THAT CARBON GOING
TO THE ATMOSPHERE. NOW CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE IS A
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS. IT HAS I
THINK ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE- UTILITY
GRADE BATTERIES WHEN I DID THE
BILL ON UTILITY GREED BATTERIES
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE.
HE WORKED AVAILABLE THEY WERE
POLITE YET THEY WERE IN YET NOW
CALIFORNIA'S THE LEADER AND
UTILIZED- GLOBALLY AND- WE HAVE
TO GET TO THAT PLACE WITH CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE. NOT AS A
REPLACEMENT TO REDUCTION. BUT IN
THE NORWEGIAN THAT WE HAVE TO
GET KEEP THAT CARBON FROM
GETTING INTO THE ATMOSPHERE. SO
THAT'S WHY I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL. I DO NOT
WANT TO USE CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE AT ALL FOR- ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY I DON'T THINK THAT'S
APPROPRIATE BUT I DO THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO USE IT IN CERTAIN
OF OUR TECHNOLOGIES. THAT FOR
WHICH WE DON'T HAVE YOU KNOW
ONCE WE'VE- FULLY EITHER VENICE
SUFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE WITH THEM
OR- YOU KNOW FULLY REDUCE THE
EMISSIONS AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
THAT WE UTILIZE THIS AND WE SEE
OTHER COUNTRIES BEGINNING TO
MAKE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS WE
SEE A LOT OF RESEARCH THERE'S A
GREAT REPORT IT CITED THE
ANALYSIS FROM LAWRENCE BERKELEY
NATIONAL LAB- AND I. TOTALLY
APPRECIATE THE FIERCE THAT. IT
WOULD POTENTIALLY PROP UP THE
FOSSIL FUEL SYSTEM BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
CASE I THINK WE ARE IN THAT
TRANSITION BUT THAT TRANSITIONS
GOING TO TAKE AWHILE AND WE NEED
TO GET THE CARBON PREVENTED FROM
GOING THE ATMOSPHERE. SO. AGAIN
I APPRECIATE THAT FOR SOME
PEOPLE THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT SHOULD BE
LIKE- NEVER TOUCH IT HANDS OFF
BUT I THINK WE- THE CRISIS IS SO
SEVERE RIGHT NOW. THAT WE HAVE
GOT TO USE EVERY TOOL IN THE
TOOLKIT. AND THAT'S WHY I'M
SUPPORTING IT BUT AS I SAID WELL
THE BILL DOESN'T COMPLETELY
PROHIBIT. THE OIL AND GAS I MEAN
THE OIL RECOVERY. ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT
IT DOESN'T GET UTILIZED FOR THAT
PURPOSE BUT I CERTAINLY. THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR MOST AT
OTHER OF OUR TECHNOLOGIES AND-
THAT'S WHY I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL THANK YOU. AND SENATOR
JUST I KNOW THAT YOU'RE HERE BUT
THE AUTHOR DID. JUST SAY ON THE
ON THE ON THE DIETS THAT TIME
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO BE A WHITE
OKAY PART OF THE FRAMEWORK. OF
THIS BILL AND SHE'S INVOLVED IN
THIS NEGOTIATION WITH MONIQUE
THAT INVOLVES BILLS ON THIS
TOPIC AND THREE. I THINK THAT
ISSUES THAT THAT ISSUE WILL BE
ADDRESSED. A CENTER BATES. I
YEAH I THOUGHT. MY ON. YEAH I
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD YONGE
ARE PUTTING YOUR SHOULDER TO THE
WHEEL ALREADY. HAD TO CONVINCE
OUR MANY THAT WE NEED THIS TOOL.
I THINK IT'S THE FIRST TIME I'VE
HEARD REALITY CHECK. ON THE
GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN SAID IT WAS
ALMOST LIKE SHE'D READY AIM WHEN
WE DECIDED WE WERE GONNA GO
WITH. JUST TWO TECHNOLOGIES.
WHEN THE OTHER PRODUCTS THAT WE
NEED TO OUR VITAL AND DO YOU
HAVE- THE CARBON EMISSIONS SOUL.
CAPTURING THOSE AND ALL THAT'S
BEEN SAID BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TOTALLY. UNDERSCORE THE
GREATNESS OF YOUR BILL IN THE
DIRECTION YOU'RE TAKING US IN.
SO YOU HAVE MY STRONG SUPPORT
AND I WANT TO PROVIDE. THE OIL
INDUSTRY AND OUR UNIONS AND OUR
OUR TRADES. FOR WORKING TOGETHER
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY THIS
THING IS GOING TO REALLY WORK
OUT IN A LONG TERM THAT WE HAVE
THAT KIND OF PARTNERSHIP. THANK
YOU AND- YOU HAVE MY VOTE. NO
CERTAINLY MY STRONG SUPPORT. AS
YOU GO FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OUR THANK YOU I'M ANYMORE
COMMENTS. FROM THE MEMBERS. OKAY
WITH- YOU MAY CLOSE CENTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST DISCUSSION
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS THIS
IS JUST NOT EASY- AND THERE ARE
A LOT OF FEARS BUT I THINK THAT-
WELL. I WILL MAKE THE COMMITMENT
TO WORK WITH- EVERYONE- AND I
THINK THAT CLIMATE. GROUP THAT
THAT'S DOING THE WORK- AND ALSO-
CHAIR STERN WHEN IF THE BILL IS-
PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY
WOULD GO TO HIS COMMITTEE- AND
THIS ISN'T THE END THERE IS A
LOT MORE WORK TO HAPPEN AND I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO SURE- AS MANY
PEOPLE AS AS A POSSIBLE. THAT-
WERE. THAT EVEN DESPITE THE
FEARS THAT PEOPLE HAVE THAT WEEK
THAT THAT THIS IS SOMETHING WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO DO AND WILL
DO IT IN THE SAFEST. AND MOST
RESPONSIBLE WAY POSSIBLE IN
ORDER TO SEND THE SIGNAL THAT WE
WANT TO SICK TO SEND THAT-
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY MEET OUR GOALS THAT THEY
WERE. THAT THEY WERE SET AND
THAT WE WERE GOING TO DO IT IN A
WAY THAT'S RESPONSIBLE AND THAT
PROTECTS ALL CALIFORNIANS SO
THAT'S MY COMMITMENT- AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THE CENTER.
CONSUMPTIONS CHOLERA. THE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. B. ELEVEN OH ONE
BY SENATOR CAFIERO THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THAT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER ALAN
HI ALAN I'D BATES BATES AYE DALI
DALI I GONZALEZ. SKINNER SKINNER
AYE STERN BY CASKEY MY CASKEY I. OKAY I WILL EITHER OPEN FOR
THEM SAID THANK YOU CENTER. OKAY
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO WITH THE
SENATE- THIS IS- ITEM TWO. SB
TEN THIRTEEN AND IT'S CENTER
ATKINS BILL BUT YOU'RE VERY
GRACIOUSLY AGREED TO. SENATE
EVEN THOUGH NOT A CO AUTHOR YOU
BECOME COST THE PRINCIPLE OF IT
PRINCIPLE COUGH OKAY GREAT OKAY
. IT'S GOOD WELL YOU KNOW NOT TO
BE TOO GRATUITOUS MISTER
JARRETT- IT COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
REALLY DIDN'T THINK THAT WAS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT POLICY
DEBATES AT A COMMITTEE THAT I'VE
HEARD IN MY EIGHT YEARS- YOU
KNOW IN THE LEGISLATURE I WANT
TO CONGRATULATE YOU ON THAT THAT
THAT THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. SO WITH THAT LET'S GET TO
ANOTHER PORT IMPORTANT ITEMS
YEAH. I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS-
RECOMMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
THE BOX WINES ARE PART OF THE
PROGRAM. ALONG WITH WINE IN
GLASS CONTAINERS AND ALSO DELAY
THE OPERATIVE DATE OF SOME OF
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE LAW TO
ENSURE THE VENDORS ARE NOT%
PENALIZED FOR GOODS ALREADY. IN
THE STREAM OF COMMERCE. TURNING
TO THE BILL SB TEN THIRTEEN IS
THE PROTONS AND MY MEASURE TO
ADD WHITED DISTILLED SPIRITS TO
CALIFORNIA'S SUCCESSFUL BOTTLE
BILL PROGRAM TO INCREASE
RECYCLING RATES ARE TO PROVIDE
CONVENIENT RECYCLING OPTIONS.
FOR CONSUMERS. CALIFORNIA
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING AND
LITTER REDUCTION ACT TOOK EFFECT
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX IS
SUCCESSFULLY RESULTED IN
DRAMATICALLY INCREASING
RECYCLING FOR ALUMINUM GLASS AND
PET PLASTIC BAG CONTAINERS.
HOWEVER SINCE IT WAS ENACTED THE
PROGRAM SAID GAPS OF SORTS IN
THAT WINE IS DISTILLED SPIRITS
CONTAIN. CONTAINERS THAT MAKE UP
A SIGNIFICANT FRACTION OF THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER WEIGHS THREE
HAVE NOT BEEN- RECYCLABLE. UNDER
THE PROGRAM. THIS CREATES A- IN
THE PROBE. AND FOR CONSUMERS WHO
HAVE HAVE TO PAY THE COST
RECYCLING WINE AND DISTILLED
SPIRITS COMPUTERS AS FAR AS
THEIR MONTHLY GARBAGE AND
RECYCLING BILLS. SB TEN THIRTEEN
REMEDIES THIS PROBLEM BY
ENSURING WHITED SPIRITS BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS ARE TREATED EXACTLY
THE SAME AS OTHER BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS. UNDER THE BOTTLE
BILL PROGRAM CENTERS MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT THIS IS A STARK
CHANGE IN LAW THAT IS FORTY
YEARS INCOMING. I WANT TO
COMMEND THE PROTEST AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES IN THE
WHITED DISTILLED SPIRITS
INDUSTRIES FOR COMING TOGETHER
TO SUPPORT THIS LANDMARK
PROPOSAL. I HAVE TIM SCHMELZER-
FROM THE WINE INSTITUTE AND MARK
MURRAY FROM CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE AS ARE TO LEAD WITNESSES.
HEY GOOD MORNING. MISTER TERRY
COMMITTEE- TIM SCHMELZER VICE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA STATE
RELATIONS FOR WINE INSTITUTE-
ONE INSTITUTE REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY A THOUSAND- FAMILY
OWNED WINERIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I AM HERE TO EXPRESS THAT
ONE INSTITUTE SUPPORTS THE
INTRODUCTION OF WINE INTO THE
BOTTLE BILL IF AMENDED. LET ME
REPEAT WINE INSTITUTE ACTUALLY
SUPPORTS THE INTRODUCTION OF
WIND INTO THE BOTTLE. I'M SURE
SOME PEOPLE JUST FELL OVER. LET
ME EXPLAIN A RATIONALE AND- IN
THE NEED FOR SEVERAL AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED. A FIRST
OF ALL WE HAD KNOWLEDGE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WIDESPREAD USE OF
SINGLE USE RECYCLING BINS IS
SIMPLY NOT GETTING IT DONE FOR
OUR PRODUCTS. WE KNOW WE NEED
OUR GLASS BOTTLES AND OTHER
RECYCLABLES TO BE SEPARATED FOR
THEM TO ACHIEVE THE RECYCLING
RATES THAT ARE INDUSTRY STRIVES
FOR. AND THE FACT ON THE GROUND
IS THAT THE BOTTLE BILL IS THE
PROGRAM THAT CAN DO THAT.
HOWEVER WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF
ONE INTO THE BOTTLE BILL THERE
ARE SEVERAL UNIQUE ATTRIBUTES
RELATED TO OUR INDUSTRY THAT
NEED TO BE KEPT IN MIND. FIRST
THERE ARE OVER FORTY TWO HUNDRED
WINERIES IN CALIFORNIA- THERE
OVERWHELMINGLY A SMALL FAMILY
OWNED BUSINESSES. SECOND ONE IS
A VERY UNIQUE PRODUCT IT IS
OFTEN BOTTLED IN H. TWO YEARS
BEFORE IT'S BROUGHT TO MARKET.
AND THIRD. THE INDUSTRY'S BEEN
EVOLVING- WE HAVE AN ATTEMPT TO
BOTH ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES AND CONSUMER CONVENIENCE
THAT EXPLORING THE USE OF
ALTERNATIVE CONTAINER TYPES
OUTSIDE A GLASS BOTTLE SUCH AS
BACK IN THE BOX. WE APPRECIATE
THE MOMENTS OF BEEN PER FOURTH
BY THE COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF THESE CONCERNS
SPECIFICALLY ACKNOWLEDGE IN THE
LEAD TIME WILL BE NECESSARY FOR
COMPLIANCE. AND THAT BAG IN THE
BOX AS AN ELIGIBLE CONTAINER
TYPE. WE ANTICIPATE ADDITIONAL
ISSUES ARE GOING TO COME UP
RELATIVE TO THE UNIQUENESS OF
OUR PRODUCT AND OUR INDUSTRY AS
WE WORK TO INTRODUCE ONE INTO
THE BOTTLE BILL. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE PRO
TEM SENATOR DODD AND THE
COMMITTEE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. TO ADDRESS THEM AS
THEY ARE IDENTIFIED THANK YOU.
MARK. MISTER MEMBERS MARK MURRAY
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
GRATEFUL FOR CENTERED TO CENTER
DOT FOR HIS WORK FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS ON THIS ISSUE
GRATEFUL FOR THE PRO TEMS
INTRODUCTION OF THIS MEASURE
FRANKLY GRATEFUL FOR US CENTER
WHITE CAL SKIS INTRODUCTION OF
THE SAME PROPOSAL THAT PASSED
THIS COMMITTEE FIVE YEARS AGO
YESTERDAY- IT HAS BEEN A LONG
TIME GOAL TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM
TO INCLUDE WINE AND DISTILLED
SPIRIT CONTAINERS. IT IS FRANKLY
FASCINATING TO ME AND IN A
REASON FOR CELEBRATION THAT THIS
PROPOSAL TODAY IS BEING DRIVEN
BY MANUFACTURED DEMAND FOR THE
RECYCLED MATERIAL ON WE'RE GONNA
HAVE ALL THE SAME BENEFITS OF
REDUCING LITTER AN INCREASING
RECYCLING BUT THIS IS BEING
DRIVEN BY GLASS BOTTLE
MANUFACTURERS AND FRANKLY I
THINK IF THEY WERE HERE PT
BOTTLE MANUFACTURERS WHO NEED
THIS SECONDARY MATERIAL. TO
PRODUCE CONTAINERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH LESS POLLUTION
LOWER GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
SO THAT'S SOMETHING WORTH
CELEBRATING- MAYBE THE ELEPHANT
IN THE ROOM IS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BOTTLE AND CAN
RECYCLING LAW AS IT RELATES TO
THE BUY BACK RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE MANY COMMUNITIES
IN THE STATE FARM ARE LACKING
CONVENIENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
REDEEMING CONTAINERS THERE ARE
ALSO MANY COMMUNITIES IN THIS
STATE THAT HAVE EXCELLENT
BUYBACK RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND BETTER THAN 80% RECYCLING SO
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THOSE
COMMUNITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY LIKE. THE INLAND EMPIRE
THAT HAVE 80% BETTER RECYCLING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SUFFICIENT
NUMBER OF BUYBACK RECYCLING
CENTERS PER CAPITA WE LOOK AT
THE NORTH COAST WE LOOK AT THE
BAY AREA OF CALIFORNIA THEY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH BY BACK
RECYCLING CENTERS TO ACHIEVE THE
RECYCLING OBJECTIVES OF THIS
PROGRAM NOW THIS PROPOSAL WILL
HELP WE KNOW THAT THIS PROPOSAL
WILL ADD SIXTY FIVE TO EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
INCREASED SCRAP VALUE IN PROGRAM
PAYMENTS TO THE RECYCLING IN
FOR. SURE IT WORKS OUT TO ON
AVERAGE ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER BY BACK RECYCLING
CENTER PER MONTH IN INCREASED
VALUE SO THAT'S GOING TO HELP.
BUT WE'RE STILL GONNA DO YOU
NEED TO DO MORE TO BRING BACK BY
BACK RECYCLING CENTERS TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE THEM
. MAY OR MAY NOT BE APPROPRIATE
FOR THIS PROPOSAL- THERE'S THE
GOVERNOR HAS PUT FORWARD A
PROPOSAL FINALLY HAS PUT FORWARD
SOME THAT TOLD US ALL HOW MUCH.
SURPLUS MONEY THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE ON SO THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO ADDRESS THIS EITHER IN THIS
BILL OTHER BILLS OR FOR IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. BOTTOM LINE
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THIS
LEGISLATION I'M IT'S GONNA
INCREASE GLASS RECYCLING IS
GOING TO INCREASE MARKET DEMAND
FOR- THIS MATERIAL AND WE URGE
AN AYE VOTE. MR MURRAY OTHER
FOLKS WANNA VOICES SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS BOB ZERO ON BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY OWNED BUSINESS THE E.
AND J. GALLO WINERY AND ITS
AFFILIATES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON-
MICROBES AND ON BEHALF THE GLASS
PACKAGING INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO%
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS IN THAT
AND THE WINDS TO ANOTHER'S ON
IMPROVING THE COLLECTION QUALITY
OF GLASS COMING THROUGH THE
SYSTEM THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
VINO TINTO. HI YEAH GOOD MORNING
MR TERRORISTAN CAP KEY WITH ME
Q. CAP CAN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF
OF STRATEGIC MATERIALS THE
LARGEST CLASS PROCESSOR. NOT
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA WITH SIX
FACILITIES TO PROCESS RECYCLED
GLASS- BUT ALSO THE LARGEST
GLASS RECYCLER IN THE NATION
THANK YOU INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
KURT CAMPBELL SHE WITH ANHEUSER
BUSCH IN STRONG SUPPORT WANT TO
THANK US INTERACTIONS AND CENTER
DOT FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
A LONG TIME COMING I THINK AT
GREAT. GREAT STEP FORWARD ON
THIS END AND THANK YOU TO MISS
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE USE WELFARE
FOR LEADING HESE EFFORTS FOR A
LONG TIME BY WORK BUT WE'RE
GETTING SOMEWHERE ON IT. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN RECYCLED
AFTER THE PRAM KAYLEE ON BEHALF
OF REPUBLIC SERVICES IN SUPPORT
. TIM LYNCH WITH PLATINUM
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF THE NAPA
VALLEY VINTNERS THAT WE SUPPORT
THE BILL CONSISTENT WITH THE ONE
INSTANCE- COMMENTS ABOUT THE
UNIQUE FEATURES OF THE PRODUCT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS READ
ADDRESS ON BEHALF OF THE
FOURTEEN LOCAL CONSERVATION
QUARTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OUR FOLKS ON THE
ON THE MATTER THEIR PEOPLE ON ON
THE PHONE LINES YOU WANT TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR SB TEN
THIRTEEN. DOMINO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB. EN
THIRTEEN. S. ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
AND FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY FIVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATT
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS AND SUPPORT
. GOOD TO SEE YOU ON THE SAME
PAGE CENTER DODD THAT'S GREAT-
THERE WE HAVE LINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOLDSMITH WITH
INDIAN RECYCLING THE TWO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL BUT WE
ALSO STRONGLY RECOMMEND AN
IMPLEMENTATION DATE THE AFTER
THE BELL WE RECOMMEND FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
AND THAT IS ALL I HAVE BEEN HERE
RIGHT NOW. ALL RIGHT. I THANK
YOU SO MUCH LET'S NOW AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO HAS THE-
VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
THIS SB TEN THIRTEEN ANYONE HERE
PERSON. ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES. A MODERATOR. IF YOU WISH
FIFTY. REGARDING THE SB TEN
THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND I HAVE
NO ONE IN CARE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO LET'S GO TO THE- THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THOUGHTS SENATE ONLY
JUST A SO WHAT ABOUT THE I MEAN
WHO STATED THERE ARE FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED SMALL WINERIES OUT THERE
NOT MOST OF THOSE ARE. OURS WHAT
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN I MEAN I
OBVIOUSLY UNDERSTAND THE BIG
PRODUCERS SO TWO QUESTIONS ONE
OF ABOUT TE SMALLER- WHAT HOW
THE IMPACT OF THE SMALLER-
PRODUCERS AND THEN ALSO- SITES
FOR RECYCLING I KNOW THERE'S
LIKE VERY FEW AT LEAST AT MY
DISTRICT THERE I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY. QUITE FRANKLY. WELL
THE FIRST WELL I THINK THAT- MR
MURRAY- YOU KNOW LAID THAT OUT
PRETTY WELL AND I HOPE I THINK
MR SMITH- SMELTERS GONNA. COME
UP AND TALK ABOUT THE SMALL
PRODUCERS I KNOW THAT IN MY
DISTRICT THE SMALLER PRODUCERS-
YOUR BEHIND THIS WE ALREADY
HEARD ABOUT THE NAPA VALLEY
VINTNERS BUT THERE'S A LOT OF-
VIDEO GROUPS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YEAH
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION A CENTER
DOLLY- WHAT FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO SAY YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED TO.
MEMBERS OF EVERY SIZE WITH AN
ORGANIZATION AND WE HAVE ALMOST
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT- OUR MEMBERS
REALLY WANT TO BE PART OF
RECYCLING- PROGRAMS- THAT BEING
SAID SOME OF THE FEATURES OF
BEING A SMALL WINERY ARE ARE
UNIQUE YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO. ALLOW ADEQUATE TIME FOR
SMALLER BUSINESSES TO COME UP TO
SPEED WITH THIS I THINK THERE
IS- YOU KNOW BRINGING IN WINE IS
A LOT DIFFERENT THAN BRINGING
IN- OTHER PRODUCTS WHERE THERE
MAY BE ONLY FOUR OR FIVE
DIFFERENT MANUFACTURERS BRING
PRODUCTS AND- SO IMPLEMENTATION
DATE WHICH IS ALREADY- SOMETHING
THAT'S MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS
IS IMPORTANT- ONE THING WE
MENTIONED IN THE LETTER WE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE- WINERIES.
COULD BE CONSIDERED A DEALER AND
HAVE TO TAKE BACK PRODUCT WE
DON'T WANT THAT. FOR EXAMPLE
AND- AND- AS I MENTIONED I
EXPECT WE'RE GOING TO COME
ACROSS A FEW OF THESE- AS WE
MOVE THROUGH. I THINK WE HAVE A
STRONG COMMITMENT FROM THE
AUTHOR AND SENATOR DOT THAT
WE'RE GONNA WORK THROUGH THIS
AND MAKE SURE IT WORKS FOR. OUR
INDUSTRY. SO JUST A FOLLOW UP
THAT'S THAT'S THE KEY BECAUSE I
WHEN I WAS THAT IN. IN OTHER
RECYCLING PROGRAMS WHERE THEY BE
THEY ARE HAVE TO TAKE IT BACK
AND THERE'S- NO PLACE THEY DON'T
BECOME A RECYCLING CENTER IF
THEY DON'T. AND I KNOW THAT
ISSUE CAME UP BEFORE. AND THEN
THE LAST QUESTION IS DO IS THEIR
PRICE PER. BOTTLE WHAT WAS I
DIDN'T SEE. IT IS- AMOUNT.
TRANSACTION SINCE OKAY. OKAY
OTHER THOUGHTS GOING HERE MOTION
FROM A MEMBER YES THERE WOULD
HAVE ALL PEOPLE LIKE TO BE
CENTER BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. ON THE MATTER BEFORE
US BUT I WILL MOVE THE BILL
THAT'S GREAT- AND I DO WANNA I
WANNA I DM I WANTED OBVIOUSLY I
THANK YOU CENTER FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP OF THE PROTON MATCH I
DO ALSO WANTED TO SIGNAL ITS-
CINEMA CASKEY IS LONGSTANDING
WORK IN THE SPACE- WHERE IS THE
BILL GO IS IT. IS IT DOES IT IS
IT DONE BUT NOW IT HAS IT
BECAUSE THAT GOES APPROPRIATIONS
IS FISCAL YEAR YEAH THIS GONNA
PREPARATIONS OKAY ALL RIGHT I
CENTER WITHOUT YOU MAY CLOSE. UP
I WOULD I TOO WOULD LIKE TO-
RECOGNIZE THE CENTER WOULD HOUSE
THIS IS YOUR DAY- THIS IS YOUR
DAY THIS IS A REALLY FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK AND YOU KNOW IN
THE SPACE- CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AB.
I'VE THOUGHT PLEASE KALRA. ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB TEN THIRTEEN BY
CENTER ATKINS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS ALAN
HI. ALAN I BATES. BATES AYE
DOLLY. GONZALEZ SKINNER SKINNER
AYE STERN BY STERN HIGHWAY CAL
SCHEME BY AYE CASKEY AYE. MMHM
OKAY THANK YOU THE BILLS OUT
THINK SO MUCH CENTER THANKS FOR
PATIENTS TO. OKAY I SEE CENTER
PORTIS'S HERE TO PRESENT S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN. COME ON UP. I
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WARNING. WHAT TIME NOW
IT'S BEEN ONE OF THOSE WEEKS MAN
YEAH I'LL WAIT HE JUST. FLYING
THROUGH THE BREEZEWAY JUST A
MOMENT EARLIER. YEAH WE IT'S A
IN A CRAZY WAY WHICH IS WHAT
DESTRUCTION THESE RIGHT WITH
SCHEDULE OKAY- GOOD MORNING-
MISTER CHAIR IN MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTEEN A
BILL THAT SEEKS TO CODIFY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT'S
DECISION IN NEIGHBORS FOR SMART
RAIL VERSUS EXPOSITION METRO
LINE CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY.
THAT'S A MOUTHFUL. FIRST I WANT
TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR FOR
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ME ON THIS
MEASURE I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINE ON PAGE EIGHT
OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. ALSO
UNDERSHIRT THAT MY INTENT IS TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS MEASURE TO
MAKE FURTHER AMENDMENTS IF
NECESSARY WHILE CONTINUING WITH
THE PURPOSE OF THE MEASURE. THE
CALIFORNIA BAR MIDDLE QUALITY
ACT SEQUEL WAS AN ACTIVE OVER
FIFTY YEARS AGO. TO ENSURE THAT
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
CONSIDER THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT OF THEIR DECISIONS. WHEN
APPROVING A PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
PROJECT. AND WHILE THIS LAW HAS
UNDOUBTEDLY DONE AN EXCELLENT
JOB. IN PROTECTING AND
CONSERVING NATURAL RESOURCES OF
THE STATE. IT IS ALSO CLEAR THAT
THIS LONG. HAS BEEN USED TO
FACILITATE COSTLY LITIGATION
NEEDLESS LITIGATION. THIS
PURPOSE IS OFTENTIMES ON RELATED
TO PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT NEIGHBORS FOR SMART RAIL V.
EXPOSITION. THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT HELD AND I QUOTE.
INSUBSTANTIAL OR MERELY
TECHNICAL MISSIONS ARE NOT
GROUNDS FOR RELIEF UNDER SEQUEL
. THAT DECISION FURTHER NOTED
THAT OUR MISSION IS PREJUDICIAL
QUOTE IF IT DEPRIVED THE PUBLIC
AND DECISION MAKERS OF
SUBSTANTIAL RELEVANT INFORMATION
ABOUT THE PROJECT LIKELY ADVERSE
IMPACTS. IF ENACTED THIS BILL
WOULDN'T WOULD WOULD UPDATE
SEQUEL TO REQUIRE A FINDING THAT
AN AGENCY CAUSED PREJUDICIAL
VIOLATION OF THE ACT BEFORE
COURT CAN ISSUE AN ORDER
DIRECTING A LEAD AGENCY OR REAL
PARTIES IN INTEREST TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL STEPS. THIS CHANGE
WOULD HELP LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
FRIVOLOUS SUITS THAT ARE FILED
EVERY YEAR UNDER SEQUEL BECAUSE
IT WOULD ENSURE THAT ONLY THOSE
CASES WITH MERIT WILL SUCCEED IN
OBTAINING RELIEF. TODAY I AM
JOINED. BY ADAM RELIGION OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WILL BE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTEEN. THE
CENTER ADAM THIS YEAR MORNING
YEAH AT A RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
SORRY WE HAVEN'T GOT A LETTER
AND WE WERE WAITING TO SEE HOW
THE IMAGE CHECK OUT BUT WE
OVERALL OUR CHRISTMAS SUPPORT
LETTER AND APPRECIATE THE-
COMMITTEE WORKING WITH- THE
CENTER ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE- THE BILL'S PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD IT IS
EFFECTIVELY CODIFIES A
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
DECISION AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED THE NEIGHBORS FIRST
MORRELL DECISION. AND BECAUSE
SEE WHAT LANDMARK ENVIRONMENTAL
LAW IS ENFORCED ENTIRELY BY
CITIZEN LAWSUITS MOST ARE MERIT
BUT THERE ARE CASES WHERE HE WAS
ABUSED FOR A REASON TO BE ON THE
ENVIRONMENT AS A SENATOR NOTED.
AND SO THIS BILL- BASICALLY
MAKES CLEAR FOR THE LOWER
COURTS- BY CODIFYING THAT
DECISION THAT ONLY- SEQUEL
VIOLATIONS THAT HAVE PREJUDICIAL
NATURE TO THE PUBLIC SHALL BE
GROUNDS FOR VACATING ADR OR MND
AND SENDING IT BACK TO THE
BEGINNING AND UNDER ALL A LOT OF
THIS IS WE SEE IN A SEQUEL THEY
ARE NOT NOTICING THIS SUPREME
COURT DECISION AND THEY ARE
VACATING ER'S FOR MERE TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS THAT ARE NOT
PREJUDICIAL. THAT SLOWS DOWN
PROJECTS WHETHER IT'S HOUSING OR
OTHER DEVELOPMENT LAND USE IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BUT- I THINK ONE STEP
IN THERE PRETTY REFORM PROCESS
TO ENSURE THAT THE- SEQUEL IS
NOT ABUSED BUT- INTEREST
ENVIRONMENT PROTECTION FOR
PROJECTS- BEING DEVELOPED IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE LOOKING TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE I THINK THIS
IS ONE STEP FORWARD TOWARDS THAT
SO WE SUPPORTED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU JOHN. ALL RIGHT- OTHER FOLKS
OF WE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR WHO WANTS TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR. S. B. ONE ONE ONE
EIGHT. ELEVEN EIGHTEEN. NOW OKAY
I DON'T BELIEVE WE IT ANYONE
WANT TO VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL. HERE IN PERSON. CAPTION.
MODERATOR HI ARE YOU ARE YOU
THERE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND FEDERAL WE'LL START
WITH LINE EIGHTEEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE DAILY
AVERAGE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND FROM
THE PORT THANK YOU. AND ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GET A LINE
NUMBER FOR OUR NEXT PLAN.
LINE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DOUG FIRST
INFORMATION VERY STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I JUST
WONDER IF YOU CAME IN STRONG
OPPOSITION PLACE. AND I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU. OKAY R. I.
C. A. SOMEONE HERE WANTS TO
VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY
QUEST ON BEHALF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. OKAY. ANYONE ELSE MONITOR OUR
MODERATOR ANYONE THE PHONE LINES
. GERMAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
AT EIGHT ONE AND ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN KILL
. WE HAVE SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO
VOICE HER POSITION ON THE BILL-
MY NAME'S LORRAINE CHILSON AND I
VOTE AGAINST THIS BILL ANYTHING
SMART IS DANGEROUS FOR US. I'M
AGAINST IT. OKAY I'M GREAT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SO LET'S. LET'S
NOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION. I'VE
CENTER CASKEY. I'M THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS SO
WE'RE GOING TO JUST LOOK AT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD TO JUDGES
ARE GOING TO BE INSTRUCTED NOT
TO GO BEYOND AND USED THEIR OWN
SEARCH SEARCHES ON THE
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF PORTION
BECAUSE SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
IS CONCERNED THAT THEY HAVE TO.
RENDER A FINE BEFORE THEY CAN
ISSUE THE INJUNCTIVE RELIEF IN
YOU'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD- BEFORE
THEM RIGHT N. AS IN ORDER TO.
ISSUE AND CHECK HEIR
CONSIDERING INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
THEY HAVE TO FIND IRREPARABLE
HARM RIGHT SO. I GUESS
OCCURRENCE YEP PARDON
PREJUDICIAL OCCURRENCE RIGHT SO. EXPLAIN YOUR THOUGHT- HELP ME
BECAUSE IF WE'RE GOING IF THE
COURTS ARE GOING TO BE FOLLOWING
WHAT IS IT SMART TRAINED. WITH
NEIGHBORS FOR SMART RAILS SO
WE'RE WE'RE SAYING WE WANT ALL
THE COURTS TO LOOK AT SMART REAL
OUR NEIGHBORS ARE SMART REAL AND
USE THIS PROCESSING ON WHETHER
IT'S- SIGNIFICANT OR INSERT-
INSIGNIFICANT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD- WHICH
ISN'T THAT EASIER FOR A COURT TO
AT LEAST MAKE SOME FINDINGS THE
SCRIPT THEY HAVE EVERYTHING IN
FRONT OF THEM. AND THE GUIDANCE
OF THIS THIS COURT VERSUS.
VERSUS MAKING IT TOO DIFFICULT I
GUESS MY THIS IS A IS THAT CLEAR
IF I MAY AND BY THE WAY YEAH FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ALLOW ME TO
ALSO BRING UP MORGAN AND ADAM
BACK UP WHO COULD PROBABLY OFFER
SOME INSIGHTS. AS WELL. I THINK
WHAT. THE SUPREME COURT ON THE
IN ITS DECISION. WAS PUT WAS
POSITING IS THAT. IF YOU'RE
GOING TO DERAIL A PROJECT OR
CHALLENGE A PROJECT. THAT YOU
CAN'T IDENTIFY THAT BECAUSE OF A
MISSING COMMA HERE OR TECHNICAL
ISSUE ON RELATED. TO THE ACTUAL
ENVIRONMENTAL MERITS THAT THAT
TECHNICAL VIOLATION. NEEDS TO
DATE BE DEMONSTRATED AS BEING.
PREJUDICIAL IN ITS OUTCOME THAT
THERE BE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT. NOW WHAT THE COMMITTEES-
THE COMMITTEE AT THE MID
COMMITTEE'S REQUEST WE HAVE
WITHDRAWN THE DEFINITION. OF
CANVAS- YET YEAH PREJUDICIAL
LACK OF COMPLIANCE WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT- IN A
MORGAN DID YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
TO THE SENATORS POINT YEAH JUST
TO DIRECTLY ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
YES- ANY PARTY WHO IS
CHALLENGING THE ADEQUACY OF AN
E. I. R. IS ONLY LIMITED TO THE
EVIDENCE THAT'S IN THE RECORD
WHICH WOULD BE A LOT YOU KNOW
CONSIDERING HOW MASSIVE THESE
DOCUMENTS ARE SO THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE. TO WORK WITH THE FIND
EITHER NO COMPLAINTS OR
COMPLAINTS AND TYPICALLY IT THE
E. R. R. IS FILED THE COMPLAINT
IS FILED AND THEN THE JUDGE IS
GOING TO DETERMINE WHETHER SHE
WANTS TO ISSUE AN INJUNCTION TO
SAY DON'T JUST STOP WITH THIS
NORMALLY YOU DON'T GO FORWARD
WITH THE PROJECT IF YOU'VE GOT A
YOU'VE GOT A LAWSUIT I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S DANGEROUS FOR THE
LEAD AGENCY YOU KNOW I SORT OF
BY FILING THE CASE THERE'S-
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF NOT DIRECTLY
BUT PER SE BUT IF YOU IF YOU ASK
FOR THAT ADDITIONAL. UNCHECKED
OF RELIEF I WOULD IMAGINE TO BE
THE PLAINTIFF. NOT THE LEAD
AGENCY RIGHT. AND THAT WOULD BE
PART OF PRAYER WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY THEY FILED A- BUT AGAIN THE
LEAD AGENCY JUST FOR PRACTICAL
PURPOSES CÁC WE'RE GONNA GO
FORWARD. WITH IT WITH THE SUIT
ENACTED IN THE WE DON'T HAVE TO.
THE CLEAR AND SO I SEE THE
CONCERN I WANTED AN OBVIOUSLY
THE JURORS COULD WORK WITH YOU
ON THOSE. THE LANGUAGE ON THE
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF BUT I WAS JUST
TRYING TO. CLEAR THAT UP AND
SINGLE YOU GOT A LAWSUIT HERE.
RIGHT SO. IT'S POSSIBLE IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT SIMPLY DIDN'T SEE
SEE WE DON'T CARE UNLESS YOU CAN
JOIN US AND THEN. AND THEN THEY
THEY'VE GOT THE RECORD AND
THEY'VE GOT. A D. NEIGHBORS
HAVE. JUST TO CLARIFY YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE STRIKING THIS THIS.
ADVERSE IMPACT DEFINITION NOT
THE PRESIDENT'S LACK. OF
COMPLAINTS RIGHT IN THE MEN'S.
RIGHT HE'S GONNA WORK ON
LANGUAGE RIGHT I BY THE WAY THE
THING I MEAN IF IT'S OUT OF.
DATE I MEAN. CRITICAL TO ALL
THIS FOLKS IS THAT IT'S HEADING
TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. WHICH IS
WHERE I WAS GOING. WHERE WHERE
SAID WITH SENATOR AND I'VE HAD
THAT EXPERIENCE I THINK I THINK
THIS IS THIS A- LOOK I MEAN I
WANNA I WANNA THANK YOU CENTER
FOR ACCEPTING THEM IT'S I MEAN I
THINK IT'S THIS IS NOT AN EARTH
SHATTERING BILL BUT- AS I WAS
CONCERNED THE WAY YOU HAD IT
ORIGINALLY WRITTEN BUT THE I
THINK THESE CHANGES MAKE IT VERY
FAIR. I THINK IT'S VERY
REASONABLE TO BE HONEST- IKNOW
THERE'S SOME CONCERNS- PROP
SIGNIFICANT OVER A JUDICIARY AND
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO WORK THOSE
OUT OVER THERE I KNOW YOU'VE
ALREADY STARTED CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR BUT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE- THIS COMMITTEE YOU
KNOW M. AND MIKE MY COLLEAGUE
CENTER DOLLY BRINGS UP A LOT OF
THINGS CAN BE DOES HAVE TO BE
REASONABLE AND- AND FLEXIBLE
AND- AND WE'RE AT A PLACE NOW
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS THAT. THIS
IS A REASONABLE BALANCE
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU. SO I'M- THE ALWAYS
MOVED BILL. I WILL THAT HI IS
VERY CENTER SKINNER. THE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SO- SEACOR IS-
LOADED SUBJECT INTO A- I
APPRECIATE YOUR TRAINER CODIFY
COURT RULING I OFTEN DO BILLS
THAT TRY TO CODIFY COURT RULINGS
SO YOU WANT TO GET CLARITY
HOWEVER OMINOUS STAY OFF UNTIL I
SEE WHAT YOU DISH DOES FROM
CAMPUS DIDN'T HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO INTERPRET THIS. THANKS OKAY
YEP- CENTER STERN YES I JUST
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE AND I'M TO SEE
THIS BILL JUDICIARY TOO SO I'LL
BE OFF TODAY- AND HOPE HOPE YOU
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION
ESPECIALLY THE FORMAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE IN LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
HERE- AND JUST TO. DRILL DOWN
JUST GET GRANULAR HERE AS BEST
YOU CAN TO REALLY HELP US KNOW
WHAT WE'RE SIGNING OFF ON-
THERE'S SOME. YEAH THERE'S YOU
KNOW THERE'S A NEED FOR
DIVERSITY IN JUDICIAL OPINION
SOMETIMES ON THESE MATTERS
BECAUSE IT IS SO CASE BY CASE SO
THAT'S REALLY THE DIFFICULTY I'M
HAVING IS LIKE HOW IF YOU'RE
CODIFYING A STANDARD. AND YOU'VE
GOT TO GET SPECIFIC AND
STATUTORY TEXT. ARE YOU LIMITING
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO CUT A
DEAL WITH THAT SO YOU CAN
ADDRESS SOME OF YOUR CLOSER AS
YOU GO FOR HERE BUT I APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS. THANK YOU YEAH.
OKAY YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU.
OUR MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENTS. ARE THIS IS A SIMPLE
BILL. THAT CODIFIES. THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT'S
DECISION IN EXPOSITION METRO
LINE CONSTRUCTION. OF VOTING ON
THE BILL TODAY ALLOWS OPTION TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON REFORMING-
THE- ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT.
AND TO. JUST SO THAT WE HAVE.
THE PROPER CONTEXT AS WE CLOSE.
IT IS A HEALTHY BALANCE. THAT
LOOKS AFTER THE ENVIRONMENT IT
PRESERVES. IN FACT IT PERFECT
PRESERVES THE INTEGRITY. OF
SEQUEL. EACH ASSEMBLY.
ARTICULATES THAT INDIVIDUAL OR
AN ENTITY. HAS TO IDENTIFY
THERE'S BEEN A PREJUDICIAL.
IMPACT WITH A RIGHT WITH WITH
THE- WITH THE CLAIM I THINK THAT
MAKES SENSE FROM A COMMONSENSE
STANDPOINT CERTAINLY FROM A
LEGAL STANDPOINT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVALS. PUBLICOLA I THE
NUMBER FIVE SB ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
BY SENATOR BORDERS THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ALLEN AYE
ALLEN AYE BATES BATES AYE DALI
DALI HI GONZALEZ. SKINNER STERN
BY CAL SKI MY COUNTY I'D. HI
THIS FOR BOTH TO GET THE BILL
OUT AND- GET TO GO TO DESERT
COMMITTEE LETS THE SAIL THROUGH
YEAH YEAH I HAD. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU CREATORS
CENTER THINKS YOUR WORK IN THIS
SPACE. WE'RE GONNA MISS YOU MAN.
REMUS YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
YOU CENTER PORTANTINO- YOU'RE
HERE TO PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY SIX SEVEN SIX IN YOUR JOB
AS MEMBERS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OBVIOUSLY PRESENTING S. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX TO CLARIFY AND
STREAMLINE THE CALIFORNIA-
SEQUEL PROCESS FOR PROJECTS THAT
MEET REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO COMPLY WITH OUR
CLIMATE GOALS VERY IMPORTANT WE
WANT TO. WE HAVE CLIMATE GOALS
WE NEED TO MEET THEM AND WE NEED
TO PROJECTS TO DO THAT A MEETING
THE SAME VICIOUS GOALS WILL TAKE
A MASSIVE COORDINATED EFFORT. AS
WELL AS SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
AND DEVELOPMENT HOWEVER PROJECTS
WE WEIGHED DOWN BY ITS
INCONSISTENCIES AND
ADMINISTRATIVE DELAYS. TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE CAN MEET ITS
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS A
MINUTE OUT MINIMIZE UNNECESSARY
DUPLICATION OF WORK. AND EXPENSE
SB ELEVEN THIRTY SIX WILL
ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY LAYERS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW FOR
SPECIFIC PROJECTS WITHOUT
COMPROMISING IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL- BENEFITS. SB
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX WILL ALSO
EXPAND THE TYPES OF PROJECTS TO
QUALIFY FOR FOCUSED
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT AND
THEREBY THEREFORE ENABLE RAPID
INVESTMENT AND SKILLED
WORKFORCE. THESE POLICIES WILL
HELP FACILITATE THE BUILDING OF
CLIMATE ORIENTED PROJECTS
PROVIDING CERTAINTY IN DESIGNING
FINANCING AND PERMITTING TODAY I
HAVE WITH ME CHRIS TENANTS FROM
THE LA ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL. AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WENT
APPROPRIATE. HI CHRIS. HELLO
AGAIN- COMMITTEE CHAIR HONORABLE
SENATORS CHRIS HANNAN- EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY LOS ANGELES ORANGE
COUNTY'S BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT ABOUT DEPLOYMENT-
NEARLY A THIRD OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND- UNION
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WORK IN THE
R. JURISDICTION IN LOS ANGELES
AND ORANGE COUNTY'S AND WE HAVE
ROBUST RULEMAKING HAPPENING ON
ALL DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. CAN AFTER THAT
ROUTE. ROBUST RULEMAKING TAKES
PLACE AND REASONABLE.
CONSIDERATIONS TO ACCOMPLISH
THAT- THAT RULE MAKING OR THOSE
ENHANCEMENTS- THIS ALLOWS FOR IN
E. ARE ARE TO BE DONE AHEAD OF
TIME- DURING THE RULE MAKING
PROCESS SO WHEN WE GO TO DEPLOY
INDIVIDUAL PROCESS PROJECTS. TO
ACCOMPLISH OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND
TO KEEP JOBS GOING ARE IT ALLOWS
FOR A FOCUSED DIR SO THAT WE CAN
BE. PRECISE WE CAN GET PROJECTS
DELIVERED WE CAN DELIVER REAL
RESULTS FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
INCLUDING KEEPING OUR ECONOMY
RUNNING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU SOON THANK YOU. OKAY OUR
OTHER FOLKS YES MISTER WHICH-
THIS IS YOUR REMEMBER SCOTT WHAT
SHOULD WE HAVE TO SEE THIS IS A
SELECT WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARTRIDGE COUNSEL IN THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL ****
WORKERS IN THE ELEVATOR
CONSTRUCTORS UNION SUPPORT.
THANK THANK YOU OKAY- ANYONE
ELSE WANTS TO VOICE SUPPORT ME
ON THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR.
THIS IS SB ELEVEN THIRTY. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX. ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. AND WE'LL START
WITH MINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ALL RIGHT THANK COOKER
LINE SIXTY FOUR. YEAH MY NAME IS
LISA HOPE OF ALL OF IT VOCALIZED
FOR STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE FEE
SEVEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE LINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ROB NO
TALK ABOUT THE DIRECTOR OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR CALLING IN SUPPORT. NEXT
HEADLINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS DAVID BEANIE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE SANTA
CLARA AND SAN BENITO COUNTIES
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THIS
EXCELLENT BILL THANK YOU. AND I
HAVE LINE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT IS A TIMOTHY JEFFRIES
OF THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD
OF BOILERMAKERS ANY IN SUPPORT
OF AB. SIXTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX
IBM THIRTY SIX SPORTING THANK
YOU. NEXT HEADLINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FIVE. HEY
LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ANTHONY
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF IBEW
LOCAL ELEVEN. THANKS ABOUT
COUNTY ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. OKAY OUR FOLKS WANNA RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OPPOSITION. ON THEM ON THE PHONE
LINES- MODERATOR. SPEAKING UP
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
FIRST WE HAVE LINE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BIGELOW DAHLE.
THE NEW. THANKS WHICH FALLS
UNDER THE BRIDGE. LINE THIRTY
ONE YEAR LINE IS OPEN. YES YES.
ALL UP THERE ON THE LUXURY READY
RICK FILED BEFORE CALTRANS
DISTRICT COUNCIL LABORERS AND WE
ARE INSTRUCTED PORT I THOUGHT TO
BE IN AN EARLIER IN THAT WOULD
ALLOW ME TO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FIFTEEN NUMBER
ONE FIVE. THANK YOU. BUT IT'LL
ROPELESS WITH LABOUR DISTRICT
COUNCIL IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND- I'M CALLING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT LIKE THE OTHER CALLER
BEFORE NAY OUR THEME CUTE IN
NIGHT. YOU GET A CHANCE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
THAT WE HAVE LINE EIGHTY SEVEN
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS JOHN
FAULTY REPRESENTING THE FIRM
INYO AND MONO COUNTY BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY SIX
STANDING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSED. TO
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. OKAY I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU OKAY SO LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
UNDERSTRENGTH YET THANK YOU- I
JUST WANT TO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S DILIGENCE ON THIS IS
WAS THE COMMITTEES- HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME BASED ON THE ASSURANCE
THAT- THAT THE BILL WOULD STILL
PRESERVE COMMUNITY VOICE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT VOICE IN THE
SEQUEL PROCESS- I KNOW WE NEED
TO GET A LITTLE MORE CLARITY ON
THE SCOPE OF THE PROJECT
INCLUDED HERE BUT- IT. IT LOOKS
A SOLID BET ON IN TERMS OF-
REQUIREMENTS STILL TO MITIGATE
STILL OPPORTUNITY FOR LITIGATION
RECOURSE OF FOLKS ISSUES ARE MET
NONE OF THIS AND AROUND SEQUENCE
THAT'S I DON'T SEE ANY OF THIS
IN THE PROCESS. I DO SEE AN
OPTION FOR- FOR THIS SORT OF
FOCUS DIR- WHICH IS JUST A
DIFFERENT TIMELINE SO SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE SAYING STREAMLINING
OR- THIS IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
STREAMLINING THE MAYBE OTHER
THINGS WE'VE SEEN. SO IT FEELS
LIKE A PRETTY MODEST AMENDMENT
TO THE SHARE FRAMEWORK THAT. HAS
BEEN WORKING PRETTY WELL OVER
THE YEARS AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
. THANK YOU. YES I'LL GO AHEAD
NASKAPI THAT STEPHANOPOULOS IS
ON PAGE FIVE TALKS ABOUT- SINCE
WE'RE THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE ENVIRONMENT THAT THERE'D BE
CERTAIN CERTAIN MANDATES THAT
ARE INCLUDED HERE INCLUDING THE
LABOR REQUIREMENTS MAY MAKE
EXPEDITED PROJECTS ALREADY ON
THE BOOKS AND THERE AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY HI BRIAN SHEER
INELIGIBLE THEREFORE DEFEATING
SORT OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
STREAMLINING GOALS. IS SIR. CAN
YOU ADDRESS THAT- BECAUSE YOU'RE
ADDING MORE PROJECTS I GOT THAT
TICKET BALLYMORE ELIGIBILITY BUT
THERE'S SOME PROJECT. WHERE DOES
MR PROJECTS IN GENERAL. RIGHT
YEAH AND OBVIOUSLY I I'LL I'LL
LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE OUR GOAL IS
TO GET THESE PROJECTS DONE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO WE DON'T
WANT TO DELAY DELAY PROJECTS
ALREADY IN THE PIPELINE SO I'LL
HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT SO I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS THAT SOME PEOPLE
HAVE DONE A MASTER ER AND
THEY'RE GOING TO DO ON YOUR
SPECIFICALLY ARE ON SCRUBBERS
WHATEVER WHATEVER'S OING TO BE
ON IT IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND IN
THIS MAY DELAY THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK. THAT'S GOING
ON FOR MAKE IT INELIGIBLE FOR-
THEM TO DO IT IN AND BUMPED HIM
BACK INTO THE GENERAL SEQUELS.
RIGHT AT THE CAN. IS THAT RIGHT
YOU GOT A BUNCH OF FOLKS THAT
ARE. ELIGIBLE RIGHT NOW AND THIS
MAY. YOU'RE NOT LOOKING TO. JIM
OF THOSE GUYS ARE YOU I DON'T
BELIEVE SO OUR OUR GOAL IS TO
GET THINGS DONE QUICKER NOT
SLOWER SO THAT SOMETHING WILL
HAVE TO CLARIFY LOOK AT SO- OKAY
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW THAT. THIS
SPECIFIC PROJECT HE'S MATCHING I
DON'T HAVE AT MY FINGERTIPS. BUT
MY COMMITMENT IS TO LOOK AT THAT
AND WE CAN. DISCUSS IT AS THE
BILL MOVES- YOU KNOW. OKAY BUT
THE WHOLE GOAL IS TO MOVE THINGS
THROUGH THE PROCESS QUICKER NOT
SLOWER. OKAY I MEAN LOOK I THINK
AND- YOU KNOW AND I MEAN IT WAS
A WE HAD SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL UNITED BEEN
DISCUSSING- ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT CENTER CASKEY WAS RAISING-
YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND. YOU'RE
ONLY MADE AWARE THESE CONCERTS
LIKE EIGHT FORTY THIS MORNING SO
I ACTUALLY THEY FORTY THIS I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT AND I DON'T
YOU KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO- TO A WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S A PROBLEM OBVIOUSLY- SO.
I LOOK I MEAN I TAKE YOU IT WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU'RE SAYING. THAT THE
GOAL HERE IS TO NOT SLOW THINGS
DOWN FACT MAKE THINGS QUICKER- I
GUESS WHAT WHAT I WOULD ASK IF
WE DO YOU KNOW. HAPPY TO GIVE
THE COURTESY TO KEEP WORKING ON
THIS. I THAT WE DO SOME SOME
WORK TO ENSURE THAT THAT THE
GOLD YOU JUST STATED IS MET YEAH
I WOULD I WOULD COMMIT TO IS
THAT WOULD LOOK AT THEM PROJECT
BY PROJECT I MEAN IT IT. SEEMS
LIKE BOB HAS IDENTIFIED PROJECTS
SO LET'S LOOK AT THOSE FOR
SPECIFIC PROJECTS- I DON'T WANT
TO COMMIT TO. A LIST THAT WHAT
I'M COMMITTING TO IS LET'S LOOK
AT THE PRODUCT PROJECT BY
PROJECT TO SEE. HOW THIS IS
APPLICABLES. OKAY BUT I GUESS.
YOU KNOW I'M I'M THINKING THAT
WE WOULD WANT TO. MOVE YOU KNOW
THAT QUESTION. WE DON'T NEED TO
NEGOTIATE THIS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
A LABOR NEXT AT LEAST CONSIDER.
YEAH WELL OKAY SO I MEAN. GET
THEIR THEIR JURISDICTION IS NOT
NOT TOO CONCERNED ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL PRODUCTS PROJECTS
RIGHT THERE THEY'RE LOOKING AT
AND MAKING SURE THAT. WORKING
FOLKS ARE TREATED WELL AND AS
THEY ARE IN THIS BILL. SO IT'S
ULTIMATELY UP TO US TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE NOT DOING THINGS HERE
THAT ARE GOING TO. MESS UP OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS- SO I MEAN
I. WE DON'T HAVE TO DECIDE ON
THIS NOW BUT I WOULD THINK THEY
WOULD WANT TO DO SOMETHING THAT
WOULD. GRANDFATHER IN- YOU KNOW-
ALLOWED TO PROCEED EXISTING
PROJECTS THAT ARE. THAT ARE
THERE ARE. VERY MUCH ON THE WAR
ON ON THEIR ON THEIR- ON THEIR
WAY- BECAUSE I COULD SEE THAT
BECOMING A REAL PROBLEM IF WE
WERE TO. RIGHT MESSED US UP YEAH
AGAIN I'M I CAN MEMBERS TO LOOK
AT THOSE LOOK AT THAT LIST OF
PROJECTS AND WHERE THAT MAKES
SENSE. WORK WITH YOU AND WORK
WITH- ARE FOR. THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND SEE IF WE CAN DO A
PROJECT BY PROJECT VERSUS. A
BLANKET I'M JUST NOT PREPARED TO
MAKE A BLANKET. COMMITMENT ON
THAT BUT I AM WILLING TO SAY I
WORK WITH YOU. TO GO THROUGH THE
FULL LIST COMPREHENSIVELY AND IF
WE HAVE TO SIT DOWN. ALL OF US
IN A ROOM TO MAKE THAT WORK- I'M
WILLING TO DO THAT. OKAY
BATHROOMS AND GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THIS AGAIN CAN I KNOW I
KNOW I NOTING I KNOW. I KNOW
YEAH I'M I'M PREPARED TO MAKE
THAT YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND NOT
GONNA MAKE A COMMITMENT THAT.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIVE BY.
ANDERSON SO MIKE AND GO THROUGH
THE LIST WITH YOU. OKAY PURSUE
THAT CENTER YES CENTER BATES.
THANK YOU I DIDN'T COME TO ME
THIS MORNING IT CAME TO ME LAST
NIGHT AS I. READ AND I THOUGHT
GREAT BECAUSE X. EXPEDITING
PROJECTS REALLY REDUCES THE
COST. THEN I SEE THE OTHER SIDE
OF IT WHERE IT REQUIRES MPLA
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT WHICH
CAN IN SOME INSTANCES RAISE THE
COST. SO TODAY I WANT TO GIVE
YOU A COURTESY ARE ABLE. TO MOVE
IT ALONG BUT ON THE INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE GOOD TO
TAKE A LOOK AT DO YOU REALLY
NEED. YOU GOT THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE THAT'S GOOD.
AND OUT ALLOWS YOU KNOW SOME WHO
ARE NOT NECESSARILY. GOING TO
BE. IN A P. LA- TO COMPETE FOR
THESE PROJECTS THAT WILL BE A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT DECISION. IF
IT'S GOING TO BE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. NOT TO THEN TIE IT TO
ON EVERY PROJECT THE P. AWAY.
THAT WILL. I THINK DELAY IT
BECAUSE WILL BE PUSHED BACK. THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHERE THOSE
PROJECTS ARE. SO TODAY I'LL GIVE
YOU AND I BUT I LIKE TO WORK ON
THAT TOO IF YOU LOOK AT THOSE
PROJECTS. THANK THANK YOU EXTEND
. BUT CERTAIN. ISSUES QUESTIONS
CENTER GIVES US I THINK THEY'VE
BEEN ADDRESS BUT THE SAME YOU
KNOW WHERE WOULD THESE BE
APPLIED AND THE SCOPE OF THE
PROJECT AND I NOW YOU'LL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH. WITH THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE TO DO
THAT YEAH. THANK YOU. YEAH I
MEAN LOOK WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
STRUGGLING TO. MEET BASIC GOALS
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT ALL.
SESSION INCLUDING THIS TODAY.
AND- SO WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING
WE'RE GONNA WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THIS DOES SPEED UP
PROJECTS NOT SLOW THEM DOWN AS
YOU JUST ARTICULATED- I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT TODAY- THEN MAYBE WE
CAN ALSO LOOK AT. HIM PROJECT
SIZE I MET THE BIG PROJECTS MAKE
TOTAL SENSE THERE'S SMALL
PROJECTS OUT THERE WHERE. A IT
JUST MAY NOT MAKE SENSE I'D LOVE
TO. WE'RE WITH THE ON THAT TWO
SEVEN. OKAY I'M MOVED BY CENTER
STERN AYE AS AMY CLOSE. REQUEST
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER CONVERSATION
OKAY THANK YOU. ARCHETYPICAL
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB ELEVEN THIRTY
SIX BY SENATOR PORTANTINO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THAT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT ALAN HI ALAN HI BATES
BATES AYE DOLLY. DOLLY I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN HI BY
COUNTY. OKAY THAT'S OUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO YOU CENTER WEST SO-
THIS IS- SB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS.
WORKING ON A RIVER VALLEY
ELEMENT NEW RIVER ALONG THE
BORDER I REPRESENT THE ENTIRE
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA MEXICO AND
COURSE WE HAVE A CONSIDERABLE
CHALLENGES WITH THE WITH THE
WATER BODIES THAT- UGH UGH
BISECT THE BORDER. SO ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE IS
A LOT OF- BUT DEBRIS. ENDS UP
COMING INTO THE UNITED STATES
FROM- RAINFALL EVENTS AND SEWAGE
FLOWS- ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CONTAMINANTS ARE OUR TIRES THE
POSE. AN ENORMOUS THREAT TO THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO TO PUBLIC
HEALTH BECAUSE WATER GATHERS.
ALONG THE RIM RIM OF THE TIRE IN
A IS A BREEDING GROUND
OFTENTIMES FOR PESTS AND
MOSQUITOES. WHICH TRANSMIT
DISEASES SO- BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD OVER THE YEARS ON CLEANING
UP THESE WATER BODIES IT'S VERY
COSTLY COSTLY PROCESS TO GO
INTO. THESE A LARGE ESTUARIES
REMOVE TIRES OFTENTIMES ARE
BURIED DEEP IN THE GROUND OTHER
TIMES. THEY'RE A AFFECTING A
VERY IMPORTANT HABITAT. THIS
BILL. WAS CONCEIVED WORKING
TOGETHER WITH CAL RECYCLE. AND
THE GOVERNMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
WE'VE DECIDED TO WORK ON A
PROGRAM TO LIMIT. THE TRADE OF
TIRES OFTENTIMES USED TIRES THAT
ARE NO LONGER USEFUL IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE SOLD BY
COMPANIES INTO MEXICO WHERE
THEY'RE RE USED. AS TIRES OFTEN
TIMES THE GROOVED AND PAINTED TO
LOOK LIKE NEW TIRES BUT THEY'RE
VERY DANGEROUS TIRES YOU KNOW AS
PEOPLE ARE GETTING. TIRES THAT
ARE REALLY NOT SAFE TO DRIVE AND
THEY OFTEN CAUSE ACCIDENTS. SO
THIS IS A BI NATIONAL EFFORT
TOGETHER WITH THE- COUNTRY OF
THE STATE OF. CALIFORNIA TO
LIMIT THE SALE. SO ESSENTIALLY
WORK IN OUR CYCLE WOULD OF- WE
TOOK SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND CREATE THIS BILL. WITH THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE COVER CYCLE
TO STRENGTHEN THE CALIFORNIA
TIRE TRACKING SYSTEM. TO
QUANTIFY MORE PRECISELY THE
NUMBER OF USED TYRES FLOWING
FROM CALIFORNIA. AND FROM OTHER
STATES THROUGH CALIFORNIA INTO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
NEAR THE NEARBY STATE OF SONATA.
IT REQUIRES COVER CYCLE TO WORK
WITH THE UNITED STATES CONS
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION TO
OBTAIN DETAILED DATA. ON A
CALIFORNIA USED TIRE EXPORTS TO
THE STATE OF BUG CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO THE
PORCH OF WRECKED VEHICLES. AUTO
DISMANTLE OURS IT PROHIBITS A
PERSON FROM SELLING AN UNSAFE
USED TIRE AS DEFINED FOR USE BY
A MOTOR VEHICLE ON A HIGHWAY.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
THAT WILL HELP IMPROVE OUR
ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY. YOU KNOW
OFTENTIMES THESE THESE TIRES CAN
BE USED ON ON COMMERCIAL
VEHICLES SOUTH OF THE BORDER.
AND PUTS- PEOPLE'S LIVES IN AT
RISK AND WE WANT TO LIMIT THAT
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND- WE
THANK OUR CYCLE FOR THEIR
COOPERATION HELPING US ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM. AND WE THANK YOU
MISTER AND YOUR STAFF FOR
HELPING US WITH THIS BILL AS
WELL. AND I JUST WANTED TO-
STATES THAT I BELIEVE. THAT-
YEAH I THINK I COVERED
EVERYTHING. AS THERE WERE NO
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. SO THERE
ARE A FEW OUT THERE NO PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND I THANK YOU FOR
HELPING US WITH THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR OKAY- I'VE
BEEN ONE VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. ANYONE THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR WAS THE VOICE SUPPORT
FOR SB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE. BUT
FOR SB ELEVEN ANYONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. WE THAT ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I HAVE
NO ONE IN KILL ANYONE OPPOSITION
I DON'T SEE ON HERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES MOTOR AND ONCE
OF SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS ABOUT SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
ONE. I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE ANY
RESERVATION. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE. ONE THEN ZERO.
AND I HAVE NO IN INDIA BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
THOUGHTS. OKAY MOVE BY CENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS AND I'VE I'VE BEEN
DOWN WITH YOU TO THE BOARD
ACTUALLY AND- WE HAD A
FASCINATING PRESENTATION ON THIS
VERY TOPIC SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THIS. I
KNOW- YEAH IT'S SOMETHING E. M.
A I WANT TO THANK YOU YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK YOU'VE DONE TRYING
TO ALSO ALERT YOUR COLLEAGUES AS
TO AS TO THE POLLUTION
CHALLENGES THERE THE RIVER SO
MUCH TO BE DONE IN. YOU
CERTAINLY ALERTED ME TO IT. SOME
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ALL RIGHT YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
IS SIMPLY ASK FOR SUPPORT OKAY.
OCTOBER'S COLOR. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR HUESO. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION.
ALAN HI. ALAN I BATES. NOT
VOTING DALLI DALLI AYE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER INNER AYE
STERN STERN AYE WHY CASKEY. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER ARE I DON'T
SEE CENTER WE WANT MAYBE TENER
SKINNER YOU WANT GO AHEAD AND
PRESENT CONTENT THINGS WERE HERE. BUT. BUT I JUST DO IT FROM
YOUR FIRST WE'RE GOING TO
ADDRESS K. GREAT I'M ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND OF
WHAT THIS PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
IS TO HAVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BE A LEADER IN THE
SAME WAY THAT WE ARE ASKING OUR
CONSUMERS AND- OUR- OUR
CONSUMERS AND OUR PRIVATE SECTOR
TO BE A LEADER. SO WE HAVE AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT BANS THE
SALE OF LIGHT DUTY GAS FUELED
CARS BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE IN
MEDIUM HEAVY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. AND GIVEN THAT WE ARE
DOING THAT STATEWIDE. I WANT
CALIFORNIA. IN OUR OWN PURCHASE
OF VEHICLES TO BE A MODEL FOR
THAT TRANSITION. SO SB TEN TEN
WOULD- INCREASE THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR STATE PURCHASE OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES TWO HUNDRED
PERCENT. BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX
FOR LIGHT DUTY AND A 100% BY
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT FOR MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY. AND WITH THAT
I'LL HAVE MY- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BILL MCGOVERN IN READ
OUT S. YEAH I SAW THE MOVIE HERE
A MINUTE AGO. ANYONE ELSE WANT
TO VOICE SUPPORT WHAT WHAT WILL
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME
BACK BUT JUST TO KEEP MOVING. OF
FOLKS WHO WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL ANYONE. YES YOU
LIKE TO COME. PRESSURES SUPPORT
. I DON'T LOSE ANY RESEARCH
OPPOSITION TO AMERICAN RIGHT
YEAH YES MA'AM. BOB HI
INDIVISIBLE GREEN TEAM-
SACRAMENTO LIKE TO VEHICLE SO
SHE XIN IN SUPPORT GREAT THANK
YOU. MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES YOU WANT TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR CENTER
SKINNER'S BILL THIS IS A B. SB
TEN TEN. ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF S.
T. TEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE FORTY TWO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JANET **** THREE FIFTY
THOUSAND VALIANT STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GET LINE NUMBER
. OKAY IN THIS RECORD. AND LINE
NUMBER NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS CHERYL ****
REPRESENTING THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CHAPTER THE CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. IF. AND ONE
MOMENT. FOR REAL HARM. WELL I DO
TOO. RIGHT. OKAY I'M WE DO HAVE
THREE MORE OKAY. LINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI
THIS IS THE WORLD YEAH ON BEHALF
OF CLIMATE REALITY SILICON
VALLEY IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
THAT LINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YOU KNOW THIS IS THE ROSENBAUM
POLLOCK OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORTER CENTERS UNITS
EXCELLENT SB KENTON. TEN NINETY
ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS AUDRA HARTMAN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AND LINES
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JANET FORTUNA
REPRESENTING. IN FIFTEEN IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH AT ANALY NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OF THREE HELLO
THIS IS BILL MURPHY REPRESENTING
THE THOUSAND MEMBERS OF OTHERS
CLIMATE ACTION SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OKAY THANK YOU AND NOW
I HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION I DON'T BELIEVE IS
ANY PRESS OPPOSITION ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR WANTS
TO VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AB ONE AND
HERE ON YOUR PHONE. ALL RIGHT.
AND I HAVE NO RUNNING OKAY THANK
YOU THE MEASURES BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR FOLKS THE WAY
ENERGY AS QUESTIONS- YEAH CENTER
GONZALEZ I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THE SORTS OF TOTALLY REASONABLE
BILL IS LOOKING- AS WELL AND I
WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
pMUCH. AND- I HEAR MOTIONS. YES
SEND US A LONG ON I'M NOT MOVING
THE BILL OKAY- OKAY. HELLO YES I
JUST WANTED TO KIND OF GET WE
JUST HAD A BILL EARLIER. THE
CARD SENATOR KIRBY THERE WAS
BILL WE TALKED ABOUT HOW. YOU
KNOW SETTING TARGETS AND DATE.
IMPACT YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT HOW
THE PROCESS LOOK SO I'M I'M
THINKING OF. JUST MY DISTRICT
ALONE WE HAVE. STATE HIGHWAYS
THAT. HAVE VEHICLES THAT WOULD
SHOW CALTRANS USES VEHICLES.
THAT ARE. EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
NINE HUNDRED POUNDS AND HEAVIER
SNOW PLOWS SNOW BLOWERS- ALL
THOSE ARE. GOING TO BE REGULATED
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO BE ZERO
EMISSIONS AT- TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT YES- AND I'M NOT
SURE THAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS EVEN
AVAILABLE TO MEET THAT IF IT'S
IF IT'S ZERO MISSION AND WE'RE
USING HYDROGEN I'M NOT SURE THAT
WE HAVE. THE FACILITIES TO EVEN
. BUT HYDROGEN OUT THERE SO I
WHAT'S THE PROCESS OF GETTING
WHERE WE'RE GOING I MEAN I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE SETTING A TARGET.
AND I'M CONCERNED THAT. YOU MEET
YOU MEETING THAT IS GOING TO BE
VERY DIFFICULT AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE I DON'T BELIEVE
IS IN PLACE SO CAN YOU EXPAND ON
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE. ABOUT TO
GET. TO WHERE WE WANT TO GO.
CERTAINLY THE- THE HEAVY DUTY
ART IS A- TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
TARGET. AND WHILE THAT MAY SEEM
VERY. YOU KNOW. IT'S LIKE
TOMORROW IT'S NOT. AND WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE ADVANCEMENT THE
NUMBER OF MANUFACTURERS OF EV'S.
IN ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES TODAY
AS COMPARED TO EVEN TWO YEARS
AGO. IT SIGNIFICANT. AND WE IF
YOU ARE MONITORING ANY OF THE
TRADE PUBLICATIONS BASICALLY
EVERY. VEHICLE MANUFACTURER IS
NOW PUTTING OUT MODELS OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. SO I. I THINK
THAT IT'S- NOT- ON. AND
SUBSTANTIATED TO PROJECT THAT WE
WILL HAVE. THOSE OF YOU A
FAVORABLE VEHICLES AT THAT POINT
AND- AND THAT WILL. WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MEET THE GOALS NOW
CLEARLY A RB HAS THE ABILITY TO
MODIFY IF WE FIND THAT AT THAT
POINT WE'RE NOT. BUT THIS IS YOU
KNOW COULD BE A STRETCH GOAL BUT
WE'RE BASICALLY THE STATUS
ALREADY BY EXECUTIVE ORDER
INDICATING THAT WE WON'T SELL
COMBUSTION VEHICLES JUST A FEW
YEARS HERE AFTER. SO WE'RE
SENDING ALL THE RIGHT MARKET
SIGNALS FOR SUCH TECHNOLOGIES IN
VEHICLES TO BE AVAILABLE IN THE
MARKETPLACE. I JUST VOTE I'M
GONNA I'M NOT GONNA BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY I
THINK THAT IT'S PREMATURE I
THINK THE TWO GOALS ARE GREAT
BUT AT IN THE DAY CALIFORNIANS.
ARE EXPECTED IF THEY'RE GONNA BE
PAYING MORE ANY PAYING AS
TAXPAYERS TO RETROFIT OR TO
EXCHANGE OUT. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A LOT OF CALIFORNIA THAT.
THAT CALIFORNIANS RELY ON TO
TAKE CARE THEIR PUBLIC SERVICES
AND IN FOR EXAMPLE. THE SNOW
PLOWS AND TRUCKS AND HEAVY DUTY
EQUIPMENT THAT WE USE EVERY DAY
IN CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT WE NEED AND I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IS GOING TO BE
IN PLACE AND I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW THE YEAH WE'RE MOVING
FASTLY TO- YOU KNOW ELECTRICAL
VEHICLES BUT WHEN YOU START
GETTING TO THE HEAVY DUTY I MEAN
WE TO AND WE HAD THIS DISCUSSION
TRANSPORTATION- ABOUT THE PORTS.
AND ABOUT. DRIED STRIKES IN AND
THEY HAVE A STRUCTURE THERE AS
WELL AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE OUT
IN THIS IS A LARGE STAT. WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PUTTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ALPINE COUNTY
WHICH I REPRESENT TO HAVE AN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE THERE IS THERE
THERE'S GONNA HAVE TO BE SOME. I
DON'T BELIEVE IT'LL WORK I DON'T
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CHARGE THESE
VEHICLES TO OR IF IT'S HYDROGEN
WILL HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THAT SO I'M LOOKING AT WHAT
TECHNOLOGY GOING TO WORK IN
ALPINE COUNTY OR- OR- TO. WHERE
WE HAVE YOU KNOW. FIFTEEN FEET
OF SNOW SOMETIMES AND THE BILL
THE BILL TO KEEP PEOPLE MOVING I
THINK THIS IS A VERY- RISKIER.
ABOUT I WAS DOESN'T DIRECTOR FOR
THREE RIGHT THREE CONCEPT FOR
SPONDON THAT THIS IS PER
PURCHASE RIGHT BY THE STATE'S
AND- WE DON'T THE STATE DOESN'T
REPLACE VEHICLES ON AN ANNUAL
ALL VEHICLES ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
THERE ARE LONGER TERM SO IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE ALL. OF THAT
EQUIPMENT TO BE ON TO BE SEVENTH
THAT YEAR JUST THE NEW PURCHASE
BUT THERE'S ALSO THE BILL
ALREADY HAS BUILT INTO AN
OFFRAMP FOR DGS. TO INDICATE
THAT THERE'S NOT AN AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY SO IF WE HAVE NOT
ACHIEVED THOSE AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGIES BY. THE TIME THERE
IS OFFERING IN THE BILL. FRANK
OKAY. MMHM ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS
CONCERNS QUESTIONS- THE MOVE BY
CENTER GONZALEZ. CONSULTAS CORAL
I WAS ARE YOU MAY CLOSE I'M
SORRY I ASKED FOR A VOTE. I THE
NUMBER ELEVEN SB TEN TEN BY
CENTERS SKINNER THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS ALAN
HI ALAN I BATES. IT'S NOT VOTING
DALLY KELLY NO GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I SKINNER BUT SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE CASKEY. GREAT ALL RIGHT AND
THREE VOTES SO WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN. BUSTER YEAH I YEAH WE
CAN THIS GARDEN OKAY I SEE
SENATOR LEONYS HERE TO PRESENT
HER SB TWELVE THIRTY. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS SB TWELVE
THIRTY WILL STREAMLINE THE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA HAS
TO INCENTIVIZE CONSUMERS TO
SWITCH TO LOWER EMISSION
VEHICLES THIS BILL REQUIRE CARP
TO SINGLE PORTAL WHERE A PERSON
CAN APPLY FOR ALL OF THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS ONLINE. MAKING THE
NETWORK OF PROGRAMS EASIER TO
UNDERSTAND AND ACCESS THERE IS
ALSO THERE CAN ALSO BE A LONG
PERIOD BETWEEN WHEN A PERSON
APPLIES TO ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND WHEN THEY RECEIVE THE
INCENTIVE UNFORTUNATELY MANY
PEOPLE CANNOT AFFORD TO WAIT
MONTHS. TO GET A NEW VEHICLE AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROCESS IS NOT A BARRIER FOR
GETTING AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
FINALLY THE BILL WILL EXPAND TO
CLICK EXPAND THE CLEAN CAR FOR
ALL PROGRAM ACROSS THE STATE
INSTEAD OF IT BEING LIMITED TO
INDIVIDUAL AIR DISTRICTS. AT
TODAY WE HAVE- BENJAMIN I
CURRENT THE DIRECTOR OF LET'S GO
GREEN CALIFORNIA AND CAMILLA
CHÁVEZ THE DIRECTOR OF THE
ARTIST THE FOUNDATION TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. CHAIR
ALLEN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANKS VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
BENJAMIN I KERR AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE ROMERO
INSTITUTES. LET'S GREEN
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE AND WE'RE
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY. FIRST I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR LIMON FOR AUTHORING THIS
BILL IN THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR HARD
THOUGHTFUL WORK. TO PROTECT OUR
SHARED ENVIRONMENT. IS YOU KNOW
EMISSIONS FROM CARS AND TRUCKS
HAVE LONG BEEN A THORN IN
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO ATTAIN
SAFE. HEALTHY AIR QUALITY FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE
CONDUCTED OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
AND LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
COMMUNITIES. TO HELP THEM GET
INTO CLEAN CARS DOING THIS WORK
WE LEARN THAT WHAT CALIFORNIA
HAS STRONG PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT%
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES. AND
THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE DONE A LOT
OF GOOD WORK. UNFORTUNATELY THE
INCENTIVE LANDSCAPE IS DIFFICULT
TO NAVIGATE. THERE ARE PROGRAMS
EACH WITH ITS OWN APPLICATION
AND ITS OWN TIMING FOR APPROVAL
IN USE. IN PRACTICE THESE
PROGRAMS DON'T MEET THE NEEDS OF
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
RESIDENTS. WHO EIGHT DON'T HAVE
THE EXPENDABLE INCOME TO BE ABLE
TO BUY NOW AND RECEIVE A REBATE
LATER. AND TO BE WHO TEND TO
DRIVE THEIR CURRENT VEHICLE
UNTIL IT BREAKS DOWN. WHICH
MEANS WAITING PERIODS ARE
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE WHEN THEY
NEED IT. THAT NEED IS URGENT. BY
SIMPLIFYING AND STREAMLINING THE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE INCENTIVES
UNDER A ONE STOP SHOP. AND
MAKING FUNDS AVAILABLE AT POINT
OF SALE. SB TWELVE THIRTY AIMS
TO ENSURE THESE PROGRAMS BETTER
SERVE THOSE WHO NEED THE MOST.
ADDITIONALLY WE FOUND A LACK OF
ACCESS TO PUBLIC CHARGERS. IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
CREATES AN ADDITIONAL BARRIER TO
ADOPTION. INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD
OUT LAGS BEHIND DEMAND. IN THIS
DYNAMIC NEEDS TO BE FLIPPED. THE
SECOND PART OF SB TWELVE THIRTY
ALTHOUGH. AND LANGUAGE. COOLEY
AIMS TO ACCELERATE THE BUILD OUT
OF CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
ENSURE THAT INVESTMENT IS
EQUITABLE. AND SUSTAINABLE IN
CONCLUSION SB TWELVE THIRTY CAN
HELP ENSURE. THAT AS WE PURSUE
OUR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE GOALS.
WORKING FAMILIES AND FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT. OF THAT TRANSITION.
COMBINED WITH THE WORK FORCE
STANDARDS ALREADY IN PLACE UNDER
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY ONE.
YOU CAN CREATE GOOD PAYING JOBS
AND GROWTH THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE. CALIFORNIA
WILL NEED WELL INTO THE FUTURE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON SB TWELVE THIRTY. AND
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CAMILA TRAVIS MD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
DOLLARS WORTH THE FOUNDATIONS
AND WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS. OF
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY BUT
THE LOTUS WHAT THE FOUNDATION IS
BASED IN BAKER SMELLED. AND WE
WORK THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY NOT A SINGLE ONE. OF THE
EIGHT. COUNTIES IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY CURRENTLY HAVE
SAFE LEVELS OF OZONE. AND SMART
SMALL PARTICULATES THIS IS
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. THESE TOXIC AIR
POLLUTANTS ARE PRODUCED FROM THE
TAILPIPES OF TWENTY NINE MILLION
CARS AND TRUCKS HERE IN OUR
STATE CAUSING RESPIRATORY
ILLNESS DEVELOPMENTAL AND HEALTH
MATH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. HEART
PROBLEMS AND SHORTENED
LIFESPANS. IT IS NOT OKAY THAT
ONE IN SIX CHILDREN AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY HAVE ASTHMA THE
HIGHEST LEVEL IN OUR STATE. THIS
IS AN INTERGENERATIONAL
INJUSTICE SUFFERED PREDOMINATELY
BY LOW INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR ACCELERATING CLEAN CARD
OPTION AND HISTORICALLY
OVERLOOKED AREAS WILL HAVE TO.
AND THIS IMPACTS. BOARDING TO
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION A
RAPID CLEAN CAR TRANSITION WOULD
PREVENT MORE THAN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND PREMATURE DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE COMING
DECADES. THE BENEFITS GOING TO
LOW INCOME AND HISTORICALLY
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES. OUR
FOUNDATION STRIVES TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF WORKING AND
UNDERSERVED FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE BELIEVE THAT SB
TWELVE THIRTY WILL MEANINGFULLY
REDUCED HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
BURDENS. IN OUR STATE ON A
BETTER PATH TO MEETING OUR
CLIMATE AND CLEAN AIR GOALS WE
THANK SENATOR LAWAN AND THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE THE SUPPLY THERE YES
WE CAN. THANK YOU ARE LOCAL TO
THE ANYONE ELSE WANT TO VOICE
SUPPORT YEP. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOT WHICH SHOULD BE AFTER THE
STATE ASSOCIATION ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION UTILITY EMPLOYEES. THE
SPONSORS OF AB FORTY ONE WE
THINK THIS IS A COMPLEMENTARY
BILL WITH YOUR DRIVER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SCOTT. YES MA'AM. YOUR
SALAD WITH INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG CLIMATE
JUSTICE GROUP INDIVISIBLE GREEN
TEAM AND SEGMENTAL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
RIGHT WAS BUILT. ALL RIGHT I ON
THE PHONE LINES MATTER ANYONE
WAS WITH SUPPORT FOR A CENTER IN
THE MONTHS BILL TWELVE THIRTY.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE AT THIS TIME. AND
FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE NINETY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE COMPARTMENT CENTRE IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB TWELVE THIRTY
THANK YOU. NEXT HEADLINE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BILL MURPHY ON BEHALF
OF THE THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
LINE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS EMILY DOMINGUEZ
I AM A MEMBER OF THE AND LET'S
OBISPO CLIMATE COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF AT THE. THIRTY AND
THAT'S LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY MY NAME'S CHRIS
LESS CALLING FROM SANDRA TELL
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT SB. TWELVE
THIRTY. AND THEN ONE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JANET
TALKED FOR THREE FIFTIES SO IT
CAN RALLY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS. WE HAVE LINE. ONE OH
ONE. I HAD. NINE ONE ONE. HELLO
MY NAME IS MANY FRED VERY. I'M
CALLING FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA
AND I'M CALLING COURTS AB TWELVE
THIRTY ON THE PART OF THE LEFT
GREEN COALITION AND I ALSO
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE
AND R. EIGHTY SEVEN CHAPTERS
HAVE SUPPORTED THIS BILL AS A
PRIORITY BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
. OKAY THANK YOU LET'S- GO TO-
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL I WOULD ONLY RAISE
REPETITION ANYONE WHO'S
ANNOUNCED THEY WANTED VOICE OF
OPPOSITION I ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR. WANTS TO VOICE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL. I WANT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WOMEN HERE ON YOUR PHONE. AND
I HAVE NO NHL FOR LET'S BE BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS COMMENTS YES SENATORS
OFFICE. AT SOME OF THE BILL
INAPPROPRIATE I THINK THIS IS A
FANTASTIC OBVIOUSLY AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT CLEAN CARS FOR ALL ON
HOW TO EXPAND ELIGIBILITY BUT-
JUST HAD A BILL TO REDUCE THE
REMOVE THE SALES TAX. IN MORE
FOLKS- IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS AND TO KNOW THAT THEIR
PART OF THIS. NEW GENERATION OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND SO IT
I THANK YOUR SPONSORS AS WELL
AND THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING AROUND
THE SPACE SO I THINK THAT THIS
IS COMBINED AT THE BIG. YOU KNOW
CHANGE FOR OUR DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU THE
CENTER OKAY TO MOVE YES AND
DOLLY. SO A- IS THIS PROGRAM.
ALLOW IS STATEWIDE FOR ANY ANY
ERRORS IS JUST AS- AIRBASES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SO
THIS IS THE SAME PAIRED AIRBASES
SO THIS IS WHAT THIS IS DOING IS
ACTUALLY CONSOLIDATING
INFORMATION THIS BILLS ACTUALLY
NOT. NECESSARILY CHANGING THE
PROGRAM PER SE I THINK THERE'S
OTHER VEHICLES THAT ARE TALKING
ABOUT HOW TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM-
BUT CERTAINLY AT THE FOCUS AND
HAS BEEN AROUND A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AT THE SENATOR DID
YOU WANT TO CHIME IN THERE IS A
HUGE HELPING YOU NO NO NO AND I
WAS GONNA ACTUALLY GO SHE'S I
MEAN AS OUR TERROR
TRANSPORTATION I THOUGHT THAT
MAYBE SHE WOULD BE IN A BETTER
PLACE IN FACT. I NEED YOU MATED
TO INTERESTING THE AMENDMENTS IN
TRANSPORTATION THAT'S RIGHT SO I
YES THAT WAS THE FIRST- THAT
THERE ARE A BUNCH AMENDMENTS
THEY'RE JUST BILLS YES YES I IN
A ACCEPTED ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
RIGHT. YES BUT BUT SHE'S GONNA
TAKE HIM. YES AND I YOU GUYS
GONNA SOME ADDITIONAL WORK. OKAY
I'M TRUST TRYING TO WE HAD A
STUDY A COUPLE YEARS BACK AND WE
ACTUALLY TRACKED WHO WAS
GETTING. TAKING ADVANTAGE OF.
THE REBATES AND LYFT AND SUCH
FOR ZAPS AND QUITE FRANKLY WE
SAW. A HUGE PROPORTION OF THOSE
REBATES COMING FROM. COASTAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE CLEAN AIR AND-
WEALTHIER PEOPLE AND WE SAW
COMMUNITIES LIKE FRESNO AND- AND
THE THEIR BASES ARE VERY
IMPAIRED NOT GETTING THIS IS A
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. TRYING TO.
STREAMLINED ACROSS THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL IS REALLY DO IS
PUTTING RIGHT STREAMLINED BUT
ALSO MAKE IT STATE WIDE AND THE
OTHER PIECE THAT IS PART OF THIS
IS THAT THERE ARE STATE PRO.
THERE'S ALSO THE STRICT PROGRAM
AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO ACTUALLY
COMBINED THE INFORMATION SO THAT
ALL OF OUR FOLKS. YOU KNOW
WHEREVER THERE I CAN GO ON TO
ONE PLACE AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
ARE ALL THE PROGRAMS THAT THEY
COULD POTENTIALLY QUALIFY FOR
BOTH STATEWIDE AND LOCAL BUT
THIS IS. A PROGRAM IN ANY DEAL A
TICKET EXPAND STATEWIDE- IT
THROUGH KIND OF CONDENSING AND
STREAMLINING THE INFORMATION THE
PROGRAM ITSELF IT'S NOT DOING.
AS MANY CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM
ITSELF. SO IT'S A WHITE I WAS
ONE MAKE SURE UNDERSTANDS
BECAUSE IS NOT PRIORITIZING. THE
RESOURCES TO THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES FIRST IT'S JUST
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS FOR
EVERYBODY THIS BILL RIGHT BUT
THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
MAKING SURE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THAT YOU BROUGHT UP HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE NOT APPLYING FOR THIS
AND SO I THINK THAT'S A PROBABLY
MORE COMPLICATED CONVERSATION-
IN TERMS OF BOTH. THE VEHICLE
PIECE BUT OFTEN ALSO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PIECE RIGHT BOTH
NEED TO HAPPEN. THANK YOU. OKAY
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATE GONZALEZ- YOU MAY CLOSE
EXACTLY THAT'S WHAT I WAS VERY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I DON'T THIS
CORAL ITEM NUMBER TEN SB TWELVE
THIRTY BY SENATOR LOAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION ALLEN AYE ALLEN
AYE BATES. DALLY NOT NOT VOTING
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN EYEWEAR
CASKEY. OKAY GREAT WE'VE FOR
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
OTHER FOLKS THAT ON THANK YOU
LET'S NOT GO TO YOU CENTER STERN
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL LAST BILL
OF THE DAY WE ALSO DO HAVE TO
ENTERTAIN WAS FOR THE CONTENT
CALIBER DO THAT AFTER CENTER
STERN GO FOR IT OKAY YEAH OUR
TEAM IS CHAIR OF BEFORE BEGIN
JUST WANT TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDED NOW ALSO
SOME SIX- THAT EXTENDS REPORTING
DEADLINE. FROM JANUARY TO JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR- AND MEMBERS
THIS THIS BILL IS REALLY ABOUT
PROMOTING CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
EFFICIENCY GOALS WHICH WE TALK
ABOUT A LOT OF OTHER GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION TECHNOLOGIES OUT
THERE BUT EFFICIENCY IS ALWAYS
THE CHEAPEST AND THE LATE GREAT
ART ROSENFELD TOLD US THAT IF
YOU STILL NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
A **** WHAT IS GREATER THAN ANY
MEGA WATTS- FROM A COST
PERSPECTIVE BUT THE PROP IS THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS ARE.
GETTING ALWAYS WHAT THEY PAY FOR
AND THE QUALITY OF OUR
INSTALLATIONS HAS BEEN FALTERING
IN THE SPECIFICALLY THE- HEATING
AND COOLING SPACE- H. FAQ
EQUIPMENT SALES- ARE ARE
INSTALLED OFTEN- HELLO CODE
REQUIREMENTS- IN TOTAL TWENTY
FOUR- CCNP YOU SEE A FOUND THE
CONTRACTORS PULLING H. BACK
REPLACEMENT PERMITS OCCUR AS
LITTLE AS 10% OF THE TIME AND
CONTRACTORS COMPLY WITH TITLE
TWENTY FOUR AS LITTLE AS 15% OF
THE TIME. SO IF YOU IMPROPERLY
INSTALL YOUR H. FAQ YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE INCREASED ENERGY USE
BECAUSE NOT GOING TO WORK RIGHT
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY HIGHER BILLS
MORE GREENHOUSE GASES GOING TO
EMERGE SO WE'RE TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER SOME KIND OF
DOCUMENTATION REGISTRY ATTRACT
REGISTRY THESE ARE NOT NEW IDEAS
WE'VE BEEN CALLING FOR THIS FOR
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN YEARS FROM
CALIFORNIA'S AGENCIES AND SO WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE. WE'RE
TIED UP IN THAT PEOPLE ARE ARE
GETTING SPANKED. I'M IN US HERE
TODAY. SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION
THE CALF- PIPED COUNCIL. A WHICH
IS WAS THOMAS LOW WITH THE WAY
STATES COUNCILS METAL. AND I A
PRE. ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK YOU
SHERMAN REMEMBER SCOTT YOUR BILL
CALIFORNIA T. PAY TO COUNTS.
TELL TWENTY FIVE. CAN ARE ENERGY
FOR SO. STUDY AFTER STUDY OVER A
DECADE IS SHOWN THAT VERY FEW
PEOPLE. ARE PULLING PERMITS
THEIR FOR THEIR CIRCUMVENTING
TELL TWENTY FOUR WE'RE NOT MERE
ENGINE GOALS THIS BILL IS A VERY
MODEST APPROACH TO ADDRESS THAT.
WE WERE URGING I VOTE FOR THOSE
ON THE PHONE WHO ARE CALLING YOU
TO SUPPORT BECAUSE OF THE TIME
IN THIS ROOM I WOULD ASK THEM TO
FORGO TESTIFYING. BUT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. WE SHOULD
THAT. COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF THAT
WESTERN STATES CONSERVE SHEET
METAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT YOU
KNOW- WE CAN HAVE THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE BUILDING STANDARDS WE
WANT BUT WITHOUT ENFORCEMENT
WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY CHEATING. ON
THE OUTCOMES WE NEED ARM OUR OWN
ESTIMATES SO JUST IMPROVING ITS
SPECTRUM PLANTS WITH A FOUR
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS IN PEAK DEMAND
A YEAR. SO THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL TO ADDRESS ISSUES
AND THESE ARE NOT NEW SOLUTIONS
FOR FIFTY YEARS BY AGENCIES BUT
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED WE NED TO
MAKE SURE THIS HAPPENS NOW.
THANK YOU AND I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU MR- WET FOR THE COMMON AND
WE MEMBERS IF YOU WANT TO SEE
THE FOLKS ARE AT THE PORT. OF
THE BILL PAGE SIX I WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES OF ANYONE
REALLY DOES WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY GET THEIR VOICE AND BUT- I
BUT THAT THE WHAT THE FOLKS IN
SUPPORTER ON PAGE SIX OF YOUR
ANALYSIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN. OF THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AB ONE LINE QUEUING UP. IN. SIX
HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BUSY REHEARSING AND I
COULD TERRY A FORMER ABOUT THE
PRICE WE ARE AN L. G. B. T. I.
Q. U. S. PLUS COMMUNITY GROUP IN
THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY OF
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ONE TWO
THREE ZERO YEAH FIRST OF THE SO
SORRY THIS IS THE WRONG WRONG
BILL WE JUST PASSED THAT BILL
BUT APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOUR
YOUR YOUR EMPLOY A GREAT DEAL.
I'M OKAY AND I DO APOLOGIZE
EVERYONE THAT THE ISSUE HERE IS
THAT WE GOT A HEARING IT ONE
THAT THE FOLKS HAVE TO SWITCH
EVERYONE OUT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE AT TWELVE BUT THAT'S NOT
ANYONE'S FAULT HERE OKAY I'M- NO
. ELSE CAN KILL THE YOU MISS
KEPT PLEASE COME ON UP IN. IN IN
YOUR CAN ABOUT THE. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS DONT CHEMO CAP
CANA. I'M HAPPY CONDITION
HEATING REFRIGERATION INSTITUTE.
HERE IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. I CERTAINLY WE'VE BEEN
IN CONTACT- WITH THE SENATOR
STAFF I REGARDING CONCERNS. TO
BE CLEAR H. ARAI IN ITS HVAC OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES AND
MANUFACTURERS OF ALL THE THIS
OEM EQUIPMENT. ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF PROPER PERMITTING
AS WELL AS PROPER INSTALLATION
FULL STOP WITHOUT QUESTION.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE A CONCERN
THAT ALTHOUGH THIS IS AT LEAST
IN ITS CURRENT FORM JUST REPORT.
THAT WOULD BE DRAFTED. DOES
PRESUPPOSE THAT THE ANSWER TO
THAT PROBLEM CONCERNS. IS A
SERIAL OUR TRACKING SYSTEM AND
SALES REGISTRY. ARE ONLY AND THE
CLINTON MANUFACTURERS AS YOU CAN
APPRECIATE MANUFACTURE EQUIPMENT
NOT ONLY JUST FOR CALIFORNIA BUT
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY
SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SETTING UP A REGISTER SALES
REGISTRY AS WELL AS TRACKING
NUMBERS. AT OUR FOLKS ARE JUST
NOT CONVINCED THAT THIS IS GOING
TO HELP RESOLVE THE UNDERLYING
CONCERNS ABOUT PERMITTING OR
LACK OF PERMITTING. AND PROPER
INSTALLATION WE HAVE AS AN
INDUSTRY BEEN WORKING WITH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION FOR MANY YEARS
NOT ONLY ON THIS PARTICULAR TYPE
OF AN APPROACH. AND. SOME
ADDITIONAL CONCEPTS ABOUT YOU
KNOW HOW TO LOOK AT FILLING THE
GAPS AROUND THE LACK OF
PERMITTING LACK OF PROPER
INSTALLATION. INCLUDING
ADDITIONAL TRAINING ONLINE
PERMITTING OPTIONS ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT WHAT HAVE YOU. WE
ARE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES ON SOME
POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS TO OFFER. I
TO THE SENATOR I HAD THE
SPONSORS AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE TO REVIEW. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSION OF
IT AGAIN JUST WANTED BESIDES.
STRONGLY SUPPORT AND ENDORSE
PROPER PERMITTING AS WELL AS
INSTALLATION SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION BUT FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU THANK YOU. AND
HAVE YOU SUBMITTED THE IMMENSE
TO THE AUTHOR. BUT NOT AS OF YET
AND TERROR I WE'RE ACTUALLY
WORKING ON THEM NOW HOPE. TO THE
CENTER STAFF AS WELL AS THE
PROPONENTS HERE AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE. HERE IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS SO WILL BE IN TOUCH FOR
SURE. THAT'S OKAY THANK YOU YOUR
HONOR. GARCIA OKAY ARE THANK YOU
MISTER P. I. OF FOLKS WANT TO ON
THE PHONE LINE INTO ONE OF
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
MODERATOR. I WENT AGAIN PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TWO EIGHT. AND I
HAVE NO ONE IN KILL OKAY ALL
RIGHT- LET ME SINCE THERE JUST
THERE WAS THAT ONE FIFTIES. AT
THE INSTITUTE THE DON
REPRESENTED THAT IT RED
SUFFICIENT OKAY THE ITEM IS NOW
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS I GUESS SOME OF YOU
HEARD AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
EARLIER SO IT'S MOVED-
DISCUSSION QUESTIONS I KNOW YOU
GUYS WILL ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THE- SUPPORTING WITNESSES- LET'S
CALL. FOR A CLOSING STATEMENT A
YES AND I JUST WANNA CLARIFY MY
CLOTHES- THE COMMITTEE ACTUALLY
DID NOT THERE WERE SUGGESTIONS
BUT ACTUALLY NOT PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE SO
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT. I
REFERENCED A SUGGESTION ON PAGE
SIX BUT- THE COMMITTEE.
HOPEFULLY THE COMMIT THE MOTION.
HOPING TO MOTIONS JUST. YOU
PASSED PATTERSON BE REFERRED ME
OPERATIONS OKAY YEAH GOOD AS
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT AND
APPRECIATE THE INPUT- AND JUST
TO REMIND YOU ALL MEMBERS OF.
THIS IS JUST A REPORT SO DOESN'T
PRESUPPOSE ANY OUTCOME IN TERMS
OF. HOW DIGITAL TRACKING WOULD
WORK OR WHAT THE DATABASE WOULD
HAVE REQUIRED JUST TO. GET BACK
TO US AND LET US KNOW HOW TO
TIGHTEN UP THIS BIG GAP IN OUR
EACH FAX SYSTEM TO PLUG SOME
HOLES AND MAKE SOME PEOPLE-
THANK YOU AND RESPECT FASTER
I'VE- THANK YOU CENTER. OKAY
CONSULT WITH LOCAL ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR STERN THE MOTION IS DO
PASSPORT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN AYE. ALLEN AYE BATES.
DOLLY ALYAS SALAS. GONZALEZ.
VICE SKINNER. SKINNER AYE STERN
NICE AYE WHITE HOUSE. OKAY IT'S
FIVE US LEAVE IT UP FOR FOLKS TO
COME BACK ENTERTAIN MOTION THE
FOR THE CALENDAR THIS IS SO
MOVED BY THE CENTRE GONZALEZ
CONSOLE PLEASE COLOR ALL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS SB ELEVEN
FIFTY THREE. ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE
BATES. DELHI DALY AYE GONZALEZ.
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STERN HI WHITE HOUSE SKI BY
CASKEY HI JUST. AS A CORRECTION
- IT'S DUE BUT THAT THE MOTIONS
TO PASS BUT FIRST TO BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE I WAS EXCUSE ME
APOLOGIZE. TAKE THAT BACK OKAY
ALL RIGHT LET'S. NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I. OKAY LET'S LET'S
LIVE COSTS IF ARE CAUSING YOU
CAN HEAD BACK WE'VE GOT THIS
ROOM FOR FIVE MORE MINUTES AND-
SO PLEASE IF ANYONE CAN GET BACK
TO GO TO VOTE I UNDERSTAND I
THINK WE'VE CLOSED THE ROLE ON
ITEMS ONE FIVE AND SIX THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. SO WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE OTHER ONES. AND LET'S
START WITH ITEM TO SB TEN
THIRTEEN. I REMEMBER TO SB TEN
THIRTEEN BY SENATOR ATKINS THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE JURORS VOTED I'D VICE CHAIR
IS VOTED ON BY DALLY. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI. OKAY OF SIX THAT'S
SIX VOTERS CAN WE LEAD TO JUST
CAN YOU LET ME KNOW WHEN WE CAN
CLOSE OUR ALL YEAH CAN CLOSER ON
THAT OKAY GREAT WHAT THE DALLAS
HEARING IN FACT SO. ARE YOU OFF
THE BILL YEAH YES- OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA CLOSER ROLE
IN AS TEN THIRD. WITHOUT IT.
OKAY SO THAT'S OFF NOW LET'S DO
ITEM FOR S. S. B. ELEVEN OH ONE.
SB ELEVEN A ONE BY SENATOR
CABALLERO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE FIRST TO BE RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. JURORS
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTE VOTING
II. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I. STERN.
OKAY GREAT ALL RIGHT- SO WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN THAT YES OKAY
WE'VE DONE THE QUOTE CONTENT
COUNTERED NO ONE IS HERE OKAY SO
LET'S GO TO ITEM EIGHT THAT'S
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE. WESA SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE BY SENATOR
HUESO THE MOTIONS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
JURORS VOTING I'D- VICE CHAIR
NOT VOTING Y. CASKEY. GAME SO
WHAT THE WAY FOR HIM- LISTU ITEM
NINE SB TWELVE FIFTEEN BY NEWMAN
. THE BATTERY BILL SB TWELVE
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR NEWMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIRS VOTING I'D- BATES. DALLI
DALLI KNOWS SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN HI OKAY THROUGH WAY
FOR CENTER BATES S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY SILLY MONTHS BILL I THINK
EVERYONE HERE IS VOTE ON THAT
ONE- EXCEPT FOR BATES AND WHAT
CASKEY- CENTER SKINNER'S TEN TEN
AS WELL IS THAT RIGHT- FROM YOUR
STERN. IS MISSING ON THE SCANNER
YEAH SKINNER YEAH LET'S DO SB
ELEVEN- THE NIGHT ITEM ELEVEN SB
TEN TEN. SB TEN TEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING IS
THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING. STERN
STERN HIGHWAY CASKEY. OKAY I'M
ITEM TWELVE STERN WE JUST DID
THE GOVERNMENT'S ON THAT LET'S
DO ITEM THIRTEEN STERN FORTINO
FOR. I'M SORRY SUPPORTIVE FOR
THE FOURTEEN OF KOREA I AM
THIRTEEN. SB FOURTEEN OH FOUR BY
SENATOR STERN THE MOTIONS DO
PAST THAT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER SHARES
VOTING I'D VICE CHAIR BATES.
DALLI DALLI ISN'T NO SKINNER.
SKINNER NOT VOTING BY CAL SKI.
STILL HAS THREE OKAY. ALL RIGHT
SO I THINK I THINK- CENTER
SKINNER GONZALEZ AND STERN ARE
ALL SET IS THAT RIGHT. YOU HAVE
THE PROBLEM WE HAVE HERE IS THAT
WE'VE WE GET WE HAVE TO VACATE
IN A MINUTE. OKAY SO BATES IS AN
ELEVATOR OKAY SO WILL- I MAY
HAVE TO CLOSE ROLES I REALLY
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THIS BUT THIS IS
THE SITUATION WE'RE IN. SO IF
STAFFERS CENTERS. CASKEY IN
BATES AFTER PLEASE YOU KNOW WE
JUST HAVE TO. THIRTY FIVE. YEAH
ON THE WHAT TO NO FOUR ON THE
FOLKS YEAH. IS THAT. RIGHT HELLO
RESERVE I DON'T KNOW IF HE
WASN'T HERE COMMUNITIES. WHEN WE
WENT WE'RE GOING TO SACRIFICE
THAT'S WHERE HE WENT ON SO WHAT
. IS WAY DOWN YOU.
SENATE WILL CASKEY IS HERE- THE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSUMPTIONS CALL THE ROLL. ARE
YOU VOTE ON THE CONSECUTIVE OKAY
SUCH AS BASE RELATING FOR AN
ISLAND OKAY LET'S GO TO WEST SO
THIS BILL THIS IS THE TIRES ONE
TEARS RUNNING AYE THIS IS S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE NO BRIDGE IN
OPPOSITION. OR. WE WILL BE YEAH
. SB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR HUESO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST BE RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
SURE VOTING IGHT WHITE HOUSE SKI
. ALL RIGHT MY CASKEY I. OKAY
NOW SO THAT WHEN WE CAN CLOSE
THE ROLAND- OKAY S. B. TWELVE C.
I THINK WE ALREADY HAD WILL CAST
HIS VOTE RIGHT SO NOW TWELVE
THIRTY LEÓN SB TWELVE THIRTY
ITEM TEN. SB TWELVE THIRTY BY
SENATOR LIMÓN THE MOTIONS DO
PASSED THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I. WE'RE
CASKEY ARE CASKEY I. OKAY SO WE
CLOSER ON THAT AND BATES IS
ABILITY TO STILL ANYWHERE SO IF
IT'S OKAY- S. B. HELLO AT TEN
TEN THIS IS SKINNER ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SCANNERS SCANNERS BILL.
SB TEN TEN BY SENATOR SKINNER
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING IOWA
CASKEY. ARE CASKEY I. ANTICIPATE
WE CAN CLOSER ON THAT. OKAY
STEARNS SB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR
THIS IS THE BUILDING- EFFICIENT
ENERGY EFFICIENCY THE DOCUMENT
REPOSITORY RATIO. AND I AM
TWELVE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
STERN TO MOTIONS DO PASSED THE
FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
TERRACE VOTING I'D BATES. BATES
HI. WHITE HOUSE SCHEME MY COW
SKI I OKAY WE CAN CLOSER ON THAT
THAT BILL IS OUT. LET'S GO TO
THE OAKS BILL THIS ITEM THIRTEEN
SB FORTINO FOR STERN'S BILL SB
FOURTEEN OH FOUR BY SENATOR
STERN THE MOTIONS TO PASS
PREFERS TO BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER THAT YOU'RE VOTING
AYE. BATES BATES NO I CASCA. I
CAN I. OKAY CLOSER ON THAT ALL
RIGHT LET'S NOT HOLD A VOTE. YES
YOU KNOW FOR. I'M SORRY I'M SO
SORRY YES I DID SB FORTINO FOR
ITEM THIRTEEN FOURTEEN OH FOUR
SKINNER HI. OKAY TAKING A BOTH
AS WE GO OKAY LET'S GO BACK TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEMS
SEVEN CONSENT CALENDAR. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE- BATES. OKAY THANK
OTHER. I'M SORRY OKAY. YES HI
OKAY. I WILL CLOSER ON THE
CONSENT COUNTIES OR TWO MORE
BILLS AGO SO NINE INTENT THIS
IS- S. B. TWELVE FIFTEEN
NEWMAN'S BILL THE BATTER
RECYCLING. SB TWELVE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR NEWMAN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BATES. BATES NO. UNTIL CLOSER ON
THAT AT BILLS AN EFFORT TO GET
OUT OKAY ITEM TEN. SB TWELVE
THIRTY LIMÓN. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERS TO BE RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
BATES. OKAY VOTING GREAT OKAY. I
THINK WE'RE ALL SET WITH
EVERYBODY YEAH. MAYBE ARE WE ALL
SET. AT THE GROCERY YES OKAY
THANK YOU EVERYBODY APPRECIATED
THANKS ALL OF THE STAFF FOR THE
HARD WORK IS A TOUGH MEETING A
LOT OF TOUGH BILL SO WE WILL BE
BACK NEXT WEDNESDAY I SAME BAT
TIME SAME BAT PLACE ON THE
TWENTY SEVENTH OF FOR ANOTHER
ROBUST HEARING. WITH THAT OUR
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.